Da sind wir.
Trotz aller Detailprobleme sind wir tatsächlich wieder on air. Ha ha. Und wer ist on air?
Freak Show ist on air.
Hallo, willkommen. Die 195. Ausgabe rollt heran. Nicht ohne technische Probleme im Vorfeld, aber das gehört ja jetzt zum Programm.
Die nichts mit uns zu tun hatten.
Nein, noch nicht. Sondern mit Pimp my Mac.
Sondern mit Pimp my Mac weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau. Also das war auf jeden Fall der Auslöser. Schauen wir mal, wie es hier so läuft. Also hier ist Freak Show. Ich bin es, Tim und Roddy ist endlich mal wieder da. Hallo, Roddy.
Guten Abend.
Und wir haben einen Wiedergänger, nämlich den Ralf, Ralf Stockmann.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Und wir haben einen Neuzugang für diese Sendung. Genau, hallo, hi. Es geht noch weiter. Heiko, hallo. So, das heißt, mal zwei Gäste auf einmal. Der Rest ist irgendwie krank, abwesend, unpästlich, gelangweilt, keine Ahnung, hadert mit dem Leben oder tut welche anderen Sachen.
Ist im Land des Trump.
Oder ist im Land des Trump, genau. Herr Schrömpel, schöne Grüße. Falls du zuhörst, weiß ich ja nicht so ganz genau.
Der noch Geräte hat, an denen er überhaupt noch zuhören kann.
Ja, abgenommen worden sind. We don't know. Aber ich glaube, der kämpft sich dann schon durch. Insofern machen wir heute mal so ein bisschen... Ich weiß noch nicht so ganz genau, was wir eigentlich machen. Aber wir müssen ja erstmal, glaube ich... Du müsstest mir gerade irgendwas anzeigen, Ronja?
Ja, der Chat beschwert sich, dass es zu leise ist.
Der Chat beschwert sich, dass es zu leise ist. Jetzt haben wir das Problem, dass welcher Stream zu leise ist. Tja, ich wüsste jetzt auch gar nicht. Also, das kann ich halt hier... Also, wir haben ja Testweise, das kann man ja mal schon wieder hier vorwegnehmen. Testweise haben wir einen zweiten Streamer am Start. Das wird dann nämlich heute auch nochmal das Thema sein. Wir streamen ja sonst hier immer über Xenim. Das tun wir jetzt auch gerade. Und zusätzlich haben wir jetzt hier noch einen Stream über das neue Studio-Link-ONR-System. Das tut jetzt zunächst einmal für die Endkunden nicht sehr viel anderes. Deswegen bezeichne ich das jetzt mal als Test. Aber ich habe da leider keinerlei Überblick über Pegel und so weiter. Das kann ich jetzt nur raten. Der Master-Pegel sieht gut aus. Der Master-Pegel sieht eigentlich gut aus. Von daher kann ich da jetzt auch nicht viel dran drehen.
Es wird geschrieben, der Einspieler war leise. Jetzt ist es okay. Das glauben wir doch einfach mal.
Der Einspieler war leise. Der Einspieler ist, glaube ich, nicht durch die Dynamikanpassung gegangen vorher. So ist es. Die Details des Sendens und des Empfangs. Das wird uns heute auch beschäftigen. Aber irgendwas hat mich doch gerade unterbrochen. Ah ja, ich wollte Heiko vorstellen.
Mach das.
Oder? Das machen wir jetzt mal. Weil du warst ja noch nicht da. Und dann wollen wir doch vielleicht auch mal kurz alle wissen lassen, was du so treibst.
Ich mache mit Ralf Ultraschall seit drei Jahren, vier.
Also auf jeden Fall war er auch wirklich der erste im Team, der überhaupt dazugekommen ist. Und das, ja, müsste jetzt so dreieinhalb Jahre, so was mit dem Dreh.
Und über die Freak Show, ne?
Stimmt. Ich habe Freak Show gehört und da hat Ralf geweint. Dass er niemanden hat, der eben seinen C++-Programm programmiert. Und dann habe ich mich erbarmt und eigentlich habe ich erstmal nur gefragt, was er glaubt, wie viel Aufwand das wäre. Und dann hat er mich als GitHub gleich eingetragen und dann war das gegessen.
Das geht schon.
Das sind so Fragen, die beantwortet man einfach gar nicht.
Konnte ich halt auch nichts mehr sagen. Seitdem mache ich das halt, mehr oder weniger still.
Du trägst ja noch ganz solide dazu bei, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Allein jetzt beim letzten Release, Ultraschall 3.0, das hatte ich hier in der letzten Sendung schon mal kurz angedeutet, was da alles dabei ist. Da gehen wir natürlich auch nochmal drauf ein. Aber wenn ich mir die Check-Ins so anschaue...
Ja, ich hätte jetzt auch gedacht, eigentlich war Ralf das mit den meisten Features, aber die commits sprechen eine andere Sprache.
Du hast also einfach nur commited, was die anderen gemacht haben.
Oder einfach alles einzeln, jedes Wort.
Zeile für Zeile.
Ich habe da so ein Gitterplugin.
Micro-Committing.
Genau, mit Micro-Committing steigt man auf. Vielleicht sollte man das nicht so sehr nach commits sagen, sondern mehr nach Kilobyte. Eigentlich bräuchte man noch so eine Maßeinheit.
Da ist aber derjenige, der immer die Bilder, die Bilder Assets eincheckt, klar im Vorteil gegenüber denen, die nur Code schreiben.
Wenn man das UTF32 nehmen, ist das gleich viermal so viel.
Deswegen wollte ich es gerade auch hinterher schieben, man bräuchte eigentlich so eine Einheit für die Feature Effectiveness sozusagen. Also sozusagen, wie viel Bang ist hier pro Kilobyte eigentlich drin und dann in Abhängigkeit von Datentypen und so, wenn unsere guten AI-Overloads dann irgendwann mal auch unseren Code verstehen und wir eben ganz stark auch auf die Singularität zusegeln, dann können die sich das ja alles anschauen und sagen so, naja, hier, das ist ja nur so ein Mem aus Fortchand und so, für so ein Bild gibt es einfach mal gar keine Punkte, aber wenn der Code halt geile Scheiße macht, dann müsste man natürlich dann auch für Bugs einen entsprechenden Punktabzug dann auch wieder einführen. Das ist die Gamification des Programmierens.
Das klingt gut, aber das Problem wird sein, müssen wir vielleicht nicht das Thema vertiefen, aber die Singularität geht ja davon aus, dass wenn die AI schon so weit ist, dann hat die Menschheit noch ziemlich genau fünf Sekunden, um sich darüber zu freuen oder nicht zu freuen, weil dann der Point of No Return schon dermaßen überschritten ist. Also klar, die können sich dann irgendwie die nächsten Äonen noch über unseren Code lustig machen, aber wir sind dann da glaube ich nicht mehr wirklich in der Gleichung drin.
Ja und dich Ralf muss man eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen, weil du ja schon ein paar Mal da warst, machen wir aber trotzdem noch mal ganz kurz. Also du hast ja das mit dem ganzen Ultraschall mal losgetreten, eigentlich so als Videokanal. Wir erklären mal Podcasting und dann ist dir aufgefallen, es gibt eigentlich nicht genug zu erklären, muss man ja sozusagen noch mal ein paar Sachen dazu erfinden, damit wir auch noch Themen für weitere Sendungen einfallen. Ich kenne das irgendwo her. Ja und da hat sich ja noch einiges draus entwickelt. Also ich finde es eigentlich sehr schön, was wir jetzt eigentlich so über die letzten, was ist hier der ganze Zauber jetzt schon, fünf Jahre oder so?
Dass wir so generell so dieses Podcast-Dingens hier so...
Es fing so ein bisschen mit Opho-Nik fing es irgendwie an.
Ja.
Das war so der Kick-Off, wo mir dann auch selber so ein bisschen die Hutchnur geplatzt ist und ich gedacht habe so, ok, jetzt machen wir das mal hier mit der Software auch.
Würde ich sagen, in meiner Erinnerung eigentlich auch, Georg war der Erste, der gesagt hat, so wir machen jetzt mal selber und wir machen jetzt mal ordentlich.
Genau, nachdem ich ihm irgendwie zwei Jahre vorher in Wien mein Leid geklagt habe. Dieses Leid klagen scheint mir überhaupt eine sehr unterschätzte Antriebskraft zu sein im Universum. Also wenn man irgendwie, wenn man noch mehr rausholen könnte bei Leidklagen, vielleicht könnten wir damit auch endlich mal Raumschiffe zu fernen Planeten, die mehrere Lichtjahre entfernt sind, in our lifetime befördern. Weil dann einfach Lichtgeschwindigkeit nicht mehr so die große Rolle spielt.
Dann hast du mich jetzt gerade verloren.
Ja, aber Leidklagen scheint dir auch zu liegen, oder?
Als Antriebskraft?
Als Antriebsmotor, ja. Also ein Leidklagungsmotor. Wo dann einfach irgendjemand drinsitzt und die ganze Zeit einfach nur darüber klagt, wie unerträglich doch dieser Zustand ist, dass man sich jetzt nicht doch schneller bewegt, als man es ohnehin schon tut, woraufhin das Ganze dann eben stattfindet.
Douglas Adams ist tot, wir sollten ihn ruhen lassen, finde ich.
Die Bistromatik hat ja ganz anders funktioniert. Da ist ja das Ganze nur so randomisiert auf Basis der Gegebenheiten.
Leitklage Drive? Lightning-Klage-Drive?
Nein, es gab die Bistromatik. Die Bistromatik war ein Antrieb der sozusagen...
Und der Unwahrscheinlichkeits-Drive.
Ich glaube, an den kommen wir noch nicht ran. Der ist einfach unmittelbar. Also wenn wir sozusagen das Äquivalent für Softwareentwicklung, Unwahrscheinlichkeits-Drive haben, das ist dann wirklich die Wünsch-dir-was-Box. Man setzt sich dann einfach nur genug vor das System und wünscht sich das dann einfach.
Ja, also generell würde ich sagen, du hast da schon einen Punkt mit diesem, man muss auch irgendwie vernünftig nörgeln können über den schlechten, desolaten Zustand von irgendwas. Aber es braucht dann immer auch zwei Parteien, nämlich eine Partei, die vernünftig nörgeln kann und eine andere Partei, die das nicht sofort persönlich nimmt, sondern versucht auch zu kanalisieren und irgendwie so auf den Wahrheitskern hin mal abschläuft.
Ja, stimmt. Man braucht jemand, der das weiß. Genau, sehr schön gesagt. Nicht persönlich nehmen, sondern man muss sozusagen destillieren, was der eigentliche Faktor ist. Da hast du sozusagen mit Heiko deinen Äquivalent gefunden.
Das ist nochmal anders, die Beziehung. Die Beziehung mit dem Nörgeln versus den Nörgeln, das kann man ja sozusagen doch mal zuhören, habe ich gerade mit Malek. Das ist ein Konstrukt, was ich mir jetzt für die 3.0 ausgedacht habe. Das gibt nämlich jetzt im Ultraschall- Entwicklerland die Rolle eines Edeltesters. Ihr kennt das von der Tour de France, die Edelhelfer, die dann immer besonders herausgehoben sind, um den Champion irgendwie in den Windschatten reinzubringen. Und meine Theorie ist, dass es für die Testphase von Software gar nicht so hilfreich ist, irgendwie da eine Testgruppe von 10, 15 Leuten zu haben, von denen 14 denselben Bug irgendwie reporten, alle mehr oder weniger zuverlässig. Und man hat ihn aber selber schon gefunden und irgendwie bei den letzten Releases war es immer alles irgendwie ein bisschen unergiebig. Und das haben wir jetzt bei den letzten beiden jeweils schon ein bisschen anders gemacht. Da haben Heiko und ich eigentlich mehr oder weniger im Hintergrund schon so die Betas zusammengefrumelt und die dann exakt einem Beta-Tester immer gegeben. Und der ganze Rest im Slack war eigentlich so auf Dunkel geschaltet und wusste gar nicht, dass wir schon längst am Testen sind. Und das habe ich diese Release mit Malek gemacht von hier Teenagers Sex Beichte, hervorragender Podcast in dem bei. Wer zu Helge Schneiders Texas Ja sagt, kann dazu eigentlich nicht nein sagen. Das ist also der Helge Schneider der frühen Jahre. Kommt da wirklich gut durch in diesem Podcast, hört da mal rein. Und der besetzt also genau diesen Sweets-Pod zwischen, zum einen arbeitet er wirklich selber viel damit, das ist wichtig. Also er fährt halt wirklich so pro Woche zwei Sendungen und ist dann genervt, wenn Dinge nicht effizient genug sind. Und hat dann aber auch so diese Nörgeligkeit, die es braucht, um sich dann auch irgendwie so gegen so ein Ego wie mich durchzusetzen, der erstmal sagt so, ah, ist nicht so schlimm, funktioniert schon. Ja, doch ist schlimm, hier, ne, guck mal da, und da sind zwei Sekunden zu viel und so geht das auch nicht. Und der aber gleichzeitig dann eben doch so eine gewisse Konstruktivität mit sich bringt. Also ich plädiere dafür, wenn ihr Softwareentwicklung macht, sucht euch Edeltester, ja, und wechselt die auch. Also bei der nächsten Release braucht man gar nicht hoffen, ja, werden die anders besetzt. Ich glaube, das prägt dann auch so eine Release, mit wem man die intensiv getestet hat. Das kriegt also dann so einen gewissen wie bei Bands so, die Per Schmurte haben ein neues Album, suchen sich einen neuen Produzenten, dann klingt die Band auch ein bisschen anders, ja. Also ich glaube, die Betatester sind so ein bisschen auch so die Produzenten von Software.
Also ich würde dir den Begriff Powertester jetzt mal in den Raum schmeißen. Edelt klingt so ein bisschen, also das kann man ja dann nicht von sich selber behaupten, ja. Ja gut, aber gut kann ja sein, dass man den Verliehen bekommt, aber wenn ich jetzt gerade davon reden will, dass ich sozusagen auch in den letzten Wochen auch so eine ähnliche Funktion übernommen habe, wo ich auch so den ganzen Tag, weißt du, man steht so morgens auf, liest so im Slack so, ah, neue Beta hochgeladen, das und das und das, und dann erst mal in so ein, noch bevor der Kaffee wirkt, so testet man das erst mal alles durch und dann so brrrr, das geht nicht, das geht nicht, das muss anders sein, nicht schön genug, hier wird Platz verschwendet, weißt du, all so eine Sachen, das macht Spaß. Das ist auch eine Rolle, die ich sehr gut kenne, aber bei euch jetzt...
Da kann man verdächtig wenig von dir finden, die so wirklich ist.
Nee, nee, bei Ultraschall habe ich diese Rolle auch nicht übernommen.
Die hattest du mal vor zwei Jahren, würde ich sagen, da hattest du mal so ein halbes Jahr, wo du da sehr intensiv und direkt dran warst.
Na ja, ich meine, ich werde in dem Moment natürlich irgendwie im Kreis springen, wo er dann auch mal meine Feature-Requests angeht. Das sind ja immer alles so Features, die mir...
Natürlich, skip, skip, skip, skip. Naja, also, ist doch klar.
Insofern ist es etwas tragisch, als das nun gerade so eines deiner Wunsch-Features bei Heiko unten runtergefallen ist.
Vieles ist fast fertig.
Die verschiedenen Klassen von Kapitelmark.
Es ist nicht alles schlecht.
Nein, nein, also es ist ja auch viel gut und auch im Kleinen ändern sich halt Dinge. Ja, also wir fassen zusammen. Software-Entwicklung in so freien Kleinst-Communities unter Beobachtung, das kann eigentlich ganz gut funktionieren. Man braucht einfach so ein paar Posten, die müssen irgendwie besetzt sein und da gehören irgendwie so ein paar Wahnsinnige, die dann auch einfach immer in so einem Rush in der Lage sind. Einerseits diese Gruppe sowohl zu bilden, zu betreuen und zu entwickeln. Also allein dieses Persönlichkeiten finden und zusammenbringen und dann im Zweifelsfall halt auch entstehende soziale Spannungen und Schwankungen innerhalb dieses Teams irgendwie versuchen, elegant auszugleichen. Muss nicht immer ein Thema sein, aber ist auf jeden Fall auch mal ein Thema, was noch mit dazu kommt. Ja, und dann dieses, wie hast du das gerade genannt? Also dieses Dialogische zwischen Träumern und Realisatoren.
Ja.
Das kann ganz gut funktionieren.
Das ist letztendlich auch so die Rolle, die jetzt Heiko und ich so haben. Also in all meinen bisherigen Open Source-Projekten hatte ich immer irgendjemanden, der gesagt hat, du Ralf, das ist Quatsch, das machen wir jetzt ganz anders. Und das muss jemand sein, der das mit einer Autorität und einem Selbstverständnis mir gegenüber ausdruckt, dass ich dann so versag, okay, gut, wir machen es anders. Ja, und exakt das macht Heiko jetzt seit drei Jahren. Und das sieht man dann auch, denke ich, an der Stabilität, die das ganze Projekt dann insgesamt hat, dass es genau solche Leute auch braucht, die dann auch irgendwie so ein Feature-Zoo mal einfangen und sagen so, das ist nicht fertig, das kommt jetzt nicht rein, das kommt in den nächsten Release rein und das ist jetzt eine Bug-Fix-Release und keine Feature-Release mehr und so weiter und so fort. Das ist schon, also solche Tandem-Konstruktion, ich finde sowieso Tandem-Funktion. Aber auch da werde ich jetzt ein bisschen älter und erwachsener, also ich bin jetzt glaube ich zu Adrenal auch stärker in die Richtung gegangen, wir wollten eigentlich darüber viel später reden, aber egal, lieber nicht ganz so viele Sachen, aber die dafür extrem gut durchdesignen und durchkonzipieren, also wo ich mich zum Beispiel gerade so richtig fetisch-mäßig beschäftige, sind so Zero-Data-States. Das heißt, wie funktioniert irgendein Feature, wenn noch keine Daten da sind, sondern Leute das zum ersten Mal irgendwie anklicken oder starten oder ähnliches. Weil man als Entwickler immer so wenig auf dem Schirm hat, weil du immer sofort mit Testdaten loshantierst. Und dann läuft das immer alles super. Das ist aber leider nicht das, wie 99% der Leute so einer Software zum ersten Mal entgegentreten. So Sachen, die mich umtreiben, da besser zu werden.
Gut, jetzt haben wir schon viel über den heißen Brei herum geredet. Ich glaube, jetzt müssen wir es auch einfach direkt in den Fokus nehmen. Also wer bisher noch überhaupt nicht verstanden hat, wovon wir eigentlich reden und vielleicht auch meine Zusammenfassung in der letzten Sendung ignoriert hat, wir sprechen von Ultraschall. Und Ultraschall ist halt ein Projekt, das sich im Prinzip vor allem an Podcaster richtet. Von daher eine sehr fokussierte Zielgruppe.
Ja, also wir haben leichte Tendenzen in Richtung Radio, aber das ist noch total stiefmitteilig. Also 99,9% Podcasterinnen und Podcaster.
Aber naja.
Ich meine, reicht. Also wir haben jetzt irgendwie Downloads 700 von der 3.0er Version. Die ist jetzt seit zweieinhalb Wochen oder so was raus. 710. Etliche von denen haben mehrere Podcasts. Also was so an Marktdurchdringung und Marktzettigungen sind, da glaube ich schon ganz gut unterwegs. Außerdem meint es gerade eben so die Teamstimmung und soziale Sachen und sowas. Das ganze Ultraschall-Projekt war immer so ausgelegt, keiner von uns will berühmt werden, keiner von uns will reich werden, sondern wir haben alle sehr solide andere Jobs, meistens irgendwas mit Technik, TM, und nehmen das so als Ausgleichssport, quasi irgendwie um was Sinnvolles, Nützliches in die Welt zu setzen. Darum geben wir das mit einer gewissen Entspanntheit an. Und von daher hat man glaube ich in der letzten Sendung, als ich da auch schon mal drüber geredet, auch der USA-Markt oder sowas, ja, das wäre alles irgendwie sicherlich auch mal interessant. Auf Englisch ist es ja schon, aber da müsste man halt irgendwie so viel an Support und irgendwie Welteroberungsplan dahinter. Da habe ich im Moment irgendwie wieder Zeit, noch Lust, noch Laune zu. Und wenn man das irgendwie anders machen möchte, kann man das gerne tun, aber ich möchte, dass das ein schnuckeliges, entspanntes Projekt bleibt. Und mir ist dann da die Weltherrschaft einigermaßen egal, muss ich sagen. Von Podcaster, deutsche Podcasterinnen, super. Passt schon. Ich meine, es ist ja eh schön, dass ich das jetzt so als Familienvater noch so alles nebenbei machen kann. Da habe ich übrigens eine lustige Theorie. Da würde mich mal interessieren, ob ihr das auch so seht. Und zwar ein Freund von mir, Arbeitskollege, hat von einem Jahr Kind bekommen und war dann in Elternzeit zwei Monate. Und als er dann zurückkam, zeigte er mir freudestrahlend ein Stück Software, was er programmiert hat. Und das war gar nicht mal so unaufwendig. Das heißt also, das war von den digitalisierten Sammlungen unserer Stabi eine Visualisierung, Datenvisualisierung, wo also klar war, okay, das hat er nicht mal eben so an zwei Abenden gemacht, sondern da hat er sich mit irgendwie durch OAI-Schnittstellen, Stabi, Staatsbibliothek Berlin, das ist da, wo ich eigentlich arbeite, genau, danke, hat sich da also irgendwie durch die Interfaces gekämpft und irgendwie Daten bereinigt und visualisiert und sowas. Da dachte ich mir so, okay, David, seriously, du bist jetzt gerade Vater geworden, hattest du nicht irgendwie was Besseres zu tun dann abends, irgendwie so, sagen wir mal, schlafen oder Binge-Watchen von Serien oder was auch immer? Na ja, und jetzt bin ich selber Vater seit drei Monaten und was soll ich sagen? Das ist super! Also, ich hatte also wirklich, wenige Dinge in meinem Leben haben mich so entspannt, wie irgendwie dann so nachts um 12 hinsetzen und irgendwie Luacode für Ultraschall hacken, wenn irgendwie Frau und Kind fröhlich, friedlich im Bett schlafen. Und ich überleg seitdem, wo kommt das eigentlich her? Ich hab mal ein süßes Bild hier in Slack plumpsen lassen, wie also weite Teile dieser Release entstanden sind, wo ich also hier lustig Baby durch die Gegend wippe. Ich hab mich gefragt, woran liegt das eigentlich? Und ich glaube, dass Programmierung viel mit kleinen Säuglingen zu tun hat. Weil also, ihr kennt das, man macht sich irgendwie einen Plan und überlegt sich, wie das Ganze funktionieren soll bei der Programmierung. Und dann hackt man das so runter und dann funktioniert es halt nicht. Und dann findet man erstmal die offensichtlichen Fehler und dann merkt man, okay, hier stößt man irgendwie gegen das Framework und so weiter. Und irgendwann läuft das dann und alles ist gut. Und ich finde, das ist ein bisschen ähnlich, wie irgendwie so mit Säuglingen. Die funktionieren halt auch erstmal nicht so, wie man das gerne hätte, sondern die machen immer irgendwie was anderes. Man versucht mal rauszukriegen, was da schief läuft, dann probiert das eine und probiert das andere. Und der Unterschied ist aber, beim Programmieren, am Ende gibt es dann eben doch in den allermeisten Fällen ein Happy End. Und das ist das, was mir gerade jetzt irgendwie bei meinem Kleinen... Du meinst bei Kindern nicht?... bleibt einem das doch häufig verwehrt, finde ich. Da hast du halt keine Errorcodes. Und du hast keine Idee, die dir sagt, was da genau eigentlich gerade schief läuft. Du hast also alle Parameter durch, Windeln sind okay, er ist eigentlich genug entspannt und so weiter. Warum zum Teufel schreit der jetzt eigentlich? Du kannst es einfach nicht lösen. Ich glaube, Programmieren hat so einen therapeutischen Effekt, weil es ähnlich ist, aber in so einer sehr rationalen und letztendlich zum Guten führenden Situation. Also ich kann das empfehlen da draußen, ihr Väter und Mütter, wenn ihr nachts das Kind doch im Bett habt, versucht es mal mit Programmieren, wäre gut.
Also bei mir funktioniert Programmieren unheimlich gut, wenn ich aus irgendeinem Grund nicht schlafen kann und irgendwelche Gedanken bei mir im Kopf sich drehen und ich habe eine bestimmte Punktmarke, ne, das wird nichts mehr, dann setze ich mich hin, schreibe irgendwie zwei Stunden Quot und dann ist es wieder gut.
Ich habe das Gefühl, bei mir geht das am besten, wenn ich wütend bin, aber so richtig.
Was, Quot schreiben? All in caps oder wie?
Vielleicht kriegt man einen Tunnelblick und möchte jemanden...
Oh, dann könnte ich ja vielleicht doch noch beitragen zu dem Projekt. Wütend, interessant. Naja, jeder kompensiert glaube ich irgendwas, oder man kann zumindest manche Sachen unter Umständen ganz gut damit kompensieren. Also irgendwas kompensiert man glaube ich sowieso, wenn man sich in solche Open Source-Projekte reinhaut. Aber es ist ganz interessant, diese ganzen Konstellationen, über die wir jetzt gesprochen haben, mit so verteilten Rollen, mit so... Ich weiß nicht, haben wir schon gute Namen dafür gefunden. Es gibt da Moderatoren, es gibt da irgendwie Rampensäue, es gibt da Kommunikatoren. Ja, es ist aber irgendwie ein bisschen... Vielleicht übersehe ich jetzt irgendwas, aber so die klassischen Open Source-Projekte waren ja meistens immer programmer-driven. Und dann nicht selten auch in einer einzigen Person beheimatet. Und dann dauert das ein paar Jahre und dann kommen dann vielleicht mal so zwei, drei dazu und in der dann mal vom Bus überfahren wird, dann verteilt sich das vielleicht noch auf mehr Leute. Aber in gewisser Hinsicht finde ich das deutlich unterhaltsamer, da einfach auch so eine bunte Rollenverteilung zu haben. Gerade so mit Leuten, die auch immer in der Lage sind, so ein bisschen Welle nach außen zu machen. Dann aber auch so einen technischeren Team, einerseits ein bisschen rückenfrei zu halten, auch Sachen abzunehmen, die sie vielleicht nicht so gut können. Ist ja bei Podlove zum Beispiel auch nicht so sehr viel anders in der ganzen Konstellation.
Nicht zuletzt die klassische Support-Schiene einfach. Also irgendjemand Dinge erklären, auf Rückfragen irgendwo, Sendegate oder sowas antworten. Das muss kein Programmierer sein.
Genau, weil das natürlich auch mal so ein bisschen frustrierend ist, wenn dann irgendwie zu viel Support anfällt, man sich aber eigentlich so die ganze Zeit auf das Schaffen konzentrieren möchte.
Obwohl das so 3.0 witzig war, da haben wir teilweise auf eine Frage zu dritt geantwortet, also so gleichzeitig im Sendegate.
Na gut, das war wahrscheinlich die Aufregung.
Ja, wir haben halt kein hochprofessionelles Support-Ticket-System im Hintergrund laufen.
Ich kenne das von der Firma, wo ich mal gearbeitet habe, wo wir irgendwie nur zu viert waren, samt First-Level-Supporter, und da ist es halt so, dass du dann so Sachen, die oft aufpoppen, auch irgendwie dann fixen willst. Also willst halt nicht, dass die Leute damit ein Problem haben, weil du dann so viel Support machen musst.
Ja, und das hat auch irgendwie...
Und das bekommt dann direkt Priorisierung irgendwie.
Der hat aber auch ganz viel mit Adrenalin zu tun. Also wenn du gerade was released hast, dann bist du sowieso, ich kann das mal hinterher sagen, bist an der Decke, ja, und...
Dann lässt das auf die User los.
Ich mache das, ja. Ralf nicht.
Ich will das jetzt nicht so sehr überhöhen, aber verdienst so ein Modell irgendwie mal einen anderen Namen? Also, naja, mit Open Source oder so finde ich, ist das irgendwie nicht ausreichend beschrieben.
Na ja, aber ich meine, dass du Software-Teams mit verteilten Rollen hast, ist ja nun irgendwie doch eher so tendenziell ein Alterhut. Also, du meinst, das Originelle ist, sowas verstärkt im Open Source-Umfeld zu haben, so. Weil also in klassischen Firmen hast du natürlich irgendwie die Designer und du hast die Qualitätskontrolle und du hast irgendwie die Architekten, die selber keinen Code mehr anrühren.
Open Source ist ein Aspekt. Dann auch, dass die Zielgruppe selber eine andere, also, etwas weniger technischere Zielgruppe ist. Also wo es wirklich um Vereinfachungen, User Interfaces und so weiter geht, was ja einfach so eine traditionelle Schwäche eigentlich von Open Source ist. Also du hast eigentlich bei Open Source-Projekten, das hat halt über lange, lange Zeit eigentlich nur wirklich gut funktioniert, wo Techniker für Techniker was gemacht haben. Und solange es darum ging...
Ja, aber auch da teilweise nicht.
Ja, teilweise auch nicht, aber wenn es überhaupt funktioniert hat, dann erst mal da. Und das war ja auch in Ordnung, weil eigentlich die ganze Open Source-Welt in den letzten 20 Jahren im Wesentlichen damit beschäftigt war, ein Betriebssystem zu bauen. Bloß irgendwann will es halt auch mal mehr. Und wenn man sich dann so Sachen anschaut, wie Open Office und so, da wurde es dann schon schwieriger. Gut, das könnte man natürlich einzelnen sagen, Erfolgsgeschichte, nicht-Erfolgsgeschichte, ja, ist Netscape, Navigator, also ist Mozilla da ein gutes Beispiel, schlechtes Beispiel. Also gibt es sicherlich von beiden etwas, aber der Großteil und so die primäre Wahrnehmung und da, wo auch so Open Source oder freie Softwareentwicklung so ein bisschen seine Nahrung herbezieht, ist eben dieses Ganze, wir kreieren erstmal ein technisches System. Aber solche Anwendungen, so Endanwendungen, da ist es schwierig. GIMP ist halt auch so ein Projekt, ist auch so ein Klassiker, ja, was auch sehr, auch eine sehr technische Zielgruppe sozusagen hat. Gut, das gilt natürlich für Ultraschall in gewisser Hinsicht auch, für Podlove auch. Von daher kann man das jetzt auch nicht so ganz wegschieben, aber ist halt selten.
Also irgendwo habe ich mal gelesen, da meinte jemand bei Open Source, ist halt die Currency, das Geld, in dem bezahlt wird, ist Code. Das heißt, die Leute, die Code schreiben, haben quasi die finanzielle Macht, um das Projekt weiter zu treiben. Und nicht die Leute, die dann dem Anwender gegenüber sitzen, die UI machen, die UX machen und so weiter. Und das merkst du halt an vielen Ecken und Enden. Selbst Open-Source- Tools, die nur von Programmierern benutzt werden und nur Kommandozeile sind, haben teilweise ganz fürchterliche Kommandozeilen-User-Interfaces. Schau dir Git an zum Beispiel. Es ist wirklich schlimm, was Git für ein rotziges Kommandozeilen-Interface hat. Also ich hoffe seit Jahren, dass da mal jemand einen Rapper drum baut, der irgendwie ein brauchbares Interface liefert.
Aber es passiert ja chronisch immer nicht. Und ich finde, die interessante Frage ist schon, warum passiert das eigentlich in Open Source Projekten nicht? Nun könnte man irgendwie polemisch sagen, naja Gott, Microsoft kriegt bis heute keine Icons designt, ja, und irgendwie so, Windows ist irgendwie total inconsistent, so, die müssten doch nur mal genug Geld drauf werfen. Aber diese Frage mit GUI und User Experience bei Open Source, das bleibt mich selbst fest.
Microsoft ist schon zu groß.
Außerdem kannst du ausgehen, dass alles, was bei denen auf dem Bildschirm kommt, durch Usability Labs gelaufen ist.
Na ja, gut, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, vor 15 Jahren habe ich genau diese Frage schon gestellt. Dadurch mein erstes Open Source-Projekt, Stud LP war das, im E-Learning-Bereich. Und da waren wir auch eine Menge Programmierer. Und ich habe immer gesagt, wir müssen mal eigentlich Geld für Designer ausgeben. Weil ich kann ein bisschen was malen und kann ein bisschen was irgendwie Oberflächen gestalten. Aber man sieht einfach, es ist nicht professionell. Wir brauchen mal Designer. Wir müssen irgendwie ein bisschen Geld akquirieren. Und dann fragte mich Stefan Suchi, das war quasi der Heiko Panjas von Stud LP damals, meinte immer, ja, wieso genau? Ja, warum ist es eigentlich so, dass bei Open Source die Programmierer immer umsonst mitmachen und aus Motivation und die ganzen Designer immer alle abwesend sind? Wieso machen die nicht auch mal beim Open Source Projekt mit? Und ich muss sagen, im Kern hat er da einen Punkt. Also ich kann natürlich verstehen, ja, als Designer hast du es vielleicht auf dem Arbeitsmarkt noch irgendwie schwerer als irgendwie Coder, so irgendwie Sachen zu finden, gerade weil du viele Freelancer hast und irgendwie wenig Fest-Einstellungen und sowas und sowieso guckst, wo ist der nächste Auftrag und dann nebenbei noch irgendwie sowas pro bono zu machen, ist vielleicht nicht immer so ganz einfach, aber generell würde ich sagen, so bei den Designern und UX-Expertinnen so, dass die wirklich was pro bono machen, ist schon signifikant seltener als bei Programmierern. Das ist so eine Kultur, dass wir eigentlich schön da mal irgendwie einen Change hinzukriegen oder zu sagen, alle kriegen Geld, ja, wobei ich ja sowieso gegen Geld bin.
Wobei man natürlich auch sagen muss, bei Programmierern ist meistens halt der Lernfaktor doch oft ein Argument. Also man engagiert sich halt auch, weil man ja mit den technischen Herausforderungen in der Regel auch immer irgendwie Neuland beschreitet. Und in dem Moment, wo es tatsächlich nur noch um Runterkoden von Sachen, die man schon tausendmal gemacht hat, dann laufen sie die auch relativ schnell weg. Also man muss ja sozusagen auch den Inhalt vergleichsweise spannend halten und es zeichnet in gewisser Hinsicht Programmierer auch wieder aus, wenn sie da nicht gleich davonlaufen, nur wenn es gerade mal langweilig wird. Also wo es nicht jetzt irgendwie ein neuer Algorithm, wo es noch nie gemacht ist, oder Technologie, mit der ich noch nie gearbeitet habe, neue Programmiersprache, all diese ganzen Reize, die da kommen, das ist natürlich jetzt in der Grafik schwierig. Wobei es gibt dann diesen schönen Zwischenbereich, User X, wie das so schön heißt, die User Experience, so diese Schnittmenge zwischen wie sieht es aus und wie fasst es sich an und warum und so.
Also, ich würde dir fast massiv widersprechen, weil also die erfolgreichste Firma der Welt ist nun mal die, die sich signifikant am meisten Gedanken um User Interfaces macht. Ob es jetzt irgendwie Peak Apple ist oder nicht, egal.
Du hast jetzt von Gestaltern gesprochen.
Weil sich auch Dinge erfinden. Also ich glaube, auch im Bereich der Gestaltung ist einfach diese Erkenntnis, dass das, womit wir gerade arbeiten, eigentlich Schrott ist und man ganz andere Ansätze finden muss. Das kann genauso spannend sein, wie sich irgendwie in eine neue Coding-Technologie oder Algorithmen reinzufuchsen. Das müssen nur irgendwie dann Gestalter auch und UX-Designer für sich mal akzeptieren. Klingt jetzt sicherlich ein wenig selbstherrlich, aber ich bin extrem stolz auf meinen doofen Color-Picker. Das ist das geilste Stück Software in Sachen User Experience, was ich bisher erfunden gebaut habe. Das hat dermaßen clevere Detailfunktion und du hast eigentlich nichts an User Interface dafür. Kein Wort, das es erklärt, kein Schalter, wo du irgendwas umschalten kannst. Und es macht trotzdem eigentlich immer in jedem Moment genau das Richtige, meiner Meinung nach. Das sagst du in meinem Screencast. Normalerweise würde ich mir das eigentlich patentieren lassen, das, was ich da irgendwie gemacht habe. Ich glaube, das ist der heilige Gral für Color-Zuweisungen von Elementen, den ich da habe. Ganz ernsthaft. Schaut es euch an, das ist awesome. Ich glaube, es gibt ganz viele solcher Sachen. Das heißt also, wo wir sagen, XY muss sich so und so bedienen. Aber warum muss das so sein? Kann man das nicht völlig neu denken? Also, dass irgendwie im Design, in Sachen User-Interface, alles schon irgendwie durchdekliniert ist, das halte ich für ein komplettes Gerücht. Guck dir doch alleine irgendwie so iPods an damals, wo Apple gesagt hat, wir machen jetzt mal ein Clickwheel. Das war natürlich irgendwie neu und originell. Oder halt das iPhone. Ja, es gab schon irgendwie was mit Touch, aber es wurde dann völlig radikal neu einfach mal uminterpretiert. Das passiert eigentlich relativ regelmäßig. Warum sollten die Designer auf sowas nicht Bock haben?
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass sie da nicht auch Bock drauf haben könnten. Aber es ist eben noch nicht so eine Selbstverständlichkeit und es mag auch was damit zu tun haben, dass die Arbeit von Programmierern an der Stelle auch schon sehr viel mehr Anerkennung erfährt. In jedem solcher Spiele hast du natürlich auch immer noch mal so eine hausinterne Währung. In der du sozusagen auch bezahlt wirst, obwohl du halt eigentlich nicht mit Geld bezahlt. Vielleicht auch, aber in der Regel halt nicht. Das ist immer die Frage, wie viel Anerkennung kannst du dafür sozusagen auch bekommen? Und vielleicht sind eben die gestalterischen Herausforderungen beim Softwareentwickeln entweder sind sie nicht so hoch, oder werden nur noch nicht so gesehen, oder die Gestalter sehen selber noch nicht, dass das so sein kann. Auch glaube ich, so ein ähnliches Problem mit Fotografen, die so macht doch mal Fotos und frei und und irgendwie, keine Ahnung, packt was in die Wikipedia und macht darüber sozusagen die Einnahmen.
Ich würde es sogar anders sagen. Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass viele Gestalter, viele Designer bei Software halt das Problem haben, dass sie halt gerne gestalten und designen, eine User Experience zu designen und dass das Design eigentlich ein Mittel zum Zweck ist und nicht selbst Zweck. Also immer dann, wenn der Designer sein Design macht, um ganz tolles Design zu sein, dann ist es von der Software-Seite her meistens halt auch Müll. ein UX-Design zu machen und vor allen Dingen das in User Tests dann zu testen und zu gucken, ob das, was man sich überlegt hat, tatsächlich funktioniert. Das ist echt noch mal ein Schritt weiter. Und dass da Open Source nicht mithalten kann, weil da keiner sitzt, der irgendwie User-Testing-Labs betreibt, außer jetzt vielleicht Mozilla und irgendwie drei andere, ist irgendwie völlig klar. Und natürlich ist es auch so, lad dir zehn User ein, dann hast du 12 Meinungen, wie es jetzt richtig zu sein hat.
Ja, Kai schreibt ja gerade was Schönes hier im Chat. Es ist auch schon irgendwie so ein bisschen so eine Kulturkluft. Also ich lese mir vor, wenn Designer sagen, ich habe hier einen Entwurf gemacht, setz den mal um, wird er von Programmierern ausgelacht. Wenn Programmierer sagen, wir haben hier was gefrickelt, mach mal hübsch, kommt das zurück. Das ist schon der Punkt. Das habe ich in der Tat bei mir auch täglich auch verarbeitet. Ich hatte auch in Göttingen relativ häufig die Situation, dass die Programmierer sich aufregen, dass irgendjemand, was im Photoshop malt, was überhaupt gar nicht in HTML auch nur ansatzweise realisierbar ist, um jetzt bei Webdesign zu bleiben, und dass andersrum halt die Designer sich, finde ich, auch völlig zurecht aufregen, wenn sie immer reduziert werden in der Rolle auf diejenigen, die am Ende ein bisschen Farbe drüber kippen. Und nicht von vornherein in so einen UX-Prozess wirklich eingebunden sind, im Sinne von, wie soll die Software eigentlich wirklich funktionieren? Da sollten die Designer möglichst früh mit rein. Aber ja, also ich glaube, Open Source-Projekte wären gut beraten, das Thema mal für sich intern zu diskutieren.
Noch ein weiterer Gedanke, und ich will sie auch nicht gleich mal vorwegschieben, bevor das wieder falsch verstanden wird, geht mir jetzt überhaupt nicht hier darum, irgendwas da zu dissen. Es sind mehr so Beobachtungen. Und ich glaube, in dieser ganzen Softwarewelt, in der wir jetzt gerade leben, wir haben ja hier so Hobbys, Hobbys, die sich um Programmierung drehen, oder um Systementwicklung. Wir wollen lebendige Systeme bauen, die sich in technischen Geräten und Umgebungen machen. Das ist ein bisschen was anderes, als sich auf ein Skatabend zu treffen oder gemeinsam ins Stadion zu gehen. Es ist ein ähnliches Hobby, und es gibt auch ähnliche soziale Strukturen, die daraus so erwachsen, aber es ist halt irgendwie auch schon so ein bisschen arbeitsähnlich, aber soll halt eigentlich genau diesen negativen Aspekt, den Arbeit meistens hat, an der Stelle eben nicht haben. Also es ist schon mal neu und hat viel technische Komplexität und ist von daher vielleicht auch einfach einer oder vielen Gruppen der Gesellschaft so noch überhaupt gar nicht ins Blut gegangen. Das ist halt was, was aus der Programmierung, aus der Systementwicklung herauskommt, und es dauert einfach eine Weile, bis man dann eben andere kreative Berufe, die vielleicht noch gar nicht so geschneit haben, infiziert haben, weil die auch wiederum, und das ist ja auch so ein Generationenproblem, was wir haben, auch ein Businesskulturproblem, was wir immer wieder sehen. Und das ist jetzt der Punkt, wo ich meine, nicht falsch verstehen, weil die Programmierenden noch nicht gecheckt haben. Und zwar nicht so, können nicht programmieren, das ist nicht der Punkt, sondern einfach die ganzen Dynamiken und Mechaniken und Feinheiten, die man so auf einmal sieht, betrachtet und lebt, wenn man Software macht. Dieses Ganze, wie verhält sich ein Computer, wie ist dieses Interaktionsspiel zwischen Menschen und Computern, Fehlerverhalten und all diese ganzen Sachen, das erfordert eine gewisse Erfahrung, die man natürlich als Programmierer mehr oder weniger sofort hat. Auch so als Power-User, der, was weiß ich, seit fünf Jahren vorm Rechner sitzt und sich schon durch alles mal durchgeklickt hat. Und diese ganzen anderen kreativen Berufe, deren Werk und Arbeit und kreative Leistung sehr wohl dazu beitragen könnte, ist da halt einfach noch nicht so reingeschwappt. Sodass das auch noch eine gewisse Zeit dauert, bis das dann zusammenwächst. Musiker sind ja zum Beispiel auch so eine Gruppe, die da so schwer reißt.
Ich würde das anders sehen. Der Programmierer ist halt der, der einfach nur den Text schreibt. Das ist, wenn ich in den Laden gehe und mir so ein Reclam-Heft von irgendeinem Drama kaufe, dann kann ich mir das durchlesen, aber da habe ich nicht allzu viel davon. Eine echte UX ist halt Show-Business. Das ist halt wirklich auf die Gefühle des Users eingehen. Wie empfindet er die Benutzung des Programms? Wir alle ärgern uns über Programme, die nicht so gehen, wie sie sollen. Das ist eine sehr emotionale Sache. Und genau diese User Experience zu designen, sodass das Benutzen eines Programmes eine emotionale Sache ist, und vor allen Dingen eine positive emotionale Sache ist, ist eine sehr schwierige Disziplin. Also hinterher den Kram in Code gießen, würde ich sagen, ist 30 Prozent der Arbeit. Aber sich vorher überlegen, wie ist denn die eigentliche gesamte Interaktion des Users mit dem, was er da interagieren soll, ist, also halte ich für, sehr, sehr schwierig. Und die meisten Open Source Projekte haben wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal begriffen, dass sie sowas tun müssen. Deswegen, sie schreiben halt einfach nur Code. Das ist halt das Reclam-Heft, was du dir aus dem Buchladen holst. Aber eben nicht der große Abend mit Bühne und mit Licht und mit Ton und mit allem drum und dran.
Finde ich einen ganz schönen Vergleich. Also, ja, ich würde sagen, Software kann auch Charakter haben. Und vielleicht muss Software auch eine Haltung haben.
Ja, muss sie, muss sie.
Obwohl ich mich da frage, ob man das allgemein so sagen kann. Also, diesen Eindruck, dass Software Charakter hat oder einen abholt, ästhetisch. Das zu formalisieren, stelle ich mir unmöglich vorher. Das geht nicht. Dass man dann vielleicht den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner nimmt und sagt, ich mache hier wie alle.
Ich würde das auch gar nicht formalisieren wollen.
Na ja, du musst ja irgendwann eine Form haben, wo du dann programmierst. Obwohl ich den Brief ja dann auch irgendwie hier durch Entwickler, Softwareentwickler setzen würde. Du musst ja irgendwie eine gewisse Struktur bringen, dass der das umsetzt. Du musst ja ein bisschen Regeln ein. Das meine ich mit formalisieren.
Ja, aber zu so einem UX-Design gehört halt nicht nur, mach das so, dass es so aussieht, oder mach das so, dass das passiert, wenn ich da drauf drücke, sondern das Design ist halt auch die Frage, wie erreiche ich, dass der User das, was er tun will, auch tatsächlich tun kann. Da sind diese ganzen Farben, Formen und was passiert, wenn ich einen Button drücke, halt einfach erstmal nebensächlich. Sondern man muss halt einen Schritt früher überlegen, was will der User erreichen. Manchmal ist man ja auch da schon irgendwie auf dem Holzweg, weil die Leute was ganz anderes erreichen wollen. Und dann halt die Frage, wie erreicht der User das mit möglichst wenig Widerstand, weil er sich über Dinge wundert, die passieren, die er sich nicht erklären kann.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Prämissen so stimmen.
Ich kann jedem nur empfehlen, mal einen User-Test sich anzugucken von einer Software, von der man denkt, das ist ganz einfach und das funktioniert doch einfach.
Und dann setzt man sich hinter die Glasscheibe und guckt dann sehr schnell, sehr schrecklich.
Ob das jetzt nicht so... Ein Beispiel, also wenn ich... Ich setze mich vor dem Computer, will schnell was machen, habe keine Zeit, will irgendeine Datei löschen, wird gefragt, willst du wirklich? Und natürlich, was soll die blöde Frage, ja? Aber es gibt aber auch drei Fälle in deinem Leben, wo du gesagt hast, danke, der Nachfrage, ja, uff. Und der Mechanismus, der aus dem UI kommt, oder UX kommt, ist dasselbe.
Ja, aber das ist ein gutes Beispiel, weil nämlich dieser Nachfrage-Dialog, willst du wirklich, ist total sinnlos. Natürlich willst du...
Nein, das geht ja, das geht, das ist mittlerweile in den Beliefkanon eingegangen, das kann man nicht.
Nein, ihr müsst so sagen, es gibt die richtigen Themen, die machen den Scheiß immer noch, aber nein, das will man nicht. Wozu sagst du, löschen? Du sagst löschen.
Einer redet, das ist das Allerwichtigste, die richtige Lösung in Sachen UX für dieses Problem ist der Papierkorb.
Genau, wollte ich gerade sagen.
Du willst nicht bei jeder Aktion nachfragen, wolltest du das wirklich, sondern du willst eine vernünftige Ando-Funktion, die eine vernünftige Metapher hat und mit der die Leute vorarbeiten.
Und vor allem, du willst keinen modalen Dialog. Modale Dialoge sind From Hell und Windows. Aber du willst, wenn du ein Problem nicht ohne einen modalen Dialog lösen kannst...
Heiko streichelt sein Windows Notebook.
Wenn du ein Problem nicht ohne einen modalen Dialog lösen kannst, dann werde... weiß ich nicht.
Grund?
Grund, weil modale Dialoge sind ein No-Go.
Die Menschen sind kriegerisch, weil sie kriegerisch sind.
Nein.
Aber nochmal zum Papier.
Weil du den User dazu zwingst, eine Entscheidung zu treffen, die er eventuell nicht treffen kann. Du zwingst ihn dazu, einen Text zu lesen, den er eventuell nicht versteht. Und du gewöhnst ihm an, einfach nur automatisch auf OK zu drücken. Und damit ist der modale Dialog in seiner gesamten Wirkung sowieso sinnlos. Und alles, was du gemacht hast, ist ein weiterer Schritt einführen, der niemandem etwas bringt.
Aber zum Papierkorb, da hast du wieder dasselbe Problem. Rettet dir 99% der Fälle den Arsch, aber in dem 1% willst du gerade ein Video, an dem du 3 Stunden rumgeschnitten hast, speichern. Und das ist deine Platte voll, weil du den Papierkorb nicht mehr gemacht hast.
Ja, gut.
Aber das sind dann so Edge-Cases. Also man kann auch nicht alles...
Ja, aber auch die Ansicht, was ein Edge-Case ist, ändert sich mit jedem Bier.
Ja, es gibt auch durchaus Momente, wo ein Modaler-Dialog sehr wohl angemessen ist, weil es schlicht und ergreifend keine anderen Optionen gibt. Also zum Beispiel während einer Installation. Da gibt es dann sozusagen gar nichts, was du theoretisch nebenbei auch noch machen kannst.
Ja gut, eine Installation ist... Also wenn ich ein Betriebssystem installiere, dann ist die Tätigkeit als solche modal, weil du auf dem gleichen Betriebssystem nichts...
Ja, aber es gibt halt modale Schritte, nur meistens halt nicht.
Ja, meistens nicht.
Also ich überlege gerade, wo wir jetzt in Ultraschall modale Dialoge drin haben. Ich habe in der Tat mutwillig einen in die 2.0 eingebaut, nämlich wenn eine Aufnahme läuft und man die Space-Taste oder Return-Taste drückt. Das sind nämlich Funktionen, die normalerweise dann die Aufnahme stoppen. Und wenn aber irgendjemand gleichzeitig anfängt, Show Notes zu schreiben oder im Web zu surfen oder sowas, und er hat zufällig mal gerade den Fokus im Reaper-Fenster und hat Space gedrückt und die Aufnahme ist gestoppt, hm, nicht so eine richtig gute Idee. Und das war genau einer der Momente, wo ich sagte, okay, das fangen wir ab und sagen, oh, hier läuft gerade eine Aufnahme, aber auch nur dann kommt es, sonst natürlich nicht, bist du dir da jetzt wirklich sicher, dass du diese Aufnahme hier stoppen möchtest. Also es gibt schon so ein paar Situationen, in denen die, glaube ich, ganz gerechtfertigt sind.
Wenn man die Leertaste nicht sowieso abschalten kann, aber das scheint ja nicht zu gehen.
Das war an der Stelle dann nicht wirklich eine Option, ja.
Das ist eine sehr sinnvolle...
Nein, es ist natürlich nichts, es ist absolut. Modale Dialoge haben an bestimmten Stellen natürlich schon Sinn, aber weniger ist mehr.
Haben wir verstanden. Du findest es furchtbar, da rennst du bei mir auch offene Türen ein. Noch geiler sind ja modale Dialoge mit Ja-Nein als Buttons. Das hat man hier auch, glaube ich, schon fünfmal durchgekaut in den letzten paar Jahren. Das kann man, glaube ich, gar nicht wiederholen. Das hat mittlerweile, glaube ich, auch sogar...
Wenn sie Ja drücken, dann passiert Folgendes. Wenn sie Nein drücken, passiert Folgendes.
Das wäre ja schon mal gut erklärt, ne? Wollen wir dann doch vielleicht noch mal kurz zur Ultraschall als solchen kommen? Sonst ist der Primetime-Slot dann auch irgendwann mal weg.
Genau. Wir haben nämlich überhaupt noch eine Agenda, warum wir überhaupt hier sind. Und das ganze Fluten hier.
Na, ihr seid hier, um die Leute zu informieren und zu unterhalten.
Ach so. Gut.
Das ist doch eine Entertainment-Sendung hier.
Nein, also wir haben jetzt lange und ausgiebig darauf hingearbeitet, warum das so total viel Spaß macht, in Open Source-Projekten zu arbeiten. Insbesondere in unserem Jahr.
Ich kann mir nichts anderes mehr vorschweren, ehrlich gesagt.
Es ist in der Tat so, dass wir nämlich mal wieder, weil wir in den letzten Freak Shows immer so viel Erfolg damit hatten, das meine ich jetzt allgemein ironiefrei, wie gesagt, die lebenden Beweise sitzen hier gerade, würden wir mal wieder eine kleine Aktion starten, nämlich einen Call zum Mitmachen. Ich habe gerade eben mal eine URL in den Slack fallen lassen, und das wird ihr natürlich auch in den Show Notes finden. Das ist eine frisch auf unserer schönen Webseite eingerichtete Seite, wo man sich informieren kann, was wir eigentlich gerade suchen. Und das mag jetzt ein bisschen undankbar klingen, aber wir suchen auch schon so ziemlich genau diese Position. Also sprich, wir brauchen jetzt nicht noch fünf Beta-Tester und nicht noch fünf Leute, die schon immer mal gute Ideen hatten. Die sind nämlich im Sendegate schon prima aufgehoben. Und da lese ich auch alles und höre auch viel zu. Und viele der Features in der 3.0 sind genau aufgrund von dem Feedback dort entstanden. Aber die Sachen, die man jetzt hier findet, das sind schon relativ harte Entwicklerinnen und Entwicklerjobs. Und dieser Aufruf rührt glaube ich weniger daher, dass wir da jetzt verzweifelt sind und jetzt irgendwie das Projekt in großer Not ist. Ich glaube, den Eindruck erwecken wir gerade nicht so wirklich, sondern weil wir einfach viele Baustellen haben, an denen wir denken, so da könnte es jetzt nochmal ein bisschen schneller vorwärtsgehen, um irgendwie das Podcast-Wesen voranzubringen. Und genau in dem Bereich sind jetzt hier diese fünf Positionen verortet. Und das ist sicherlich unschädlich, wenn man sich auf mehreren wirbt, aber man sollte nicht alles so ein bisschen haben und machen und können, sondern sollte sich schon irgendwie doch als Expertinnen und Experte in mindestens einer dieser Blöcke hier wiederfinden. Ich weiß nicht, Heiko, du kannst vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen moderieren, gerade zu den C-Geschichten, da stecke ich ja noch wirklich gar nicht so drin.
Ja, also was man hier sieht, ist, also wer es gerade nicht sieht, hier ist Swift-Frontendentwicklerin, C-Sharp-Frontendentwicklerin, dahinter steckt eigentlich unsere Zusammenarbeit mit Studio Link.
Genau.
Für Sebastians Standalone-Tool, das wollen wir ein bisschen aufpeppen.
Dass er derzeit einfach so als Browser-Start-Plugin realisiert ist und daraus wollen wir eine Standalone-App machen.
Ja, genau. Und wir brauchen halt eine für den Mac und eine für Windows.
Da existiert noch gar kein Code?
Nein, Andy, Andy, der uns leider verlassen hat, der hat einen Prototypen gemacht für den Mac. Mit so ein bisschen Mock-up eigentlich.
Es geht ja eigentlich um ein relativ einfaches User-Interface. So Apps, Daten, Verbindungen herstellen, Audio übertragen.
Das sind eigentlich ideale Anfänger-Projekte, würde ich mal sagen. Da stecken ein paar Ecken und Kanten drin. Also Sebastian's Software ist in C. Und dann muss man halt in der Stelle... Die Calls umsetzen. Man sagt dann vielleicht leider in C, aber eigentlich ist es gut. Man kriegt das halt in beide Technologien, in C-Sharp und Swift, eigentlich ganz gut rein. Das ist eigentlich der einzige Weg, der dazu gehen muss. Aber ansonsten kann man sich da austoben.
Bei der Herausforderung glaube ich gerade, ist ein sehr simples User-Interface da umzusetzen. Was manchmal viel schwieriger ist, als dann eben Feature Creep Geschichten zu machen.
Ja gut, aber man könnte mal was ausprobieren. Das ist ja durchaus auch mal eine ganz angenehme Sache. Da, das wären die beiden Punkte. Also inwiefern wir da bei Ultraschall direkt etwas in 12. C-Sharp machen, wissen wir nicht. Also wenn wir irgendwann mal eine eigene abhaben, was ich jetzt noch nicht so sehe, doch ich sehe es eigentlich schon, wir sehen es so halb, das Wechsel von Tag zu Tag.
Ja, so nach Wetterlage.
Dann wäre das wieder aktuell.
So, dann klappert es doch mal durch hier. Also Swift für Mac vor allem, vielleicht auch iOS, wer weiß. C-Lattenzauen für Windows, der selbe Kram. Und C++ für was?
Für das Plugin, für die Reaper-Integration.
Das muss in C++ oder das ist halt der Fall in C++?
Das entzwingt Reaper so. Aber an der Stelle vielleicht auch nochmal die Einwand. Also wir wollen eigentlich das, was wir jetzt in Reaper laufen haben, an C++ Code durch Lua ersetzen.
Lässt sich denn das auch alles ersetzen?
Ich denke ja. Beweisen kann ich es noch nicht. Aber ich glaube schon. Hängt natürlich auch ein bisschen davon ab, was wir da einbauen wollen in Zukunft.
Also nochmal zum Hintergrund. Lua ist halt mit Reaper mitgeliefert. Also Lua ist ja sowieso diese extrem abgespeckte, sehr simple, sehr effiziente Gaming-Scripting-Sprache. Gaming-Scripting, quasi so die super schlank Variante zu irgendwie so einem Java auf irgendeinem Device. Wenn du es irgendwie schnell und einfach haben willst, dann packst du lieber Lua drauf. Und das ist halt mit jeder Reaper-Installation kriegst du auch automatisch deinen Lua mit drauf, inklusive einer kleinen IDE. Du kannst also dann sogar deinen Code dort in Reaper reintippen und hast auch einen kleinen Debugger drin, wo du also ständig irgendwie so den ganzen State von den Variablen siehst und sowas. Die Reaper-Entwickler sind einfach voll Nerds. Mir ist keine andere Endkunden-Software, auch nur ansatzweise bekannt, die mit einer eigenen IDE daherkommt. Und von daher ist dann die Versuchung nahe, möglichst viel in Lua zu machen, weil es also extrem einsteigerfreundlich ist und zum anderen halt wirklich out of the box einfach mitgeliefert wird. Wohingegen man bei C halt diverse Abhängigkeiten zu Libraries und so weiter.
Ich habe halt bei C das Problem, dass ich platformabhängig bin an der Stelle. Ich muss an bestimmten Teilen unterscheiden. Das Binary ist halt auch einfach nicht das Gleiche und der Lua-Code ist einfach dann immer gleich. Da muss ich mir keine Gedanken drum machen. Das ist einfach auch ein Riesengrund.
Lua finde ich ist auch... Ich meine, es gibt ja so Sachen, was weiß ich, wenn ihr jetzt nach Erlang aufgerufen hättet, zum Beispiel nach Erlang-Programmieren. Da haben wir ja schon viel drüber geredet. Ich würde jedem Programmierer, jeder Programmiererin generell empfehlen, sowieso pro Jahr eine neue Programmiersprache zu lernen. Erlang ist so in meiner Top Ten von Sprachen, die man mal gelernt haben sollte, um zu sehen, dass diese Welt sich nicht immer immer in dieselbe Richtung dreht, sondern dass es da einfach auch Möglichkeiten gibt, über Probleme ganz anders nachzudenken und dass das auch sehr sinnvoll ist, das zu tun. Lua hat glaube ich auch noch bei manchen so ein bisschen diesen Appeal einer weiteren Exotensprache, die keiner macht. Das Schöne an Lua, und ich sage das jetzt aus einer Position heraus, wo ich ehrlich gesagt mich noch nicht zu tief da reingedacht habe. Ich habe mir Specs mal durchgelesen, ein bisschen was gemacht hier und da, aber eigentlich auch noch nicht so richtig in diese, wie man die kniffligen Sachen gut damit löst und so, weil da gibt es ja dann ein paar nette Strategien bei Lua. Ich kenne auch ein paar Freaks, die auch schon so komplett im Luaverse untergekommen sind und irgendwie alles Mögliche damit machen, einfach weil es so viel Spaß macht. Aber Lua ist halt auch einfach eine sehr leicht zu lernende Sprache und letzten Endes die eigentliche Mächtigkeit entsteht dadurch, dass Lua sich ja quasi immer so einlistet. Also das ist einmal dafür optimiert worden, einfach klein, schnell, kompakt und gut implementierbar zu sein.
Ja und embedbar.
Genau, das nehme ich vor allem, darauf wollte ich ja hinaus. Das heißt, hat man jetzt irgendeine Software, die im Prinzip intern viel Funktionalität hat und irgendwann beschäftigt man sich eigentlich selbst in seinem Code nur noch damit, diese ganze Funktionalität miteinander zu verknüpfen. Will aber gar nicht alle Feature-Anforderungen von allen Usern, die aus den Seiten heraus, von allen Seiten hereinprasseln, umsetzen. Dann tut man vielleicht ganz gut da dran und das machen ja auch sehr viele dann einfach, sich diesen kleinen Lua-Core dazu zu nehmen, dafür zu sorgen, dass diese internen Schnittstellen nicht nur der eigenen Poemiersprache gegenüber geöffnet sind, sondern dann eben auch einfach direkt mit Lua aufrufbar sind. Und dann hat man quasi eine allgemeine Scripting Engine mit dem Vorteil, dass eben viele Leute, die in diesem Bereich der Automatisierung arbeiten, mit Lua schon aus anderen Systemen Bekanntschaft geschlossen haben dürften. Aber selbst wenn man es halt komplett neu lernt, weil jetzt das erste Mal ein Programm da ist, wo einem Automatisierung wirklich interessiert, ist es immer noch sehr schnell zu erlernen und sehr schnell zu machen. Das hat mich sehr gefreut, als Reaper 5 mit Lua ankam, weil vorher war das ja so mit Python.
Das war aber schon in der Vier, war es auch schon drin, oder? Kam das Echte, als es in der Fünf war?
Das war das große Ding. Es ist nicht so groß angekündigt worden, aber es war so, ja, jetzt auch Lua. Ich dachte mir so, ach ja.
Ist halt auch leicht zu integrieren.
Genau, bevor jetzt die Python-Fans wieder aufschreien. Damit will ich nicht sagen, dass man nicht mit Python, kann man natürlich auch super automatisieren. Nur, da gab es halt mal diese Probleme mit irgendwie externen Installieren und Versionen.
Genau, die kriege ich auf Windows drauf.
Ja, ja, also das war, sagen wir mal, suboptimal. Und mit Lua sind diese ganzen Probleme einfach gegangen. Ja. Jetzt könnte das halt nochmal ganz interessant werden in Reaper, weil bisher immer alles ein bisschen schwierig war. Wie entwickelt sich Reaper so, was die Nutzbarkeit von interner Funktionalität über Lua betrifft?
Also synchron zu den anderen. Die API-Calls sind ja schon sehr, sehr umfangreich. Ich kenne keine andere Software, die so eine umfangreiche API hat für Sachen gegen machen. Und jetzt gerade zur 3.0 haben wir noch wieder Ecken und Kanten aufgebrochen, die ich vorher überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm hatte. Also beispielsweise, dass wir jetzt selber GUI schreiben könnten. Also vorher hieß es immer, okay, wir können irgendwie Makros machen und wir können ein bisschen Scripting machen. Und letztendlich sind wir aber immer auf das zurückgeworfen an GUI, was uns halt irgendwie Reaper vorgibt. Und jetzt habe ich mir dann, das war jetzt erst diesen Dezember, mal angeschaut, was man eigentlich mit dieser GFX-Library so machen kann, die da mitgeliefert wird mit der API. Und siehe da, du kannst GUIs malen mit Buttons und Schaltern.
Ist das dein Color Picker?
Der Color Picker kommt daher, der Startscreen kommt daher, der Export Assistant kommt daher. Das ist jetzt alles selbstgemalte GUI. Und da stehen wir jetzt erst ganz, ganz, ganz am Anfang von dem, was da möglich ist. Du kommst über die API beispielsweise, kämmst du in Echtzeit sogar an die Waveforms ran. Man könnte in einem extremen Punkt die komplette GUI ausblenden von Reaper und eine eigene drüber setzen. Das wäre sicherlich sehr ambitioniert, aber theoretisch machbar.
Ich glaube, die haben die gesamte C-API über Lua abgebildet.
Da würde mir so einiges einfallen, was man da mal ablösen könnte.
Eine der Sachen, die wir jetzt für die 3.1 auf dem Schirm haben, ist beispielsweise ein Setup-Assistent, der die ganze Routing-Matrix weg abstrahiert. Also das, wo die meisten Leute sich das Hirn verknoten und erst einmal einen 2-Stunden-Film gucken müssen. Wie funktioniert das? Ein Schritt für Schritt-Assistent. Was hast du für Hardware? Guck mal, ich hab das hier gefunden. Das wäre jetzt das Preset für, wenn du ein Monitoring in deinem Device hast und wenn du kein Monitoring übers Device hast, dann nimmst du Setup B und jetzt guck mal, du hörtest dich vernünftig an. Ja, nein, solche Geschichten, das wäre ziemlich sinnvoll. Wir werden jetzt schon zur 303, das haben Udo und ich jetzt fast fertig, werden wir die Routing-Snapshot-Verwaltungen komplett selber mit eigener GUI und in Lua umgesetzt machen, damit man das los wird von der SWS, weil die auch einen Fehler drin haben. Also da ist so manches, was da demnächst, denke ich, noch anrollt. Da kann man auch viel Fantasie reinstecken. Von daher suchen wir hier auch Lua-Entwickler, allerdings eher im Bereich Backend. Im Frontend sind Udo, Sauer und ich da schon sehr kräge unterwegs. Es wäre eigentlich wichtiger, dass es im Hintergrund jemanden gibt, der das auch mal mit einer vernünftigen Architektur versieht.
Und der sich auch mit dem Reaper-Datmodell beschäftigt, wo man die Marker ja kriegt.
Und der halt mal ein hartes Refactoring durchführt und das Ganze mal in vernünftige Klassen überführt. Was wir im Moment jetzt doch schon eher so hemmsärmlich runter coden. Dass dann noch mal eine gewisse Eleganz in Sachen der Architektur draufkommt. Das wäre schon sehr hilfreich. Keine Zeit. Unit-Tests. Unit-Tests, wirklich. Also ein Continuous Integration und so was. Das machen wir. Ja, kannst du auch noch erzählen, wenn du möchtest, weißt du, wer hier im Bereich Release Manager ist? Genau.
Also wir haben da für jede Plattform einen Installer. Und die machen beliebig Arbeit, gerade wenn sich was ändert. Und an der Stelle hätten wir noch Bedarf. Also das wäre super. Wird allerdings dadurch erschwert, dass man bei Mac halten Developer-Account braucht. Also von daher mache ich mir da wenig auf.
Aber den braucht man ja nur zu klicken.
Kostet ja nicht ein Hunderter.
Du brauchst den Developer-Account nur noch, wenn du was in den Appstore stellen willst.
Na okay, ich brauche die Developer-Installer-ID, die ich da kriege. Die kriegst du auch so.
Also du kriegst die IDs, um den Kram zu signen.
Ja genau.
Kriegst du für Ome.
Das reicht, ja.
Aber wenn du was in den Store tun willst, dann brauchst du den bezahlten Account.
Ist nicht mehr ganz so schlimm.
Das war nie so. Früher musstest du bezahlen.
Da leg ich meine Hand für uns früher.
Das haben sie erst vor zwei Jahren geändert. Als sie angefangen haben mit diesem, wie ist dieses Sicherheitsfeature, mit dem Finanzamt-Kreuzberg-Ding, wie ist das? Gatekeeper. Dann konntest du, um deine Sachen Gatekeeper zu signieren, konntest du immer für umsonst dein Signing-Certificate bekommen. Nur, wenn du in Adler wolltest.
Ja, aber es war am Anfang so, dass du einfach, wenn du da überhaupt auf dein eigenes Device poamieren willst, musstest du so, wie die Developer-Betreffung ist.
Für iOS, aber nicht für ein Mac. Also da waren die, die Developer-Tools waren immer für Oma.
Ja, okay. Aber wenn auch mit...
Nur das Signieren von die...
Genau, das Signieren war das auch abgedeckt.
Also ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich das vor ein paar Jahren noch zweimal bezahlen musste. Einmal für iOS und einmal für ein Mac.
Ja, das war dann, ja, wenn du in beiden App-Stores präsent sein willst, dann war das eine separate Programme.
Habst du den Mac schon? Ich weiß es nicht, das ist wirklich schon lange so.
Na, den gab es später, aber es gab erst eine Unterscheidung.
Du musstest bezahlen, wenn du die Beta-Version haben wolltest. Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das immer noch so ist, keine Ahnung. Aber das Signieren von den Installern ist ja auch noch nicht so alt. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall immer für umsonst gewesen.
Ja, das bräuchten wir halt immer einmal genau. Ob man die Beta-Version jetzt signieren muss, weiß ich nicht.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist jetzt noch das geringste Problem. Na gut, also, um es mal zusammenzufassen, wer noch Bock hat, sich ein wenig weiterzuentwickeln als Programmiererinnen, Programmierer und insbesondere im Bereich Lura, Swift und C-Lattenzauen und C++ unterwegs ist oder sein möchte, dann gibt es hier die Gelegenheit anzudocken.
Du kannst nochmal Reload drücken. Ich habe gerade noch einen Job hinzugefügt.
Ach so, dann kommen wir gar nicht zu Ende, was?
Video Editor.
Du hast ja einen noch gar nicht erwähnt.
Ach so, das ist, glaube ich, das, was eben...
Video Editor.
Genau, also es kommt häufig mal der Wunsch, nach einem so zwei bis maximal fünf Minuten knalligen Video, das ist Ultraschall und das funktioniert es. Und darum solltet ihr das mal ausprobieren. So, das ist...
Das ist ein fancy Schmancy Kickstarter-Dingsbund.
Genau, das ist nicht meine Welt. Ja, also wie ich auch gerne lange podcaste, mache ich auch gerne lange Erklärbär-Videos. Und ich sehe da auch durchaus eine Gefahr, so was zu machen, weil dann irgendwie mehr Support hast. Wenn die Leute es irgendwie nur klicklichbunt ausprobieren und nicht wirklich verstanden haben, dann hast du mir auf der Support-Schiene. Aber ich würde es zumindest, glaube ich, mal ausprobieren wollen, wie sich sowas anfühlt. Aber gerade solche Videos sind, glaube ich, sehr schwer zu produzieren. Und wenn irgendjemand da draußen Erfahrungen hat, genau in solchen Kickstart-Video-Geschichten, dann wäre ich bereit, das mal auszuprobieren. So, was da so bei rumkommt.
Ja, und vor allem an der Stelle auch natürlich international. Also Sprecher, englische Sprecher, so ein Video machen, was man vielleicht an unterschiedlichen Sprachen vertont.
Also ich würde eigentlich gerne mal durch die USA tun und da die Podcast-Szene mal aufmischen, aber das geht eigentlich realistisch nur in einem Symbatical.
Don't doubt the Germans.
Da müsste man wirklich ein Jahr mal Urlaub nehmen und das ist jetzt auch irgendwie mit Familie und sowas alles nicht so arg realistisch. Das kann natürlich auch irgendwie anders machen. Also klar.
Muss ja nicht gleich die USA sein, du könnt ja erst mal Europa nehmen.
UK, solange sie noch Teil von Europa sind.
Gut, so viel zum Stellengesuch. Willst du jetzt mal kurz nochmal erklären, was Ultraschall eigentlich ist?
Nach drei Stunden. Es ist, glaube ich, die mit einiger Sicherheit funktionsstärkste und mittlerweile vielleicht auch bedienfreundlichste Software zur Produktion von High-End-Podcasts, wie ich es nenne. Das sind also Podcasts, die einfach von vorne bis hinten so rund und shiny und mit Feenstaub überzogen sind. So wie Freak Show zum Beispiel. Du nimmst ja auch noch Opphonic. Hast du mal mit dem Dynamics experimentiert, so AB-Vergleich gemacht? Mit der 3.0-Version haben wir jetzt eine Alternative zu Opphonic eingebaut, kurz Hintergrund dazu, der dynamische Lautstärke-Anpassungen aller Spuren einzeln macht und so weiter. Da bin ich auch äußerst unsicher, wie das da draußen eigentlich ankommt, da haben wir noch relativ wenig Feedback bekommen. Aber es reicht demnächst auch mein Sendegate, wenn Sendungen damit produziert worden sind, wie gut sich das da draußen im Feld wirklich hilft. Schlägt, mal sehen.
Also habe ich tatsächlich noch nicht getestet. Ich habe jetzt überhaupt erst seit kurzem hier, also Running System und so weiter, das ist natürlich hier so ein Ding. Jetzt habe ich hier gerade das Bluetooth-Modul in meinem Mac Pro ausgewechselt. Jetzt funktioniert nur noch die Hälfte meiner V-Modes. Das ist schon nochmal ein Problem, das ich hier auch nochmal angehen muss. Und die Stabilität dieses Setups hier ist natürlich auch unerreicht. Also ich denke, es gibt niemanden, der so lange schon so produziert am Stück hier mit einem Setup.
Die Stabilität dieses Setups ist unerreicht. Das ist Fishing for Previously, oder?
Na mal ehrlich, ich mache jetzt hier seit sechs Jahren in diesem Setup irgendwie meine Aufnahmen.
Na ja, also gefühlt so bis vor ungefähr 2,5 Jahren war ich ja so die ersten 20 Minuten an jedem Freak Show erstmal noch das Rumruckeln an der Technik. Aber das ist signifikant weniger geworden, so, das kann man sicherlich sagen.
Ja, auch dank Ultraschall muss dazu sagen. Also da ist, gut, aber das hat natürlich was damit zu tun, dass ich dann doch auch immer wieder meinen Experimentierbereich habe, worauf ich eigentlich, ist aber auch eigentlich egal, worauf ich hinaus wollte. Erzähl mal weiter, was ihr noch so für Features habt.
Was Heiko jetzt eingebaut hat in der letzten Release und was man glaube ich irgendwie so an Schmerzlevel gar nicht hoch genug einschätzen kann, ist Metadaten in MP3s schreiben. Also LAME ist ja jetzt lizenzfrei. Ist es schon geworden oder wird das jetzt die Tage? Ihr hattet das glaube ich auch mal als Thema im Lautsprecher, ne?
Na, AC3 ist jetzt durch, aber du redest ja von MP3. Ja, gute Frage. Wie weit sind wir jetzt eigentlich bei MP3?
Also wir waren auf jeden Fall mal...
Ich schau mal, es muss soon sein, ja.
Also auf jeden Fall waren wir jetzt mal mutig. Wir haben gar nicht nachgeguckt, ob es nun schon passiert ist oder nicht. Sondern haben es jetzt einfach in die Distribution reingepackt. Das heißt also, das, was man normalerweise sich bei Reaper, so den Lame-Encoder noch dazu installieren muss, liefern wir jetzt mit dem Installer gleich mit aus. Und da sind wir nicht stehen geblieben, sondern wir haben gesagt, so wir können auch noch gleich Episodenbilder reinschreiben und wir können Kapitelmarken reinschreiben und wir können die ganzen sonstigen Metadaten, die halt so ein MP3 als Podcast so braucht, auch alle mit reinschreiben. Das sind auch alles Funktionen, die bisher auf Honig und oder andere kostenpflichtige Programme übernommen haben. Das machen wir jetzt auch heute out of the box. Da könnte jetzt Heiko sicherlich lang und ausgiebig über die Fiesigkeiten von Umlauten und Sonderzeichen und ähnliches und UTF-8 und sonstige Spezereien erzählen. Und ansonsten halt so, ich würde sagen, das Feature, was wahrscheinlich so am meisten Impact jetzt schon hat draußen, ist halt dieses On-Air-Streaming. Was wir jetzt gerade ja auch mit der Sendung hier parallel machen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele jetzt gerade parallel darauf zuhören, dass man also wirklich mit einem einzigen Buttonklick und das haben wir versprochen und es ist auch genauso gekommen. Dank Studio Link On Air eine laufende Reaper- Ultraschall-Aufnahme einfach ins Netz raus streamen kann und man nimmt sich die URL und postet die auf Twitter und Leute können zuhören. Also das, wo man vorher einen echt komplizierten Software-Stack für brauchte mit NiceCast-Account und Software und virtuellen Geräten und so weiter und so fort. Das haben wir alles auf einen einzigen Klick runter reduziert. Das ist glaube ich so das Feature der 3.0, was so den größten Impact in der Szene haben wird, weil jetzt wirklich jeder, der sowieso schon mit Ultraschall arbeitet, kann einfach mal ausprobieren, wie fühlt es sich eigentlich an, live zu podcasten. Und wir sind uns hier alle einig, dass so das die Herz und die DNA von Podcasting natürlich die Zeitsouveränität ist, das heißt, ich kann die Sache nachhören, aber es macht viele Sendungsformate eben auch nicht schlechter, wenn sie live gesendet werden. Das ist also eine Sache, die sich überhaupt nicht ausschließt und wir haben jetzt, Sebastian hat mir gerade eben noch die Zahlen rüber geworfen. Wir haben jetzt gesagt, seit ungefähr zweieinhalb Wochen sind wir draußen und es gibt 170 neue Anmeldungen jetzt bei ihm auf der Plattform. Und ich glaube, 60 Sendungen sind seitdem schon, also unterschiedliche Formate sind schon umbenannt worden mit eigenen Namen, das heißt also, da ist dann auch schon Branding stattgefunden, das heißt also irgendwas zwischen 60 und 170 Sendungen von verschiedenen Podcasts sind jetzt schon gestreamt worden, wovon wir davon ausgehen können, dass ein Großteil von denen zum ersten Mal irgendwie live auf Sendung war. Und wer mich ein bisschen kennt, sowas liebe ich halt immer, Disruption, einfach Technologie so einfach machen, dass jeder mal was komplett Neues irgendwie ausprobieren kann. Es ist einfach cool, live zu senden, es ist auch in Chat integriert, man hat dann auch gleich das Feedback der Führer und so weiter, spielt damit, habt Spaß, ist cool.
Ja, das denke ich, also da stimme ich dir auch total zu, dass das mal wichtig war, das einfach zu machen, ich hoffe, dass da vor allem bei Studio Link noch ein bisschen Features andocken, auf die ich so primär scharf bin, weil derzeit ist ja Streaming immer gleich nur Ice-Cast-MP3-Stream und das ist so ein Standard, auf dem sind wir jetzt irgendwie seit wann, seit 20 Jahren oder was?
Lange auf jeden Fall, ja.
Lange, ja, also es ist jetzt einfach mal Zeit für moderne Streaming-Ansätze und also was heißt ich nicht nur Ansätze, sondern es ist ja im Prinzip auch durch so, hat sich ja gezeigt, was gut funktioniert und gut bisher ist es noch dieses HLS von Apple.
Waren es jetzt aber auch schon 10 Jahre alte, so oder so, ne?
Ne, 10 Jahre sind es noch nicht, aber ist schon ein paar Jahre abgehangen, hat sich im Prinzip auch bewährt und wird ja jetzt auch standardisiert durch MPEG-DASH und DASH ist glaube ich im Chrome schon durch und im Firefox auch, glaube ich, ne? Und ich weiß auch gerade nicht, wann das in iOS kommt, aber es kann nicht mehr so lange dauern. Also wenn es nicht schon drin ist, dann kommt es bestimmt mit dem nächsten iOS, kann ich mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass sie noch sehr viel mehr Zeit verschwenden. Aber das hat dann den Vorteil, dass dann eben dieser letzte Nachteil von Internet-Streaming wegfällt, dass wenn du dich bewegst und schlechtere Verbindungsraten hast oder eben auch abreißende Netze etc. und ein guter Streaming-Server, der muss halt einerseits eben das alles über HTTP machen. Klar, das läuft bei Ascas ja derzeit auch so, aber eben immer in Häppchen, sodass man eben bei jedem Request sagen kann, das letzte Paket kam ein bisschen langsam, dann gehe ich mal in der Qualität runter, nehme eine niedrigere Bitrate, weil lieber ein bisschen rauschiger als gar nicht. Das ist immer das Schlimmste. Bei Audio ist immer ruckeln immer das Schlimmste und das kann man halt dadurch ganz gut abfangen und dadurch, dass du es halt immer wieder in separaten Requests machst, kannst du ja im Prinzip auch dieses Handover zwischen verschiedenen Netzen ganz gut machen. Was dann noch dazukommt, wie heißt denn das gleich nochmal diese Technik, die in, wann ist das eingeführt worden, bei MechOS vor zwei Jahren? Diese Multi-Link-Connection.
Multi-Peer.
Ne, nicht die Multi-Pink, sondern das im Prinzip, während du in einem W-Lan bist, was aber gerade schon irgendwie rumschwächelt, das iPhone im Prinzip auch direkt über 3G oder LTE parallel ein Request macht und es gewinnt dann sozusagen der, der zuerst antwortet.
Ich glaube, das ist 10. Mit iOS 9, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ne, 9.
Also bestimmt 9. Ja, doch 9. Schon eine Weile her.
Und Apple verwendet das, glaube ich, für Siri auf jeden Fall und das musst du dann quasi serverseitig halt auch irgendwie unterstützen, weil du ja sozusagen zwei Anfragen von derselben Quelle kriegst, die nur auf unterschiedlichen Wegen unterwegs sind. Und das wäre natürlich etwas, was ein Streaming-Server auf jeden Fall auch ausprobieren sollte, weil man dann eben explizit dieses schnell verbinden kann, weil es gibt ja nichts Schlimmeres als aus dem Haus rausgehen, während man was live hört. Ja, dann hörst du halt nicht live, weil dann irgendwann verreckt halt dein WLAN das Telefon und immer so, ja, aber vielleicht und ich noch mal probiere und ich noch mal 10 Sekunden warte und so und denkst dann so, Schalt, hält mich um und dann schaltest du schon selber deinen WLAN von Hand aus, damit du irgendwie mal wieder ein Netz hast und genau das sind halt solche Probleme, die man damit ganz gut umgehen kann und dadurch, dass man eben nicht eine Verbindung hat, die dann immer wieder neu aufgebaut werden muss, sondern im Prinzip sich das immer in so separaten Chunks holt, ist halt auch für Serverbetreiber eigentlich viel besser. Es wird archivieren ganz hilfreich, weil es dann eben in verschiedenen Bitraten ablegen kannst. Du kannst halt HTTP-Caching benutzen, du kannst automatisch Zeitversätze senden. Du kannst sagen, ah, was weiß ich, bin jetzt gerade hier aus der Turnhalle gekommen, Sendung läuft seit 15 Minuten. Du willst irgendwie so ein bisschen live dabei sein, aber auch nichts verpassen. Du kannst halt einfach 15 Minuten zurückspringen und dann hängst du dich ganz so sehr hinterher. Also, das sind alles Dinge, die ich noch gerne sehen möchte, sprich, der Podcast-Streaming-Bereich, hat sich eigentlich kaum groß entwickelt. Und ich denke, dass man hier mit vergleichbaren, also mit einem vertretbar großen Aufwand und sehr naheliegenden Technologien einfach eine ganze Menge reißen kann, indem man einfach mal eine Infrastruktur schafft, wo einfach dieses Live-Senden von Podcasts besser wird. Und zwar deutlich besser als das, was wir eben derzeit auch im professionellen Radiobereich haben. Die Öffentlich- rechtlichen bekleckern sich ja auch nicht gerade mit Room, mit ihrem Streaming. Eben habe ich gerade auf dem Apple TV gibt es jetzt irgendwie eine ARD-Media- Atek-App, da dachte ich so, ja hurra, endlich, 2017, 21. Jahrhundert ist irgendwie vorbei gekommen, probiere das aus, dann stelle ich fest, die senden immer noch nicht in HD, sondern immer noch mit so einem Pixling-Scheiß, auch was sie in ihren Videopodcaster für eine absurde Qualität raushauen, einfach lächerlich, lächerlich ist das einfach. Also die kann man auf jeden Fall...
Sehr gut, aber Fernsehen gucke ich eigentlich selten live.
Es geht um Streaming, es geht nicht unbedingt um live.
Naja, aber so diese Mediathek-Kram, der funktioniert eigentlich...
Ja, sieht aber scheiße aus.
Nö, bei mir nicht.
Ich habe das vorhin ausprobiert, es sieht zum Kotzen aus. Und auch alle Podcasts, die du abonnierst. Versuch mal...
Wahrscheinlich nicht die ARD-Mediathek, sondern irgendwas Freies.
Red von ARD.
Ja, doch, ich glaube, es war ARD.
Ja, abonnieren, mal wissen, macht A. Guck dir mal, das ist einfach zum Heulen. Du willst einfach nur noch um dich treten und schreien. Sollte jemand irgendwie aus dem Bereich hier zuhören, Leute, echt. Das geht nicht. Also es ist einfach mal schlecht für euer Image. Und wenn schon niedrige Bitrate wichtig ist, da gibt es auch echt bessere Encoder. Die machen auch kleine Dateien, aber es muss nicht so aussehen, wie fünfmal durch einen Kakao gezogen.
Wahrscheinlich ist es immer noch irgendein Flash-kompatibler Rotz, den sie dann auf ihrem Internet Explorer 6 noch fahren können oder so. Es muss ja überall spielbar sein.
Es ist ja MPEG-4, es ist schon überall spielbar. Nee, nur die Encoder, also entweder die Encoder oder die Encoder-Einstellungen, die sie da verwenden, die sind einfach doof. Aber ich will bei Audio bleiben. Ich will sagen, man muss einfach diesen Streaming-Kram besser machen. Und man muss ihn erstmal vor allem in dem Kernbereich machen, also bessere Audioqualität, niedrige Bit-Raten, verschiedene zur Auswahl, das Ganze über Dash oder HLS anbieten, Zeitversetztes, Springen und so weiter, alles mit einbauen und halt eine entsprechende Server-Infrastruktur aufbauen, die das eben auch einfach flexibel erlaubt, dass man da auch automatisch Streaming, ReLive-Archive aufbauen kann. Und dann muss man sich natürlich auch ganz klar Gedanken machen über den Weg zurück, also das interaktive Element. Also Chat, okay, meinetwegen, das ist alles schön und gut und hat ja auch hier immer wieder segnende Wirkung auf Rückmeldungen und Informationen und so weiter. Aber ich denke, da geht halt noch sehr viel mehr, was so diese unmittelbare Interaktionskanal betrifft. Das muss einfach an der Stelle ein bisschen innovativer werden.
Ja, also unser Ziel war erst mal nur ein Button. Weil das ist immer eine Frage von Angebot und Nachfrage, und ich glaube, dass du jetzt...
An der Stelle rede ich ja nicht von Ultraschall. Ich rede von Streaming als solchen und so. Und das ist gut, dass es da halt mal eine neue Initiative gibt, wo man wieder rumsitzen darf und einfach das Leid beklagen kann. Die Leidklage, Energie freilassen kann, damit wir uns dann in Lichtgeschwindigkeit bessere Sphären zuordnen, zu nähern können. Gibt es noch ein Feature, was du noch preisen möchtest von Ultraschall 3?
Ich kann noch was pluggen, was in der 3.1 vielleicht kommt. Was vielleicht dein Herz erwärmen wird. Du kennst vielleicht, du hast auch so einen Podcast, Forschergeist, diese kleinen Social Media kompatiblen Minifilmchen, wo man so 30 Sekunden aus einer Episode nehmen kann mit Hintergrundbild und Metadaten und so einer kleinen Audioanimation und sowas. Und vielleicht produzieren wir die mal aus Ultraschall heraus. So mit zwei Klicks.
Eine zwei Klicks, na gut, das geht natürlich davon aus, dass man diese Exerpte nicht weiter bearbeiten muss.
Naja, beziehungsweise also wenn du das Audio halt hast. Also wenn du das Audio zusammenschneidest, dann sind es ein paar mehr als zwei Klicks, aber der ganze Rest. Noch nicht versprochen, wir forschen noch, aber ich halte es für möglich. Weil nebenbei Reaper auch ein Video-Editor ist. Weil die Leute sind halt verrückt.
Stimmt, Reaper hat ja auch Video.
Naja, als Video-Editor würde ich es normalerweise nie nehmen, aber dafür könnte es ausgesprochen nützlich sein. So und ich muss noch ein paar Sachen klären, aber da generell irgendwie MP4-Videos raus zu rendern, ist relativ simpel. Und man muss sich eigentlich erst nur noch ein paar lustige Konzepte überlegen, wie dann die richtigen Daten mit den richtigen Bildern in den richtigen Spuren und so weiter berücksichtigt werden. Aber das halte ich für ein generell lösbares Problem und das könnte da draußen doch mal für etwas Hurra sorgen, denke ich.
Können wir das Kapitel jetzt auch erst mal zumachen? Ach so, um den Podcast-Teil dann vielleicht noch abzuschließen, werfe ich noch kurz hinterher, dass es auch von unserem Podlove Publisher eine neue Version gegeben hat. Da gibt es nicht ganz so viel zu erzählen. Aber immerhin gab es mal wieder eine Version. Also Podcaster aufgepasst, ihr solltet alle mal ein Update fahren. Und da haben wir dann zumindest mal so einen Hintergrund ein paar Dinge verbessert, die schon lange hätten anders sein sollen. Stichwort Kapitelmarken. Das muss ja alles noch viel einfacher werden. Und Kapitelmarken haben wir ja da sozusagen jetzt auch etwas zugänglicher aufgebaut. Demnächst, denke ich mal, werden wir dann auch mehr Kapitelmarken aus diesen ganzen anderen DAWs importieren können. Es gibt ja auch Leute, die mit Hindenburg arbeiten und so. Und wenn die da ihre Marken setzen, dann kann man die da halt direkt aus dem Projekt rauslesen und solche Sachen. Tut sich also ein bisschen was. Und auch da hoffe ich, dass wir mit unserem neuen Release-Zyklusansatz da jetzt bald mal wieder schneller neue Sachen liefern können, um es einfach noch etwas flauschiger werden zu lassen. Soviel erstmal dazu.
Ich könnte, es gab noch einen Artikel über Podcasting. Wolltest du den noch irgendwie pluggen, weil er noch irgendwo hier im Workflow drin stand? Der von Krautreporter?
Wollte ich den pluggen? Ich hab den einfach mal so notiert, weil er da auch Ultraschall unter anderem drin...
Er ist jetzt glaube ich aber auch nur noch wenige Stunden, wenn überhaupt öffentlich zugänglich von daher.
Was, dieser Artikel?
Ja, die haben ja so eine 48 Stunden Paywall. Das ist 48 Stunden, weil die frei zugänglich ist.
Zwei Stunden noch oder so.
Jetzt noch schnell klicken.
Nee, gar nicht. Du bist ja schon links.
Woran sieht man? Ist das generell so?
Ich glaube, das ist bei Krautreporter jetzt der...
Willst du weiterlesen?
Ist schon hinter der Paywall. Dann brauchen wir sie auch nur noch bedingt pluggen. Fürchte ich. So ist das mit dem Paid-Content.
Aber was ist denn so deine Wahrnehmung, wie sich denn so die Wahrnehmung geändert hat? Ich meine, ich beobachte das ja nun schon eine Weile. Und es gibt ja dann immer diese schöne Hype-Curve. So übersteigerte Erwartungen und dann so das Teil der Verzweiflung. Gefühlt habe ich das beim Thema Podcast schon irgendwie zweimal durch. Und die Wahrnehmung von innen ist ja eigentlich eine ganz andere. Meine Wahrnehmung war eigentlich immer nur so, dass es ein Medium ist, das befindet sich in Entwicklung. Das wartet darauf, dass die technologischen Voraussetzungen ideal werden, sowohl was die Produktion als auch die Konsumtion betrifft. Und dann wird sich einfach ein bestimmter Effekt einstellen. So, dann wird es einfach seinen Platz finden. Auch wenn ich vielleicht Schwierigkeiten gehabt habe, zu sagen, wie dieser Platz dann aussieht und wie wichtig der ist. Jetzt gab es dann nochmal diese zweite oder vielleicht auch schon so dritte Hype-Nummer. Mit dem ganzen Storytelling, Serial, und ach Gottchen, Millionen Zuhörer haben sich was runtergeladen. Und so, was er jetzt dann auch so in diesen Dingen wie Plattformen versuchen, Podcasts irgendwie jetzt auch zu encapsulieren, damit man, um da den Saft rauszuziehen für sich. Das finde ich ja immer so ein bisschen schade an diesen ganzen Plattformen. Und dann hatte ich heute irgendwie auch so eine, gestern hatte ich irgendwie so eine bizare Interaktion mit dem Fußballmagazin 11 Freunde. Das muss ich nochmal nachschlagen. Gott, ich kriege zu viele Antworten. Und zwar haben die halt auch einen Anführungsstrich Podcast, der aber dann bei dieser irgendwo gehostet ist. Und den kriegst du natürlich dann auch immer wieder mit dieser. Eigentlich gibt es da noch ein Webinterface, das funktioniert ja alles nicht. Und dann ist ein bisschen gesucht, dann hat man so ein Podcast und so. Vielleicht kann man das ja auch einfach mal normal abonnieren. Nee, geht aber nicht. Man meint dann so halt so, hier liebe Freunde, gibt es den Podcast auch als Podcast? Wo ist der Feed? Pampige Antwort. Das Wort Podcast hat sich vom Wort Podcast emanzipiert.
Und die wollen Medien sein, oh Mann.
Also ich will jetzt hier nicht einfach so drauf losbäschen und die, wie habt ihr nicht verstanden, nochmal fahren. Das heißt auch ein bisschen, glaube ich, auf was mit... Also ich kann auch was Positives ablesen. Ich war schon teilweise sehr überrascht, wie viele Outlets, die bisher eigentlich auf andere Wege gesetzt haben, auf Print vor allem, Text, wie viele eigentlich mittlerweile auch einen Podcast haben. Und bei wie vielen, der auch zunehmend eine Bedeutung hat. Manchen mehr, manchen weniger. Auch wenn man sich so die Podcast-Landschaft anschaut, insbesondere jetzt in den USA, in der aktuellen Trampokalypse, wie viel Debatte auf einmal darüber gefahren wird. Gerade mit der ganzen Fernsehdiskussion wissen wir ja alle, was dabei rauskommt. Das ist alles wenig. Die interessanten Debatten, die interessanten Hintergrundinformationen, die interessanten Gespräche, Analysen, um diesen Wahnsinn zu verorten für sich oder sich eben auch weiterzuentwickeln, finde ich jetzt tatsächlich auch gerade da wieder. Ich finde gerade die Podcasts, die zeigen ihre volle Stärke in diesem Bereich.
Ja, das muss nicht so bleiben. Ich mache mir Sorgen gerade. Ein bisschen getriggert durch einen Beitrag, den der Michael Seemann, MS-Pro, vor zwei Monaten, glaube ich, ungefähr mal geschrieben hat, anlässlich von Trump, mit irgendwie der stark zusammen distilierten These. Wir haben das mit dem Internet völlig falsch verstanden. Wir dachten, wir machen hier ein Medium der Freiheit und der Offenheit, wo alle partizipieren können, wo jeder Sender auch Empfänger ist, die ganze Brechnummer. Und was passiert? Die Nazis haben es überrannt und jetzt machen sie uns kalt damit, mit unserer eigenen freiheitlichen Technologie. Weil die einfach schneller, effizienter, meme-behafteter und so weiter sind. Und wir haben, wir stehen da und starren uns das Ganze an. Ich habe Panik davor, wenn die Nazi-Podcasts losgehen. Es gab jetzt eine angefangene Debatte im Sendegate dazu. Und ich frage mich wirklich ganz persönlich, ob das, was ich da gerade tue, eigentlich gut ist. Also von daher wird es vielleicht fast etwas zu ernst für diese Freak Show hier. Aber trotzdem, ich stelle mir diese Frage wirklich in den letzten Wochen. Dadurch, dass wir Technologie immer einfacher machen und die Zugangshürden dazu, irgendwie den Podcast rauszuhauen, immer weiter senken, wer schützt uns davor eigentlich, dass wir irgendwann demnächst auf YouTube-Niveau ankommen, wo jeder Idiot irgendwo was rauspustet, dann per Podcast und irgendwie dann eine mittelgroße Zielgruppe darüber findet. Vielleicht war diese komplizierte Technologie derzeit auch noch so was wie ein Schutzwall vor den ganzen Idioten und ist also das, was wir hier tun, eigentlich verantwortungsvoll, indem wir dort dann irgendwie die Horden reinlassen. Aber auf der anderen Seite sage ich, was wäre denn die Alternative gewesen?
Also die Gruppe, vor der du dich wirklich zu Recht vielleicht fürchtest, die ist nicht so doof. Die teilen zwar nicht unsere Auffassung über den Lauf der Dinge und über die notwendige Struktur dieser Welt, aber blöd sind die bestimmt nicht. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo sich irgendwelche Dinge urbar machen, dann liegt es nicht daran, dass du die Software so einfach gemacht hast und uns so niederschwellig angeboten hast. Also die wirklich problematischen Debatten-Teilnehmer an der Stelle würden auch andere Wege finden. Also da würde ich mir ehrlich gesagt überhaupt keine Sorgen machen. Also das ist auch, weiß nicht, da finde ich jetzt irgendwie so die Verbindung von Wirkungen und Ursachen und Gründen und so weiter finde ich einfach ein bisschen einen Hahn herbeigezogen.
Ja, es ist auch so ein bisschen zu kurz gedacht. Also ich meine, eine offene Kommunikationsplanform ist halt in jede Richtung offen und das ist halt auch am Ende des Tages gut so. Also ich meine, klar wollen wir alle nicht hören, was die Nazis sagen, aber wir wollen halt auch nicht, dass andere Leute, die sehr viel zu sagen haben, es nicht tun können, weil sie halt die Plattform nicht benutzen können. Also ich denke, dass es sicherlich da draußen potenzielle Podcaster sind, denen die technische Hürde heute noch zu hoch ist, die aber, wenn sie dann mal niedrig genug ist, sehr, sehr interessante Podcasts machen.
Vielleicht ist die entscheidende Technikhürde auch nicht die auf der Ebene der Sender, sondern die auf der Ebene der Empfänger. Im Prinzip war es ja schon immer einfach, auch einen Podcast zu finden und zu abonnieren. Aber jetzt haben wir so einen Subscribe-Button von Podlove. Das führt halt dazu, dass Leute einfacher dran kommen. Aber auf der anderen Seite, gut, iTunes war nur als allererstes da und war eigentlich auch hinlänglich einfach. Da kann man sich in Detail immer darüber beschweren, mit irgendwie World Garden und so weiter.
Aber es ist doch alternativlos. Wir haben überhaupt keine andere Wahl, als die Dinge einfacher werden zu lassen. Und am Ende kann man natürlich keine Kontrolle darüber ausüben, was Geisteskind jetzt die Leute sind, die da sich betätigen. Ich denke aber auch, dass man in...
Ich könnte bei Ultraschall einen Gesinnungstest einbauen mit schöner GUI.
Ja, aber ich meine, so ein Nazi-Podcast, es gibt auch welche, die sind nicht in Verzeichnissen. Bisher habe ich zumindest keine gesehen. Aber das wird schon getan. Klar, das wird dann in ihrer eigenen Zielgruppe irgendwie ganz interessant funktionieren.
Ja, aber das hat früher mit Kopierern funktioniert. Du kannst genauso gut sagen, der Fotokopierer hat es einfach gemacht, Fernsehens zu machen und macht es einfach, Nazi-Hatschschriften zu kopieren. Das ist die gleiche Argumentation. Die führt nirgendwo hin. Also die werden immer irgendeine Technik finden, die einfach ist. Und dann will ich lieber die offene Technik einfach haben, als die Plattformen, die im Zweifelsfall dann nicht so offen sind und halt auch die Sachen blockieren, die vielleicht kritisch werden zu hören.
Also ich wollte eigentlich auch nur jetzt dem Tim jetzt mal etwas zugespitzt, hat er gesagt. Podcasts sind jetzt eine wichtige Gegenöffentlichkeit, unter anderem jetzt halt in den USA und bei Trump, weil dort eben dadurch, dass die Leute sich lange unterhalten und intensiv und eben nicht verkürzt und zugespitzt, ist das eine Gegenöffentlichkeit, die so woanders derzeit vielleicht weniger oder nicht mehr stattfindet. Da würde ich sagen, einfach nur, das muss nicht unbedingt so sein.
Okay, aber da lag jetzt nicht mal eine Betonung drauf, sondern das war sozusagen ein Aspekt. Meine Betonung lag eher auf, ich finde es erstaunlich, wie viele Medien oder vielmehr sogar, wie viele Organisationen jetzt auch zu dem Medium Podcast greifen, aus den unterschiedlichsten Gründen. Also gerade bei News-Webseiten, also jetzt nicht News im Sinne von alle 10 Minuten News, sondern vielleicht auch die mit längeren Artikeln, die mir so nachdenken und so weiter. Also fast zwangsläufig sehe ich so, dass die eigentlichen Köpfe, Schreiberteams etc., die Leute, die da sozusagen haben, ihre Metadiskussion in einen Podcast reinlegen. Und das finde ich super. Weil das natürlich auch eine ganz andere Zugänglichkeit zu den Menschen schafft, dadurch verstehst du dann eben auch diese Organisationen besser. Und USA, gut, gibt es jetzt auch, also zum Beispiel gibt es jetzt diesen relativ populären Pod Save America Podcast, ich weiß nicht, ob du davon schon gehört hast. Sehr interessant, weil das sind halt relativ junge Leute, die aber schon im Government gearbeitet haben, so mit 30s Leute, und zwar vor allem Leute, die im Weißen Haus Redenschreiber von Barack Obama waren. Also die einfach auch einen ganz interessanten Einblick in Policy hatten und diese aber auch nach außen formuliert haben. Also auch Leute, die schreiben können, die quasi für die öffentliche Rede gedacht und konzipiert haben. Und die jetzt halt in diesem Podcast alles zusammenwerfen an Betrachtung dieses Wahnsinns, der sich da gerade abgeht, hat auch was Beruhigendes.
Also um dein Ding nochmal aufzugreifen, von wegen Podcast ist etwas, was eigentlich ein längeres Format bevorzugt, finde ich, dass es eigentlich gerade den verkürzten Argumentationen der Nazis eher zuwiderläuft. Weil du in einem langen Podcast eben die Möglichkeit hast, etwas differenziert darzustellen. Und ich glaube auch, dass deswegen das Medium eventuell gar nicht so interessant ist für dich.
Das ist natürlich all das, was Claudia und ich irgendwie seit Jahren und Tim ja auch von Bühnen runter predigen auf der Republikar und so weiter. Aber ich meine, dann guck dir mal an, beispielsweise jetzt so diese ganze Szene, um irgendwie die Erde ist eine Scheibe. Das sind eben auch nicht irgendwie kleine Stücke von zehn Zeilen irgendwie zugespitzt, sondern da hast du also irgendwie 30 Seiten Herleitung, warum die Erde eine Scheibe ist. Das können die halt auch. Das bespielen die auch das Medium. Also ich sage auch nicht, dass ich das glaube, dass es ernsthaft jetzt irgendwie, dass der Podcast jetzt irgendwie dem Faschismus vortrieben kann. Ich habe einfach Angst. Ich habe jetzt gerade ein Kind in die Welt gesagt. Und ich will nicht hinterher, dass der Stockmann mit Ultraschall überhaupt schuld dafür, dass die ganze Sache richtig gegen die Wand gefahren ist. Das würde ich...
Wie hieß es so schön? Um nicht zu sehr von dem Thema abzukommen, wollte ich mal kurz auf mein aktuelles Experiment hinweisen. Was ja auch mal ganz interessant ist. Ich bin da jetzt noch nicht sehr weit gekommen, weil ich gerade noch andere Dinge im Fokus habe, aber ich habe mir mal wieder ein bisschen Audio-Hardware gekauft, die einen sehr schönen Eindruck macht.
Auch bei Podcastern durchaus beliebt.
Ja, wobei ich mich da ganz schön zurückgehalten habe. Ich habe wirklich jetzt schon seit langer, langer Zeit...
Läuft da gerade was drüber?
Nein, nein.
Ach so, okay, gut. Dann darf ich das hier etwas rabiater mal durch die Gegend drehen.
Genau. Also es handelt sich hier konkret um ein Fokus-Ride. Clarett 4Pre-Gerät. Hab ich es richtig zitiert? Ja. Die Clarett-Serie, das kam ja auch schon mal zur Sprache. Ist die Serie von Audio, also die Produktreihe von Audio-Interfaces von Fokus-Ride, die alle mit einem Thunderbolt 2 Anschluss kommen.
Nicht 3.
Das heißt, da gibt es noch nicht mal USB oder so als Fallback, sondern das Ding hat einfach nur Thunderbolt, was ich besonders attraktiv finde. So etwas empfinde ich als Vorteil, wenn so ein Gerät sich in gewisser Hinsicht auch konsequent.
Du bist doch so ein Portkiller.
Darum geht es mir nicht. Aber es ist so, ehrlich gesagt, USB, das ist so ein bisschen die schmutzige Unterhose in diesem ganzen Audiobereich.
Ich würde sagen eher die lange Unterhose.
Nee, nee, das ist die schmutzige Unterhose. Also wenn du so eine Technologie in deinem Produkt überhaupt noch drin hast, also ich rede jetzt von USB 2 oder 3.0, dann...
Meinst du, da ist nicht einfach auch einer drin oder der Port ist nicht rausgeführt? Weißt du gar nicht.
Er spielt aber keine Rolle, wenn es ihn irgendwo intern vielleicht noch gibt und nicht rausgeführt ist. Es muss hier keine Software permanent gefixt werden, damit das irgendwie auch noch läuft, die dann vielleicht Auswirkungen auf das Team hat, vielleicht auch nur dahingehend, dass sie dann keine Zeit hat, sich um die richtigen Sachen zu kümmern. Nun ja, also auf jeden Fall ist das ein halbwegs kompaktes Gerät. Also ich würde es jetzt nicht als super kompakt bezeichnen, trotzdem ist das mein Kandidat, den Zoom H6 abzulösen, den ja alle Podcasts liefern.
Zoom H6 hat ja auch eine Akku eingebaut, oder nicht?
Der Zoom H6 hat eine Akku eingebaut, ja.
Aber der Focus reiht nicht.
Nein, der hat keine Akku eingebaut. Aber ich benutze ja meinen Zoom H6 nicht als Handheld, sondern ich benutze meinen Zoom H6 ja eingebaut in einen Koffer, der dann, wenn er im Betrieb ist, auch immer fest Strom kriegt. Und benutze das eigentlich nur, weil es halt ein kompaktes Gerät ist, wo man ordentlich vier Ports hat und so. Das war so ein bisschen die Motivation. Es gab natürlich auch andere vier-Port-Audio-Interfaces, die im Prinzip hätten in Frage kommen können. Nur war, weiß ich nicht, beim H6 sah das alles sehr vielversprechend aus, hat sich leider nicht so richtig weiterentwickelt. Ich dachte, die kommen ja dann vielleicht mal mit irgendwelchen Firmware-Updates oder zumindest mal mit ein paar Nachfolgern oder irgendwas, aber da tut sich derzeit wenig. Und so ein Thunderbolt-Gerät hat natürlich eine Verheißung, der ich ja nun schon länger nachgeifere, nämlich, dass die ganze Audio-Kommunikation einerseits so stabil ist, dass man einfach nie verkacktes Audio hat.
Einfach nie verkacktes Audio?
Ja, mit USB hast du halt einfach immer mal wieder verkacktes Audio. Das können mir Leute einfach alles Mögliche erzählen.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich bisher nur Firewire-Interfaces benutzt. Insofern kann ich gar nicht mitreden.
Genau. Und jetzt werden sich bestimmt Leute melden, die sagen, ich habe ein USB-Audio-Device und es war immer alles gut. Dann sage ich, gratuliere, Glück gehabt. Die Realität ist anders. Die Realität ist, it sucks.
Obwohl, ich habe ein Zwei-Kanal-USB, das geht. Zwei-Kanal kriege ich da eigentlich immer hin.
Gratuliere.
Also wie oft ich schon USB-Headsets irgendwie rein- und rausstecken muss. Das kann mir einfach keiner erzählen, dass das eine stabile Geschichte ist. Das ist es halt einfach nicht. Und dementsprechend sieht das bei Thunderbolt dann doch schon mal ganz anders aus. Und vor allem heißt Thunderbolt ja im Prinzip auch, dass es sich dabei einfach um ein PCI-Interface handelt und damit natürlich super schnell in den Computer reinkommt und auch wieder heraus. Ich muss gerade mal gucken, welchen Stecker ich hier mal...
Das ist eine dramatische Situation.
Es ist nicht so dringend, die zwei Stunden hab ich noch.
Ja, du sollst deinen Strom kriegen.
Weil Tim jetzt entscheiden muss, welchen von acht Stromsteckern er rauszieht aus einer Steckdosenleiste, wo er einfach nicht der sicherlich ist, wo er was hinfühlt.
Schneide ich das rote oder das grüne Kabel durch? Und mit Thunderbolt kann man halt so Sachen machen, wie das Audiosignal direkt in die Software rein, da mixen und wieder raus. Und man hat halt ein Signal im Kopfhörer, was quasi in Software gemixt ist, aber man merkt es halt nicht. Sprich, die Latenz ist halt einfach niedrig. Und ich habe hier eben mal mit unserem Lieblingstool, diesem Akustik-Roller, habe ich mal nachgemessen. Hast du eigentlich noch Kontakt zu dem Programmierer?
Jetzt länger nicht mehr, aber im Prinzip ja.
Hier ab ist noch 32 Bit. Das heißt, die läuft nicht mehr lange.
Neulich ging es um 200.000 Apps, die angeblich demnächst nicht mehr laufen. Das würde mich nicht wundern. Ich halte das für einen großen Fake, dass Apple das abschaltet.
Nee, werden sie machen. Ich halte die Zahl fast für untertrieben, weil da ist so viel Abandonware-Escore.
Da waren es 20 Millionen.
Ich sagte dir, wenn Apple etwas tut, wahrscheinlich wären sie schon länger gerne diese ganze Abandonware losgeworden.
Es gibt keine billigere Methode, um das Zeug loszusenden.
Und die jetzt mal einfach zu kanten, indem man alles, was 32-Bit ist, dann mal Feierabend sagt, das werden sie tun. Also wenn sie etwas tun, dann das.
Und die Zahl 200.000 ist auch eher ein Minimum.
Aber das ist dann ein Drittel der Apps, würde ich sagen, auf meinem iPhone plötzlich useless ist. Und den Shitstorm wird dann schon Apple abbekommen. Wie nicht useless.
Wenn du update hast, hast du sie nicht mehr.
Ja, genau.
Sie sind nicht useless, die sind dann weg.
Ja, das ist nicht gut. Also das war glaube ich noch nicht Thema einer Freak Show, oder? Also ich finde, ihr seid da gerade sehr tiefenentspannt dafür, dass das, glaube ich, einer der größten Shitstorms mit Ansage ist, die Apple jemals hätte erleben können.
Das wird Apple so dermaßen null kratzen.
Na ja, aber es ist... You're holding it wrong. Also wir reden hier von, wie viel... Haben wir irgendwie über eine Milliarde iOS-User? Also ich meine, das ist ein bisschen eine andere Hausmarke, als ob jetzt irgendwie der Mac Pro scheiße ist oder nicht. Also ernsthaft, Leute, das ist hier Big Business. Ich wette einen mittelhohen Betrag, dass Apple das nicht macht.
Das würde ich nicht an deiner Stelle tun, weil das, glaube ich, das wirst du einfach verlieren. They will do it. Und ich hoffe auch, ehrlich gesagt, dass sie es tun.
Also wir können gerne um ein Bier wetten, aber... Also gut, vielleicht machen sie es doch nicht. Also, ähm, und...
Sie werden es.
Machen den Requestern noch viel gemeiner?
Nein, sie haben es ja schon angekündigt.
Na gut, wir haben hier jemanden sitzen, Heiko. Wie häufig haben sie angekündigt, dass sie was an unseren P-List-Verwaltung... Damals, als wir noch immer Dingens drin hatten, Soundflower. Seit wie vielen Releases wollten sie das angeblich abschalten und sie haben dann immer einen Tag... Also in der letzten Beta war es schon draußen und in dem Release-Candidate ist es dann plötzlich wieder reingepoppt. Weil, oh mein Gott, wir haben es doch nicht abgeschaltet. Wie häufig hatten wir das Spielchen?
Bis auf die letzte Developer-Beta, ja.
Ich wette einen mittelhohen Geldbetrag darauf. Also ich habe alleine, ich glaube, 5-10 Apps, die mir im Wochentakt jetzt diese Warnung geben. Von denen mein Leben abhängt. Ich persönlich werde Apple hassen.
Ja, dein Herzschrittmacher-App, oder was?
Wann sind denn diese Apps das letzte Mal überhaupt aktualisiert worden?
Völlig egal, sie funktionieren. They just work. Sie brauchen keine Updates. Sie tun genau das, was ich von ihnen will. Ich brauche keine Updates für diese Apps. Ich brauche einfach nur, dass diese Apps mit ihrem derzeitigen Funktionsumfang die nächsten 30 Jahre weiterlaufen.
Das war nicht meine Frage. Die Frage war, wann haben sie das letzte Mal ein Update bekommen?
Vor, weiß ich nicht, 2-3 Jahren? Aber völlig egal.
Ist es die Programmierer noch?
Mir völlig egal. Die App funktioniert. Und das ist das, was meine Mutter denkt. Das ist was, was deine Mutter denkt. Und deine, und deine, und deine, und deine. Die wollen keine Logik. Die wollen, dass ihr iPhone, das sie lieben, mit genau den Apps, die sie lieben, morgen noch funktioniert. Und ob dann irgendein Developer sich zurückgezogen hat und gestorben ist oder einen anderen Job hat, ist denen scheißegal. Gestern hat die App noch funktioniert. Ich wollte nie neue Features, ich wollte nie neues Design. Ich wollte einfach nur, dass diese eine Funktion von dieser einen App die nächsten 30 Jahre funktioniert. So, und Apple geht hin und schaltet mir das ab. Das wird ein Shitstorm, wie ihn die Welt noch nicht gesehen hat.
Funktioniert 30 Jahre lang.
Na ja, wir könnten jetzt irgendwie so mit Linux-Technologien, E-Mail, also das eine oder andere wird mir da schon einfallen.
IPv4 hat, glaube ich, 30 Jahre ganz gut funktioniert.
So, und wir reden hier schon...
Was ich mir vorstellen kann, ist, dass sie tatsächlich keine 32-Bit-Apps mehr in den Store lassen. Und dass du wahrscheinlich auch 32-Bit-Apps nicht mehr neu kaufen kannst. Im App Store. Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Ob sie sie dann tatsächlich auch für das upcoming iOS abschalten? Wie gut, das wird man dann sehen.
Ach so, die Unterscheidung muss man natürlich noch mal machen. Aber sie haben ja jetzt bei diesen 32-Bit-Apps, wo derzeit die Warnung kommt, könnte langsam laufen. Kommt ja bei dem 10.3-Update, habe ich gelesen, der Hinweis wird in einem zukünftigen Betriebssystem-Update nicht mehr funktionieren.
Darum merke ich das auch, tagtäglich.
Muss aber nicht unbedingt jetzt bedeuten, dass Version 11 die Apps schon sofort wegschmeißt. Kann aber sein, dass sie dann schon nicht mehr im App-Store sind.
Das ist glaube ich jetzt schon der Fall.
Sie sind dann sozusagen nicht mehr zu kaufen.
Richtig, das ist jetzt schon so. Ich glaube, so fünf meiner Apps, die ich hier drauf habe, sind nicht mehr im Store erhältlich.
Ja, aber nicht, weil sie 32-Bit sind.
Ich glaube schon.
Das kann auch andere Gründe haben.
Das kann viele andere Gründe haben. Ich gucke einfach mal, ob dieser Akustik-Ruler jetzt noch drin ist.
Zum Beispiel im Mac App-Store.
Der ist drin.
Kannst du alte Mac-OS-Versionen nicht mehr neu kaufen oder runterladen? Wenn du die in deinem Account hast, als bereits gekauft, kannst du sie nach wie vor runterladen. Aber du kannst sie nicht mehr neu beziehen.
Also wirklich nochmal auf eine einfache Formel runtergebrochen. Ich verstehe euer Punkt. Ich sehe, dass Apple bei solchen Dingen normalerweise sehr konsequent ist. Aber vergesst nicht, verlasst mal kurz eure Nerd-Bubble. Es geht hier um eure Eltern. Nein, nein, es geht nicht um meine Eltern. Es geht um die normalen Leute der Raum. Und es geht um die einzige echte Cash-Cash-Cow, die Apple hat.
Na ja, meine Eltern haben bis jetzt noch kein Smartphone. Das ist mir eigentlich nicht ganz positiv. Geräte, die meine Eltern nicht haben, für die muss ich keinen Support leisten.
Es gibt einfach so viele gute Gründe, voranzuschreiten.
Nein, nicht wenn diese App funktioniert.
Doch, dann gibt es auch trotzdem sehr viele gute Gründe. Also erstens heißt, alte 32-Bit-APIs, die durch moderne 64-Bit-APIs ersetzt wurden, und zwar nicht nur, weil sie 64-Bit sind, sondern weil sie auch...
Deine Mutter hört dir jetzt schon nicht mehr zu. Sorry, aber das ist das Argument, was Apple, glaube ich, letztendlich dem Witz ums Geld geht.
Nein, also die technischen Gründe, über die müssen wir uns ja nicht unterhalten.
Moment, Moin, doch, selbstverständlich müssen wir uns darüber unterhalten. Ich hab gerade angefangen, mich darüber zu unterhalten. Ich sag mal eins, Security. Um Security wirklich den Anforderungen, die da draußen nun mal bestehen, um sich am laufenden Meter weiterzuentwickeln, um die mitzuhalten, musst du deine Codebase am laufenden Meter verbessern. Das tun sie mit IOS. Und weiß ja gar ja, welche Klimmzüge sie da als nächstes noch mit reinholen.
Da hab ich ein kleines TIT-Bit zu. SHA-1 signierte Zertifikate.
Und das muss sich einfach am laufenden Meter ändern. Irgendwann musst du einfach auch alte Zöpfe einfach abschneiden. Ist halt einfach so. Und 32-Bit ist halt jetzt in der Lifetime von IOS ein ganz interessanter Punkt. Also ich meine, dieses läuft schneller, läuft langsamer und so weiter. Ja, 64-Bit-Code läuft tatsächlich schneller als der 32-Bit-Code. Durch die Weiterentwicklung des ARM-Befehlseits konkret auf diesen Dingern. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Grund. Aber was es ja auch in vielen Stellen bedeutet, also 32-Bit-Apps sind ja meistens auch noch für iOS 6 mal designt worden. Das trifft nicht unbedingt auf alle zu, aber auf sehr, sehr, sehr viele. Das heißt, damit geben sie sozusagen auch dem alten UI-Kram auch so ein bisschen.
Na, jetzt vermischst du aber Dinge.
Ja, ich vermische Dinge, habe ich ja auch gesagt. Es gibt da verschiedene Sachen, die sie mit diesem Cut abschneiden.
Ist auch meiner Mutter auch egal, wie das Design aussieht.
Das war immer mit diesen meine Mutter. Das ist doch auch sexistische Kack-Scheiße. Irgendwie die Mutter sagt dein Vater.
Mein Vater auch. Wir haben übrigens beide keine iOS-Devices.
Das ist immer ein tolles Beispiel.
Also ich verstehe, dass es hier ein Problem gibt, aber wenn sie diesen Druck nicht aufbauen auf die Developer, wird sich da halt nichts ändern.
Der Punkt ist aber, ausbaden werden ist die User, nicht die Developer.
Also die User müssen sich halt bei ihren Developern melden.
Die haben keine E-Mail mehr, an die sie schreiben können. Da ist einfach gar kein Developer mehr. Der interessiert sich dafür nicht mehr. Der ist einfach mal weg. Die User haben ihr Geld bezahlt. Sie haben eine App, die genau das leistet, was sie wollen. Es gibt keine andere. Sie können keine Datenmigration machen. Es ist Abandonware, aber sie funktioniert halt.
Ja, aber dann merkst du halt, dass dein Butler seit Jahren ein Zombie ist.
Ja, aber solange er mir das leckere Essen auf den Tisch stellt und mich nicht anknabbert, ist mir das ziemlich egal.
Das tut er dann vielleicht mal.
Dein Butler ist ein Zombie.
Ja, das Schöne ist ja, wir werden es bald erleben. Also dann gucken, was passiert. Ich wäre mir da nicht so sicher. Also wie gesagt, ich kann das alles logisch total nachvollziehen. Aber ich glaube, Apple ist nicht, die werden das Risiko nicht eingehen bei ihrer Hauptcash Cow. Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Also ich denke, die 32-Bit-Apps sind raus aus dem Store mit iOS 11.
Das glaube ich auch.
Wahrscheinlich schon mit 10.3 oder so. Kann durchaus sein, dass du keine neuen kaufen kannst.
Kann auch schon sein, ja. Und dann sind sie mit 11 irgendwie weiter beschnitten.
10.3 und SHA-1. Es gibt ja dieses Transport Layer Security, was glaube ich bei iOS 9 neu war.
Dein Butler ist ein Zombie, guter Sendungstitel.
Ja, würde ich auch so sehen. Wenn du mit deinem eigenen Server reden willst, du willst das Security-konform machen, dann hat Apple so ein Transport Layer Security-Dings da geschrieben, was gewisse Dinge enthält. Und wenn du dich nicht daran hältst, brauchst du eine Ausnahmegenehmigung. Sie haben jetzt zu 10.3...
Aber du musst aktiv was tun.
Du musst aktiv was tun. Und SHA-1-signierte Zertifikate sind jetzt aus dem Transport Layer Security rausgefallen, nach dem Shattered. Weil ihr habt ja letztes Mal davon geredet, ich kann zu SHA-1 noch mehr sagen, aber das ist ja jetzt nicht Thema.
Ja, aber das zeigt ganz schön, also Security ist einfach in zunehmendem Maße eine Anforderung, die erfordert, dass Dinge sich öfter ändern. Ich sage jetzt auch gar nicht, Apple steht hier in keiner Pflicht, weil ich denke, was sie sehr, sehr, sehr schlecht getan haben, ist, sie haben für Indie-Developer, kleine Developer, den App Store einfach nicht richtig weiterentwickelt und tun es auch bis heute nicht.
Für alle Developer nicht.
Das hat nichts mit Indie zu tun. Ich denke, da gibt es schon ein paar Große, die leben ganz wunderbar von diesem ganzen Apparat mit ihrem ganzen Scheiß inner-Purchase-Klimb.
Mit 10.3 wird es halt die Möglichkeit geben, dass der Developer tatsächlich auf App Store Reviews antworten kann. Und dieses komische Build-in-Review-Dialog. Mal sehen, wie sich das entwickelt.
Was ist das?
Na, du hast doch eigentlich in allen Apps diesen Battle-Dialog drin. Bitte rate uns im App Store. Hat dir die App gefallen? Ja, nein. Wenn du Ja sagst, rate uns. Wenn du Nein sagst, dann kommst du auf irgendeine Hilfe-Seite. Das ist das Übliche. Und jetzt hat Apple tatsächlich zu 10.3 einen offiziellen Dialog reingebaut, den du benutzen kannst, um dieses App Store-Rating von deiner App aus auszulösen. Bis jetzt gibt es keine Ansage dazu, dass du den benutzen musst, wenn du nach einem App Store-Rating fragen willst oder so. Aber das wird sicherlich noch kommen.
Das kann ich dann systemweit abschalten.
Das weiß ich nicht. Soweit habe ich nicht geguckt. Ja, und du kannst deinen Icon verändern. Das kannst du auch machen.
Das stimmt.
Das ist alles neu. Aber lassen wir das. Wo waren wir? Ach so, das war das.
Irgendwas mit Zombies.
Irgendwas mit Zombies. Da habe ich sogar noch einen Topic. Nach wie vor ist es so, dass der App Store für niemanden irgendwie gut ist. Klar, die Art und Weise, wie er funktioniert, bevorzugt diese Schlumpfbeeren-Spiele. Die laufen wirklich relativ gut. Das hat inzwischen Apple auch eingesehen und bewirbt die nur noch sehr sparsam. In letzter Zeit habe ich das Gefühl, dass Spiele, die Geld kosten und einem dann wirklich auch allen Spiel-Content auf einmal bieten, gerne mehr gefeaturet werden jetzt im App-Store, als das noch von einem Jahr war. Aber im Großen und Ganzen wüsste ich jetzt nicht, warum es den Großen jetzt da besser gehen sollte als den Kleinen. Gut, die Großen basteln meistens ihre Wertschöpfungskette um das ganze iOS außen rum und haben ihre eigene Serverinfrastruktur. Und verdienen ihr Geld gar nicht damit, dass sie im App-Store Geld machen müssen, sondern machen das irgendwo anders.
Die Großen haben einfach eine andere Bekanntheitsgrad und eine ganz andere Möglichkeit, sich Featuren zu lassen und sich über Werbung und Secondary-Maßnahmen im Rennen zu halten. Die Indie-Developer hängen traditionell sehr viel mehr davon ab, eine explizite Kundenbindung zu ihren Usern herzustellen und da eben Vertrauen aufzubauen und dann eben auch so eine Investition über die Zeit zu machen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich verstehe ehrlich gesagt bis heute noch nicht, warum gibt es keine Upgrades? Das will mir nicht in den Kopf. Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was bitte an ihrem iOS-Modell, an ihrem AppStore-Modell, das nicht vollhängt.
Kein neues Thema, ich gebe dir total recht. Ja, keine Demo, keine Upgrades und kein Kontakt zum Kunden. Das sind die drei großen Schmerzpunkte im AppStore.
Genau, und deswegen ist es halt schwierig. Das ist das, was sie halt irgendwie fixen müssen. Aber dieses 32-Bit-Apps müssen dann irgendwann mal sterben, da gehe ich mit. Ich sehe das auch. Und es ist auch jetzt nicht so, dass ich jetzt auf meinem iPhone keine Apps hätte, die ich auch gerne noch weiter benutzen möchte und wo es mir ein bisschen wehtun würde, wenn die komplett rausfallen. So. Aber ich hab halt auch gerne ein sicheres Telefon.
Also ich kontaktiere mal den Entwickler, eigentlich um die Latenzmessung, um das acoustic ruler und sag ich mal.
Ich hab meine ganze Claretten-Geschichte noch gar nicht zu Ende erzählt, ne?
Aber 32 Bit ist doch per se jetzt kein Sicherheitsrisiko. Also die Argumentation verstehe ich jetzt auch nicht so ganz.
Nein, aber alte Software ist ein Sicherheitsrisiko, weil wenn sie, insbesondere wenn sie nicht weiter entwickelt wird, weil sie sich immer an die neuen Gepflugen halten, das ist doch gerade eben selber mit TLS und so weiter, neue CD-Mechanismen, HTTPS verwenden, etc., Also das ist halt einfach ein Problem, das hast du an der Backe und auch gerade, wenn du halt jetzt mal auch alte Scheiße wegschmeißen willst, willst ja auch dieses iOS nicht ewig aufblähen und immer kompatibel zu allem sein lassen. Also in dem Moment, wo du 32 Bit killst, killst du ja quasi auch alles, was bis 64 Bit auf dem Zeiger war. Also du kannst halt sehr viel deprecate und kannst sehr viel, also nicht nur deprecate, sondern du kannst es dann auch wirklich entfernen.
Da müssen wir uns nicht darüber streiten.
Der Code, der nicht da ist, kann nicht falsch funktionieren und muss auch nicht mehr supported werden. Und das ist insofern ganz gut. Soll ich denn hier meine Clarett-Geschichte nochmal zu Ende erzählen?
Aber ja, wenn es noch was gibt.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht.
Ist da zwei Kopfhörerausgänge?
Wir sind bei der Latenz leider nur zwei Kopfhörerausgänge. Das finde ich ein bisschen schade. Vier wären geil. Ja, und sie sind auch mit den Outputs hinten gekoppelt, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Das heißt...
Also die Line-Outs.
Die Line-Outs sind damit gekoppelt, glaube ich. So hat sich mir das dargestellt. Ich habe jetzt noch nicht so viel Zeit damit verbracht mit dem Device. Fände ich in gewisser Hinsicht ein bisschen schade, weil ich irgendwie mit vier Outputs auch noch was anderes anfangen kann. Und ich dachte, Kopfhörer ist da vielleicht entkoppelt. Muss ich noch mal schauen, ob mir das ausreicht. Aber ich will halt im Prinzip ein mobiles Studio bauen für vier Headsets und ich möchte halt jetzt auch langsam mal den Mix komplett in Software machen. Weil das ist halt einfach mit Reaper. Geht das einfach gut? So, man kann halt Equalizer gleich anbringen, etc. Du kannst im Idealfall das Setup auch so machen, dass nur wenn dein Recording auch läuft, du was hörst.
Das heißt, läuft dein Recording nicht, merkst du das so, wirken instantan.
Reuspartasten sind ein Riesending. Man könnte auch Expander zum Einsatz bringen.
Ja, also ich habe ja mit Dennis Mohr das mal durchgetestet. Wir sind mal verschiedene Effekte durchgegangen innerhalb von Reaper. Wie viel Latenz bringen die eigentlich dann zusätzlich rein? Ja, und es gibt echt viele Effekte, gerade die von Apple selber, die praktisch überhaupt nichts nennenswertes da zusätzlich reinbringen. Also diese JSFX-Geschichte, auf die wir jetzt vermehrt setzen, auch mit Ultraschall 3, weil sie einfach kompatibel auch zur Windows-Welt ist, die sind alle signifikant langsamer. Aber die Apple-Interneffekte, da gibt es wirklich viele, die de facto latenzfrei arbeiten, also unter 0,5 Millisekunde drauf, irgendwie so, das ist also wirklich nicht, oder 0,1 Millisekunde, glaube ich sogar. Und auch so eine in Echtzeit Mute-Funktion, das hatten wir auch schon mal gebastelt, das funktioniert schon alles. Also, man muss da nur eine Menge denken und sich ein paar Gedanken machen, halt so, und das alles mal so vernünftig durchmodellieren, aber so per se ist das eigentlich verstanden, das Thema.
Und dieser Fear-Pre, den ich hier habe, also ich habe jetzt vorhin mit dem Akustik-Roller gemessen und ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube, der misst falsch. Ich habe so ein bisschen kalibriert und pipapo, vielleicht liegt es doch daran, dass es 32 Bits ist.
Vielleicht liegt es daran, dass du einen neuen Airpods genommen hast über Bluetooth.
Nein, nein, auf jeden Fall, das Ding hat irgendwie Roundtrip vom Mikrofon zum Kopfhörer, also einmal durch Reaper durch, in den Rechner rein, über Thunderbolt und wieder raus, mir 0,5 Millisekunden angezeigt.
Das wäre sehr schnell.
Das wäre allerdings sehr schnell.
Du sagtest aber 96 Kilohertz Abtas-Drigens. Ich habe es ausgerechnet, es wären 48 Samples. Das ist realistisch.
Ja, realistisch ist aber vor allem das, was Fokus-Ride auf seiner eigenen Webseite angibt. Da ist es halt bei 96 Kilohertz spezifiziert mit 1,2 Millisekunden. Da fände ich dann 0,5 Millisekunden schon so ein bisschen hart.
Es kann sein, dass man da irgendwo in so einem Edge-Messbereich wieder ist, dass da irgendwo seine Algorithmus ein bisschen... Gestartet, die App ist ja, um irgendwie Abstände innerhalb von einem Raum zu messen.
Ja, also da sollten wir nochmal auch... Ich weiß nicht, gibt es überhaupt eine andere zuverlässige Methode Latenzen, Audiolatenzen, zu messen?
Du hattest noch mal eine Geschichte in Reefer gebaut, dass dann auch der Ausgang wieder reingeht und man dann quasi halt in einem selben Peak auf der Timeline ausmesst.
Ich brauch ja nur mein eigenes Signal einmal durch, durchlöten und wieder aufnehmen und dann... Genau, stimmt.
Das könntest du zur Verifizierung oder Falsifizierung mal dazunehmen.
Genau, das muss ich mal machen.
Oder halt mit einem ganz normalen, normalen Analogen aus Zyloskop.
Aber gut, die Essenz wird trotzdem sein, es ist sau schnell. So, das ist natürlich schon mal gut.
Genau, es ist sau schnell und es ist auch so sau schnell, dass ich so den Eindruck habe, dass man eben auch schon so ein paar nicht so zeitfressende Plugins halt drauf werfen kann und damit kann man halt dann schon sehr angenehme Environments machen. Und mittelfristig überlege ich natürlich sowas auch hier im Studio zu machen. Da müsste man halt darüber nachdenken, ob so ein Interface hier auch in Frage kommt und mein IP-basiertes System hier ablöst, was mir so ein bisschen schmerzen würde. Das wäre schon geil. Also stateless Audio hat was.
Ich habe es übrigens gerade nachgeguckt. Also der erste Kopfhörerausgang ist immer der Ausgang 1,2 auf der Rückseite. Und der zweite Kopfhörerausgang ist, unabhängig davon, ist also nicht 3,4 auf der Rückseite.
Das heißt, 1,2 ist Master und der zweite Kopfhörerausgang ist... 5,6.
Ist 5,6 in der Software. Und 3,4 ist aber unabhängig von dem 5,6 des zweiten Kopfhörerausgangs.
Das heißt, wenn ich nur den zweiten benutze, habe ich vier Ports komplett frei.
Genau. Also so steht es in der Anleitung.
Ja, wäre noch schöner, wenn sie dem Teil gleich mal vier Kopfhörer verpasst hätten. Das wäre grandios. Dann hätte man überhaupt nichts mehr gebraucht. Also muss ich mir mal überlegen, wie ich das mache.
Das ist aber bei allen Audio-Interfaces so, dass du unglaublich viele Eingänge hast und irgendwie immer nur eine Handvoll Ausgänge. Ich verstehe nicht, was das soll.
Es ist ein Elend. Das ist einfach nicht deren Use-Case. Also deren Use-Case sind halt immer Musiker, Musiker, Musiker, Musiker. Und hier sitzen natürlich nicht alle irgendwie mit Kopfhörern da dran, sondern...
Ja, aber trotzdem, selbst wenn du so viele Musiker... Du willst ja gerne dann auch einen unterschiedlichen Monitormixer machen für Studio-Musiker, die zusammen spielen. Also das ist irgendwie so...
Ja, das ist schon... also ist auch für den Preis. Also ich hab jetzt gerade mal geguckt, dass 699 werden hier so aufgerufen. Gut, das ist noch mal signifikant über dem H6, aber jetzt auch nicht irgendwie um Größenordnung halt. Das ist schon nicht unspannend so. Hat halt zwei strategische Nachteile gegenüber dem H6. Das eine ist halt irgendwie keine Batterie. Dann auch nicht die Möglichkeit irgendeinen... Also bei dem H6 hast du ja dieses auch ziemlich geile XY-Mikro. Also beispielsweise machen wir an der Stabi Staatsbiothek zu Berlin preußischer Kulturbesitz Podiumsdiskussionen und so was, indem ich einfach ein H6 auf dem Stativ da auf dem Tisch drauf baue. Das XY-Mikro ist echt saugut vom H6. Hast du sie halt auch nicht.
Ja, aber das spielt ja überhaupt nicht in dieser Liga von mobilem Aufnehmen. Ich benutze ja den H6 für was anderes. Weil ich immer ein mobiles 4-Port-XLR-Device haben wollte.
Ja, und größtes Dropout-Kriterium ist natürlich nur 48 Volt Phantomspeisung. Nicht 12 Volt wie das H6. Da laufen die HMC 660 nicht drauf.
Ach, diese China-Willig-Dinger.
Die immer noch wunderbar ohne einen einzigen Ausfall da draußen ihren Dienst tun. Wo hier in der Freak Show schon vor exakt einem Jahr prognostiziert würde, wie die alle auseinanderfallen. Das ist nicht passiert.
Was werden wir noch erleben, wenn die überhaupt noch in Betrieb sind?
Na, was ich prognostiziert hatte, aber was scheinbar auch nicht passiert ist, ist, dass die irgendwann halt andere Bauteile in ihre Production leihen tun und sie dann plötzlich ganz anders klingen und sich ganz anders verhalten.
Ja, ich habe einen dreiviertel Jahr später gekauft. Das klingt immer noch so. Also von daher, nun ja.
Gute chinesische Technik.
Ja, das optimale Ziel wäre natürlich, so ein Setup zu finden mit Ultraschall, wo man dann eben auch mal so ganz intelligentes Routing machen kann. Also gerade so für den Online-Betrieb. Also wenn man so im Studio sitzt, möchte man ja zum Beispiel auch sich mal über die Headsets unterhalten. Das ist mal was, mal so als Input hier für eure künftigen Experimente. Zum Beispiel, jetzt sitzen wir so hier, haben alle so Headsets auf und dann gibt es immer mal wieder so Kommunikationsbedarf zwischen Leuten, die gerade nicht reden.
Roddy aufwachen.
Man schaut sich an, will sich was sagen, fängt dann an rum zu gestikulieren. Dabei wäre es doch viel sinnvoller, man würde einfach die V-Mode in die Hand nehmen, drückt irgendwie auf die B-Taste. Und solange die B-Taste gedrückt ist, ist man in einem anderen Backchannel und kann sich dann einfach mal ganz sanft so zuflüstern. So was finde ich halt nice. Das wird dann eben einfach durch Software-Routing überhaupt erst denkbar und wäre einfach mal ein geiles Teil. Also mir gefällt dieses Thunderbolt-Teil irgendwie.
1,35 Kilogramm laut Andereleitung.
Es ist schwer und wird heiß, ja?
Ja, es ist schwer, wird heiß, braucht mehr Platz.
Also im Rucksack ist das schon brocken gegenüber dem H6.
Ja klar, aber ich habe es ja auch nicht im Rucksack, sondern ich habe mir einen speziellen Koffer gebaut, wo das H6 drin ist, mit den ganzen anderen Kram.
Der Koffer ist so schwer, da kommt es darauf, wie man es hat.
Ja eben, genau.
Damit der Petteleporter auch materialisiert er sich. Also ich finde, Gewicht ist schon immer ein Faktor, egal, wo du irgendwie unterwegs bist.
Klar, aber wenn ich damit unterwegs bin, dann habe ich den eher auf dem Bollerwagen. Also ich habe immer mit dem Koffer, weil ich schleppe mich nicht mit so einem Teil ab, sondern wenn ich mit dem Zug fahre, da habe ich einfach so einen Bollerwagen, schneide den drauf, mache Spannleute drum herum. So ein Handkarren. Eine Sackkarre. Eine Sackkarre, so eine aufklappbare halt so. Und das funktioniert ganz gut. Die kann man mit Festbereifung, wie ich das jetzt gerade habe, oder eben auch mit Luftbereifung, wo ich vielleicht demnächst mal darauf wechseln werde, weil so Kopfsteinflasser und so weiter immer nicht so gut. Dang, dang, ist auch zu laut. Und man hat immer so ein bisschen Angst, dass die Geräte dann doch zu viel Schaden nehmen. Ja, aber so ein kompakt Koffer, der eben gerade noch ins Fluggepäck reinpasst. Also das ist dann so overhead. Also in der Kabine mitnehmen kannst, weil da eben den Abmessungen entspricht.
Okay, und Amerika seit neuestem, aber...
Wieso, das gilt doch nur für Laptops.
Für alle Geräte, die größer sind als ein Smartphone. Also auch für Tablets, sowas wie ein iPad. Für Laptops.
Ja, nur wenn da ein Lithium-... Ja, ein Jojoko drin ist, der ist bei mir nie drin. Außerdem nur, wenn der aus den Arabien einreist, und überhaupt können die mich alle mal am Arsch lenken.
Nee, will man nicht.
Sorry, liebe USA, es war schön mit euch, aber sorry.
Jetzt habt ihr diesen Wahnsinnigen gewählt, jetzt ist es vorbei.
Fangt euch erstmal ein, und ihr Briten auch, und ruft an, wenn ihr wieder klar gekommen seid. Bis dahin beschäftigen wir uns mit anderen Sachen. So, und so ein Köferchen werde ich mir mit diesem Focus-Ride zusammenklöppeln, was ein bisschen größer ist, als das, was ich derzeit habe, damit auch meine ganzen Kabellagen und so weiter da reinpassen und die Stecker mal ordentlich verkleidet sind, und dann natürlich alles auf mein 5-Pol-XLR-System, was ich hier generell verwende, was ich ja immer noch tausendmal besser finde, als diesen oldschooligen XLR-Klinke-Dualismus, den alle fahren, weil es halt schon immer so war. Aber es ist einfach mega unpraktisch. Und insofern blicke ich in eine mobile Zukunft mit Fokusreit. Auch wenn ihr da mit eurer Treiber-Update-Politik auch nochmal ein bisschen nachlegen könnt.
Also doch Treiber. Weil du irgendwann mal gesagt hast, Audio-Interface sollte möglichst ohne Treiber sein.
Ein USB-Audio-Interface sollte ohne Treiber sein. Ja, oder? Ja, bei Firewire war das spezifiziert. Bei Thunderbolt, meines Wissens, gibt's, weiß ich, nichts von der Audio-Spezifikation. Das ist ja da auch nochmal ein bisschen komplexer, weil letzten Endes Thunderbolt ist ja im Wesentlichen so PCI. Genau. Was nicht heißt, dass man das nicht machen könnte. Und vielleicht wäre das auch nochmal ganz schön, aber ich will jetzt auch nicht zu sehr aus dem Fenster lehnen. Klar, also das ist ein Problem. Die Driver-Software gehört natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht zum Programm, zur Hardware dazu. Und wenn das halt dann nicht gut ist, dann ist halt auch die Hardware nicht gut. So sieht's aus. Und das ist im Audiobereich auch immer schon so ein bisschen schwierig gewesen, aber gut. Also, weiß ja, man kann, you can't have it all. Sogar ich muss manchmal kompromissieren.
Die blutende Kante heißt nicht umsonst so.
Die blutet dann halt auch manchmal ein bisschen.
So, Audio.
Audio durch.
Genau.
Nao Video.
Ich wollte mal, ich wollte mal, genau.
Das war kein Scherz.
Also eigentlich, kommen wir jetzt vom Programm her, sind wir jetzt schon wieder komplett weg, aber vielleicht kommen wir da noch drauf. Aber bevor wir das verpassen. Ich wollte mal die Gelegenheit nutzen, wo du jetzt schon da bist, Ralf, und ich weiß, dass sich dieses Thema auch sehr innerlich sehr tangiert. Die Frage der heimischen, heimatlichen AV-Bespaßung ist ja ein sehr komplexes Thema.
Ich wurde von meiner Frau mal beauftragt, ein Medienkonzept für unser Wohnzimmer zu entwerfen, bevor weitere Hardware-Investitionen getätigt werden. Ich fand, das war ein fairer Deal, weil die Spielregeln waren, entwirf ein vernünftiges Konzept und dann können wir dafür auch Geld ausgeben, aber nicht wahllos irgendeinen Kram kaufen. Ich liebe meine Frau sehr.
Aber wenn man im Jahre 1900... Nee, schon gar nicht. 2017!
Mir wär's fast nicht aufgefallen.
Ich hoffe, es hören noch ein paar Jugendliche zu. Also wenn man in diesen Zeiten einen Bildschirm erwerben will, wird's ja wirklich richtig haarig.
Du meinst große Fläche in bunt mit selbst beleuchtet?
Genau, große Fläche in bunt selbst beleuchtet. Weil ich besitze zwar einen Fernseher, aber der zeigt halt so ein bisschen so Schwächen. Das liegt vor allem daran, dass das Teil, der eigentliche Receiver, also das, was quasi aus einem Kabelanschluss zum Beispiel ein Fernsehsignal rauszieht oder über HDMI-Ports entsprechende Video- und Tonsignale entgegennimmt, dass dieses Gerät mit dem eigentlichen Bildschirm nicht durch ein Kabel verbunden ist, sondern durch Funk, über irgendeine magische 5 Gigahertz-basierte Sony-spezifische Übertragungsweise.
Okay, was ist jetzt das Videosignal?
Und Audiosignal. Okay, also sie haben quasi einen Funk...
Den Magic 5 Gigahertz-Link.
Genau, die haben einen Magic 5 Gigahertz-Link zwischen Receiver und Fernseher, also Bildschirm, der, wenn er irgendeinem Standard entspricht, bin ich bewusst, welcher Standard das ist.
Dein neuer Sony-Fernseher.
Neu ist der nicht.
Okay.
Der ist eher alt, also der ist jetzt...
Und lass mich raten, das ist so zuverlässig, wie es jetzt klingt?
Naja, also sagen wir mal so, wenn du die beiden einzelnen Elemente weiter als drei Meter voneinander entfernt hast, dann wird's schon schwierig. Also optimal steht das Ding dann doch eigentlich direkt da drunter. So ein bisschen so dieses, du kannst das Teil halt an die Wand hängen und das einzige Kabel, was da hingehen muss, ist Strom, aber ist natürlich dann irgendwie eigentlich auch scheißegal.
Dann können es auch zwei sein.
Dann können es auch zwei sein, also von daher so richtig sinnvoll ist das irgendwie nicht, aber es ist halt mal so ein Produkt gewesen, was Sony hatte und mir befreundete Firma hat die Dinger mal gekauft, dann für ihren Einsatz zwecklich als überlebensfähig angesehen und dann habe ich die irgendwie vergleichsweise günstig geschossen, das Teil, so und jetzt habe ich das halt noch. Jetzt natürlich auch so so ein Teil, dann habe ich mal angefangen im Rahmen der ganzen Home-Automatisierungstests auch mal den Strom zu messen, der da so durchgeht. Das ist auch schon ganz gut. Das Gute ist, das Teil läuft halt nicht so oft, von daher fällt das jetzt nicht so auf, aber würde das so dauerhaft laufen? Ich weiß nicht, was hat der gefressen? Jetzt kriege ich glaube ich die ganzen Zahlen durcheinander. Das war schon ordentlich, ich glaube so 150 Watt hat der schon verbraten. Das ist auch ein relativ großes Teil. Und das war nur der Bildschirm, nicht noch der Receiver, den muss man im Prinzip noch dazurechnen. Also ich würde mal sagen, insgesamt dürfte das wahrscheinlich so mit 200 Watt dabei sein. Kann ja mal gucken, was es so gibt. Heutzutage kann man ja dann seine Laptops auch irgendwie über HDMI anschließen. Und es gibt ja auch schon 4K-Bildschirme und das geht jetzt auch schon mit den Computern. Und wenn man sich sowieso schon so eine Funzel hinhängt, dann möchte man dann vielleicht auch irgendwann mal so in diese 4K-Welt vorstoßen. Und vielleicht gibt es noch ein paar andere Annehmlichkeiten. Die Bildschirme sind ja auch besser geworden und die LCDs sind...
Und 3D ist wieder weg.
Ja, 3D ist wieder weg und Curved hat mich noch nie interessiert.
Das hab ich übrigens total verpennt, ehrlich gesagt. Vor einem Monat hieß es, 3D ist übrigens weg. Da war ich so, was? Wie? Wieso ist 3D weg jetzt?
Das war Steading-Ovation.
Kommen wir vielleicht hinterher noch zu, aber egal.
So, ja, dann guck ich mal so, was kostet das so? Und dann hast du ja dann immer diese bekloppten Webseiten, wo du dann so, ja, was du gerne hättest und die Auswahlfelder, die bedienen einen immer nicht so richtig, weil man irgendwie entweder keine Ranges angeben kann oder nur sagen kann, was man haben will, aber nicht einfach mal sagen kann, dass man eigentlich alles haben will, aber nur etwas bestimmtes nicht haben will und so, ja. Genau solche Sachen fehlen ja immer in diesen ganzen Webseiten. Das macht einen wahnsinnig oder genau das Kriterium, was an interessiert ist, dann halt überhaupt nicht gelistet, aus der beliebt. Na ja, und dann habe ich das mal so ein bisschen reduziert auf so halbwegs bezahlbare Bildschirme, die 4K haben, die vielleicht mit dem Computer funktionieren oder nicht, weil das steht ja natürlich nicht, also so HDMI 2.0.
Von Samsung gibt es einen, der ganz interessant scheint.
Genau, und dann gibt es dann so von Samsung so Sachen, die ganz interessant schauen. Und dann schaust du halt mal so, also ich meine, Samsung, ganz ehrlich.
Die Bildschirme sind nicht so verkehrt.
Ich habe Samsung Fernseher und Display seit irgendwie 15 Jahren, war nicht immer ganz zufrieden damit.
Bildschirme sind ganz okay.
Jaja, klar, die sind ja auch total führend. Die sind ja auch total führend in Sicherheitslücken, die von allen möglichen Leuten...
Ich rede von Bildschirmen, nicht von Smart oder Dump.
Die gibt es ja schon gar nicht mehr, ohne.
Doch, als reinen Bildschirm schon?
Also habe ich nicht gefunden. Es gibt einen Bildschirm, der einfach nur Dump, HDMI rein und dann kommt Ton und Bild raus und sonst macht das Ding nichts. Das fände ich mal geil. Also ich fände diese Trennung von Receiver und Bildschirm, das findest du auf dem Markt fast gar nicht. Und lustigerweise kannte ich das überhaupt nur von einer Produkt-Serie, die es mal gab vor 20 Jahren von Sony und jetzt mit meinem Gerät von Sony. Ich habe noch nie gesehen, dass das irgendjemand anders macht, dass das sozusagen konsequent zu trennen, dass du so den Bildschirm und das Teil, was das Bild dafür akquiriert. Ja und eigentlich ist das aber genau das, was man heutzutage haben will. Eigentlich willst du nur noch einen Bildschirm haben, der mehrere Signale, eigentlich braucht man nur noch einen einzigen HDMI-Eingang. Eigentlich brauch ich einen Bildschirm mit einem HDMI-Eingang.
Genau, der geht an den Receiver und der macht da einfach den ganzen Punkt.
Genau, dann hast du da deinen Switch oder was auch immer das ist.
Aber ich mein, das kannst du doch auch haben. Also ich hab einen Samsung-Fernseher zu Hause, ich glaub, der hat irgendwie 38 Zoll, gar nicht mal so riesig, weil ich auch einen riesen Beamer noch irgendwie daneben stehen habe. Und ja, der hat glaube ich irgendwie einen Kabeltuner drin und ich glaube, der hatten sogar irgendwie, wie heißt dieses Fernsehen, über Luft, da dieses HD-HBTV, wie heißt das? Genau, da hat er nie eingeschaltet, nie konfiguriert, immer ignoriert, HDMI 1, rein an den Receiver, fertig, funktioniert. Also ich hab kein anderes Feature dieses Fernsehers jemals benutzt, außer noch irgendwie den Zero Latency Mode für Gaming-Geschichten. Und das funktioniert ja nach wie vor.
Und macht er auch die ganzen Remote-Controlls über HDMI mit, also wenn ich dann sozusagen Apple TV sagt, schalte ich mal ein, schalte ich mal aus, mach mal lauter, mach mal leiser.
Also das ist das, was bei meinem relativ alten Samsung nicht funktioniert, mit dem lauter, leiser, keine Ahnung, vielleicht haben sie es inzwischen nachgewiesen.
Ich glaube, das würde funktionieren über HDMI, nur ich hab's, das kann wiederum ein Receiver nicht, weil der glaube ich ein bisschen zu alt dafür ist. Ich glaube, der schickt die Steuerungskommandos nicht. Aber das Problem habe ich gelöst über so eine All-in-One, von wem ist die? Philips Fernbedienung, wo ich also mit zwei Klicks irgendwie, oder ich könnte auch ein Makro darauf programmieren, schalte alle Geschichten aus. Also da finde ich, muss nicht jede einzelne Komponente, jedes Problem selber lösen, sondern das kann man dann auch irgendwie wieder auf einer Metaebene abhandeln.
Ja, aber kennst du dann auch gute Receiver, die auch, also die das tun, was man dann normalerweise im Fernseher hat? Also man bräuchte ja im Prinzip eine Box, die entweder DVB-T und DVB-CE oder S macht, oder die T2, C2, was auch immer, also sozusagen die aktuellen DVB-Standards über Kabel und oder Satellit und oder terrestrisch drin hat. Das ist das, was ich von einem Fernseher-Receiver erwarten würde und der außerdem noch mehrere andere Quellen auch noch mitschalten kann. So dass du so einen Apple TV, so einen Amazon Stick und was weiß ich, man da noch so für Spielegerätequellen hat.
Eine zentrale Voraussetzung des Krellstockmannschen Medienkonzeptes war es in der Tat halt, ich glaube, wir hatten durchgezeichnet acht HDMI-Eingänge. Das heißt also, die sind alle in Benutzung und ich muss den HDMI-Splitter davor setzen, weil wir einfach noch mehr Geräte haben. Weil mit jedem Scheiß Amazon Stick und so weiter kommt ja wieder ein neuer dazu. Was ist denn dein Switch? Das ist ein Sanyo Receiver XY. Also du kriegst problemlos Receiver mit irgendwie acht HDMI-Eingängen.
Aber das Wort Receiver ist ja jetzt hier nur verwendet, als das, was ich als Switch bezeichnen würde. Richtig, genau.
Das ist richtig, aber das ist auch für uns nie ein Thema gewesen, weil wir beispielsweise immer Kabelfernsehen hatten. So und da musst du den Kabel-Receiver mehr oder weniger von irgendwie Vodafone, Kabel-Deutschland, Telekom, whatever nehmen. Den hängst du dann halt per HDMI dann wieder an deinen Receiver dran.
Das muss man nämlich eben nicht tun.
Ja, aber was für ein Vorteil ist es, dass dann, who cares?
Was für ein Vorteil das ist, wenn es nicht ist?
Wenn das so all in one ist, ist auch immer so irgendwie alles...
Eine Fernbedienung und alles passt irgendwie zusammen.
Ich habe eine Fernbedienung, die ist halt selber programmierbar.
Okay, aber du musst ja selber dann auch so, das heißt, du hast da so ein Schlagschiff mit 380 Tasten, wo du dir dann irgendwie alles zusammen...
Touch-Display.
Mit einem Mac anschließbar und programmierbar.
Ich würde ja nur die Begrifflichkeit haben. Also für mich ist, also ich weiß, dass im Audiobereich war Receiver immer ein Gerät, was überhaupt erst mal aggregiert. Und man vielleicht auch noch...
Und Radio empfängt.
Vielleicht noch Boxen anschließen.
Genau, Radio.
Radio war dann manchmal auch noch mit dabei.
Nein, nein, Radio war im Receiver. Alles andere war ein Verstärker.
Das stimmt richtig.
Receiver war der Verstärker mit dem Radio, mit dem Eingebauten.
Genau. Und in dem Moment, wo man halt Fernsehen bedient, würde ich natürlich auch erwarten, dass er genauso auch ein Fernsehsignal receiven kann.
Nur so ein Gerät kenne ich halt nicht. Das machen die DVB-T, sonst wie Receiver, aber machen ja genau das. Die receiven ja dein Fernsehsignal, dein DVB, irgendetwas.
Ja, aber da hast du dann so eine Box für eine Anbindung und dann ist das irgendwie so Techni, Satoshi, Min, Botdav3, VW, noch eine Fernbedienung.
Ich habe eh neun Devices, die alle HDMI rausgeben. Also wie gesagt, sie sind einfach da. Sie werden auch nicht weggehen. Weil du hast irgendwie Amazon, ich habe Apple TV, ich habe drei Gaming-Konsolen, ich habe den...
Ich habe schon aufgescheitert, sorry.
Ich habe den eigentlichen Kabel Fernsehzugang und noch irgendwie zwei, drei andere, die ich jetzt gerade irgendwie vergessen habe. Die fliegen auch sonst nur noch ein paar HDMI an. Genau, ein Pie mit diversen lustigen Mediencenter-Geschichten. Die gehen auch alle nicht weg.
Hast du überhaupt die Zeit, dir das alles anzugucken?
Nee, die habe ich ja nicht, aber ich muss sie programmieren. Darum die eigentliche entscheidende Frage ist natürlich, wer kümmert sich in dem Jahr 2017 noch um Fernsehen? Es gibt Netflix und das war's. Beziehungsweise halt irgendwie Ersätze durch diverse andere Dienste.
Ich habe noch eine Chromecast irgendwo rumfliegen.
Genau, eine Chromecast haben wir auch.
Kann man damit 20 Uhr Tagesschau einschalten?
Nein, schon. Der Livestream der ARD ist Internet.
Über Netflix?
Nein, nicht über Netflix, aber über Browser. Browser? Hallo? Internet?
Browser?
ARD, gib mir tageschau.de live an.
Ich will aber jetzt nicht für jedes Programm mein Output-Device ändern.
Du hast deinen Rechner.
Muss ich meinen Rechner an meinen Fernseher anschließen, damit ich das irgendwie...
Also ich habe mein iPhone und ich drücke so...
Schalt bei Tagesschau ein, hast du mal einen Laptop, der gerade irgendwo anders steht.
Handy, iPhone, iPad, alles, whatever. Jedes Gerät, das ich besitze, kann mir die Tagesschau anzeigen.
Ja, aber dann muss ich halt den Kindern, damit sie Sesamstraße gucken könnten, muss ich dann noch ein iPad in die Hand drücken, oder was?
Das könnte durchaus Vorteile haben gegenüber... Ich sage ja nicht, dass man gar......
Retten damit ins andere Zimmer und spielen wie Minecraft.
Ich sage nicht, dass es irgendwie kein Szenario dafür gibt, dass man auch noch irgendwie einen Fernseher vielleicht baut. Ich sage nur, ich habe neun andere Devices. Ich werde jetzt keinerlei Fantasie darauf optimieren. Wie kann ich jetzt den Fernsehempfang irgendwie weg abstrahieren, wenn ich dasselbe Problem bei acht anderen Devices habe, die alle nicht weggehen werden? Also, who cares? Ein Gerät mehr oder weniger, das macht halt den Braten überhaupt nicht fett. Ich rege mich darüber auf, zum Beispiel eher, dass Apple es immer noch nicht hinbekommt, mal vernünftig irgendwie eine wirklich stabile HD-Video-Verbindung irgendwie von meinem iPhone zum Apple TV hinzubekommen. Und das über irgendwie ein Mörder-WLAN, was ich zu Hause habe. Das riecht mich auf. Nicht, dass ich da jetzt irgendwie eine zusätzliche TV-Box irgendwo stehen habe.
Ist das eine AirPod Extreme?
Die habe ich mittlerweile abgeschafft. Das war auch irgendwie ein Teil des Problems, dass die irgendwie nicht mehr performt hat. Clemens war mal bei mir zu Hause und seitdem ist alles schick. Ich fahre jetzt quasi das Republikas-Hintergrund ab. Alles ist gut. Ja, also ich sehe da einen Punkt, Tim, aber meine Probleme sind andere. Also ich hätte dann gerne diese neuen Devices weg. Und da lohnt es sich nicht jetzt enorm viel Energie auf die Lösung für eines dieser neuen Devices zu. Meine PS4 wird nicht weggehen. Meine PlayStation 4. Die muss da auch dran.
Nein, das ist ja auch vollkommen klar.
Auch dieses Fernsteuerungs-Dings. Ich brauche nur Multifunktions-Fernbedienung. Ich kann nicht mit neuen Fernbedienungen handeln. Du weißt, die hängen bei mir alle an der Wand. Also ich habe alle Fernbedienungen, alle Geräte, die ich jemals besessen habe, als Wand-Installations-Kunstwerk bei mir an der Wand hängen. Und sie sind alle durch eine Multifunktions-Fernbedienung ersetzt. So, und es ist jetzt einfach egal, wie viele Devices noch hinzukommen. Der einzig echt limitierende Faktor ist die Anzahl der HDMI-Eingänge im Receiver.
Ja, na gut, ich wollte mich ja sozusagen auch nur der Frage nähern.
Dein Baby wird das alles umstecken, scheint dir. Ja, so wird das kommen.
Also wenn man jetzt sozusagen im Jahre 2017 so ein Medienzimmer neu denkt, wie viel alt ist sozusagen geboten und wie viel neu ist auch sinnvoll. Es gibt jetzt einfach so viele Möglichkeiten, sowas zu akquirieren. Es gibt ja zum Beispiel auch noch hier von mittlerweile bei der Firma Genia Tech angesiedelt, ehemals Elgato Produkte. Die haben ja diesen ganzen alten TV-Kram aufgekauft, was früher mal Elgato war. Da gibt es ja dann zum Beispiel hier für Kabel-Fernsehen diese ITV-Netstream-Box. Wenn du so einen Kabelanschluss hast bei dir, dann kannst du halt einfach diese Box ranhängen und dann macht das einfach mal daraus Streaming-Media. Dann hast du es sozusagen auf jedem Device. Aber wie kriegst du Streaming-Media jetzt auch mal so problemlos auf einen großen Screen, ohne da noch mal einen Computer ran zu hängen? Auch so eine Frage. Ich rede jetzt von einem Szenario, wo du schon so einen Default Big Screen hast. Und du möchtest gerne alles Mögliche, egal woher es kommt, möchtest du so einfach, wie es irgendwie geht, ohne weitere Geräte hinzunehmen zu müssen, zumindest temporär hinzunehmen zu müssen, da drauf haben.
Der Chat sagt, Bildertisch reinstellen, wer braucht schon ein Medienzimmer?
Na, ein Medienzimmer brauchst du zum Beispiel, wenn du mal gepflegten Filmen gucken willst.
Also meine Welt sieht wirklich ein bisschen anders aus. Also seit, ich würde sagen, drei Jahren ungefähr, ist eigentlich alles, was Claudia und ich an Medien konsumieren, eigentlich auf dem iPad drauf, sei es, ob es über Netflix kommt, sei es, ob es über unseren lokalen Medienserver kommt, sei es, ob es über tagesschau.de kommt, wie auch immer. Und von da aus streamen wir über Apple TV auf dem Beamer, wenn es denn mal Not tut. Ja, aber häufig, also von daher mein Medienzimmer ist einfach mal ein iPad. So, und dann, das funktioniert genauso, wenn wir halt im Bett liegen.
Ja, aber du hast ja auch einen Beamer.
Ja, der wird aber nur für Kino angeworfen, wenn wir einen Kinofilm schauen. So, und den lege ich dann eben doch einfach bei Apple oder bei Netflix oder sonst wo. Ansonsten Fernsehen eigentlich ganz, also wirklich nicht häufig. Wir gucken gerade irgendwie Modern Family ganz gerne, wenn der Kleine irgendwie schläft, so, dann gucken wir da irgendwie zwei, drei Folgen, so. Das ist das einzige Szenario, wo der Fernseher bei uns überhaupt läuft. Nur sind wir sicherlich gerade in einer Extremsituation geschenkt, ja. Aber ansonsten den Beamer nehmen wir für Gaming und ansonsten für Kinofilme, wenn wir explizit Kino machen. So, und das ist so gelöst, dass Fernseher und Beamer einfach über einen HDMI-Switch verkabelt sind, der beides gleichzeitig beschickt und wenn beide an sind, ist auf beiden ein Bild und ich kann nicht mal ziehen und her schalten, sondern es ist einfach eine doppel weiche. Relativ effizient. Und ansonsten, also in den allermeisten Fällen zückt einer von uns iPad oder iPhone und streamt Sachen auch über das Apple TV in den Receiver und der auf das Gerät, was gerade an ist. Das ist relativ übersichtlich.
Wenn das die weiß, dass Streaming erlaubt.
Naja, Bildschirm-Streaming funktioniert ja immer. Wo denn nicht? Gut, habe ich nicht. Dich ausprobiert, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Auch kein Airplay-Mirror.
Was, echt? Airplay-Mirror geht nicht mit Sky und das lässt Apple durch? Das wird mich jetzt fast... Also bist du ja ganz sicher?
Auch wenn der HDMI-Kabel anschließt, sagt er, geht nicht.
An ein iPad, ein HDMI-Kabel?
Dann kommt die App und sagt, nö, du hast mich gekauft, um die Scheiße auf dem iPad anzuzeigen, komm mir nicht mit externen Bildschirmen mit Beamer und so, weil dann kannst du ja damit unser teures Fernseh-Kabel-Fernsehen-Programm umgehen. Abgesehen davon, dass dieser ganze Dienst von Sky sowieso eine totale Zumutung ist, weil du irgendwie viel Geld dafür bezahlst und dann irgendwelche Streams startest und dann fängt es erst mal so, jetzt das Spiel live, bloß nichts verpassen und dann erst mal zu Beginn 30 Sekunden Werbung zeigen und dann irgendwann zwischendurch kackt dir irgendwie der scheiß Stream ab wegen Bodennebel, WLAN zu schwach, irgendwas, keine Ahnung, musst du es mal über die Straße laufen und dann startest du es wieder neu und dann kriegst du halt wieder erst mal 30 Sekunden Werbung, fünf Minuten bevor das Spiel zu Ende ist. Dann fragst du dich halt einfach, wieso bezahle ich euch eigentlich Geld, dass ich mir irgendwie Werbung angucken muss, also bekloppt, da geht es einfach wirklich nicht.
Ja, eine relevante Frage. Also hier steht gerade im Chat, dass es Absicht war, Sky Go günstiger ist als das normale Sky.
Ja klar ist das Absicht, gar keine Frage ist das Absicht, voller Absicht. Aber warum gibt es nicht einfach nur ein Sky?
Also ich finde das, ohne jetzt gleich den nächsten Apple-Rand irgendwie aus, das finde ich interessant, dass das Apple überhaupt ermöglicht, einer App sich gegen Screen Mirroring zu wehren, das habe ich höchstens das erste Mal.
Auf iOS, das kann ich mir vorstellen, ja.
Lustig, stecken mit denen unter einer Decke.
Also bei Mac OS ist das ein bisschen einfacher. Also zumindest habe ich die DVD auf dem Apple TV so abgespielt, dass ich irgendwie das vom, na wie heißt das, das Ding mit dem Absperrhütchen, VLC, die DVD beim VLC angemacht habe, Fullscreen und dann Apple-E-Mirroring.
Naja, auf Mac ist es nicht abgefangen, unter iOS geht es.
Na gut, unter Mac ruckelt es dafür. Das ist irgendwie auch in A-Sicht.
Also die DVD hat nicht geruckelt.
Ja, DVD geht, aber Blu-ray kannst du vergessen. Also Full HD-Streaming über Airplay vom Mac aus, auf dem Apple, aller Neues ist das Apple TV. Das ist immer noch irgendwie ein Drama.
Jetzt sag mir nochmal, was ein geiler Receiver ist deiner Meinung nach, der sich wirklich gut bedienen lässt.
Da bin ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht wirklich up to date. Also ich hab einen Onkyo. Wie gesagt, Hauptkriterien wäre wirklich Anzahl der HDMI-Eingänge. Wir haben das genauestens durchgerechnet. Und zwei Jahre später musst du dann der Vierfach-Splitter davor. Musst du mal gucken, ob da irgendwo...
Was ja immer so ein Problem ist bei diesen HDMI-Umschaltern ist...
Yamaha ist auch gut.
Meine Frage, ob das hier konfigurierbar ist, bleibt ein Port aktiv, wenn er nicht ausgewählt ist als Output? Weil, wenn ich da einen Computer anschließe, dann hast du ja immer dieses Problem, dass der...
Urstellfragen.
Na ja, das sind die entscheidenden Fragen damit.
Ja, das ist schon richtig. See your point. Muss ich jetzt, glaube ich, gestehen, habe ich sogar noch gar nicht ausprobiert.
Also das wäre zum Beispiel so ein Feature, was ich gerne hätte, dass ich für jeden Eingangsport sagen kann, ob der immer aktiv ist oder nicht. Oder ob der nur aktiv ist, wenn er ausgewählt ist als Quelle.
Das mache ich überlege gerade. Und mal wieder über Ultraschall zu reden. Meine Ultraschall-Screencast sind ja in 720p. Die kriege ich aus meinem beschissenen neuen, gar nicht so neuen MacBook Super, weil man kann sie auch auf dem iPhone noch sich angucken von der Auflösung her. Die sind gar nicht so einfach zu recorden, weil nämlich auf meinem schönen MacBook Pro hier, was irgendwie gar nicht mit Touchbar ist und so weiter, kann man keinen 720p-Bildschirmmodus einschalten, außer du verbindest ihn per HDMI-Kabel an deinen Receiver, dass er dann auf einen 720p... Plötzlich kannst du 720p einschalten. What the fuck, Apple? Warum kann ich nicht jederzeit meine Bildschirmauflösung so einstellen, wie ich es irgendwie richtig halte?
Hast du das mit Alt gedrückt alt ausprobiert?
Ja, und ich habe fünf verschiedene Tools installiert, die alle versprechen, jede beliebige Auflösung fahren zu können. Weder 1080p noch 720p sind da dabei. Das sind immer nur krude Zwischenstufen von dem Display. Der Punkt ist aber, da war keines meiner Endgeräte an. Der Heck ist, ich schließe einen Receiver an, dann habe ich 720p durch einen zweiten Bildschirm. Der macht 720p. Dann biete ich das ausnahmsweise auch mal an, mit Alt-Taste gedrückt. Von daher wäre meine Vermutung, dass es bei denen auch funktioniert, wenn sie nicht als Eingang ausgewählt sind. Es reicht ihm also, dass er einen einmaligen Handshake hat, dann hält er den stabil. Aber ich würde es jetzt nicht beschwören, müsste man noch mal intensiver durchtesten.
Hier gibt es auch schon 4K-fähige Receiver.
Ja, aber 4K hast du mal durchgerechnet, weil Steve, als er noch lebte, hat uns ja die Wahrheit eigentlich schon gebracht, auch wenn es natürlich ein Per-Erst-Hand war, aber so Retina-Logik, also hast du mal geguckt, so Abstand zu Bildschirmdiagonale, also ist dein Auge überhaupt in der Lage, 4K aufzulösen?
Klar.
Bei dem Abstand in dem Zimmer, um das es geht, ist das der Fall, ja. Weil du kannst jetzt mein Wohnzimmer dir imaginieren, mit der Couch und dieser riesigen Leinwand, die wir da haben, da würde 4K knapp etwas bringen gegenüber 1080p, aber auch nur ganz, ganz, ganz knapp. Also, und wir haben eine Bildschirmdiagonale von, ich glaube, drei Metern oder so was, das ist schon recht wuchtig.
Alter, es gibt nur ein einziges Live-Erlebnis auf diesem Planeten, was wirklich relevant ist.
Fußball.
Und bei Fußball kann es einfach mal nicht genug Pixel geben. Und wenn es nicht groß genug ist, dann machst du es einfach größer.
Ja.
Ich will einfach mal zwei, ich will einfach die komplette Wand voll haben, von links nach rechts ein komplettes, zwei 4K-Streams nebeneinander, eins für die linke Hälfte und eins für die rechte Hälfte.
Dazu irgendwie Stadion-Zerraun-Sound.
Und jedes beschissene Grashalm kannst du einzeln auf deiner Raufhase tabellieranfangen.
Geh doch einfach hin.
Man kann ja leider nicht immer hingehen.
Ja, kann man machen.
Also Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft werde ich nicht hinfahren, kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen.
Die nächste noch, die übernächste.
Es ist da irgendwo dann angekündigt, dass sie in 4K übertragen werden. Also wir erinnern uns an das Drama, die irgendwie öffentlich-rechtliche, die machen ja glaube ich heute noch 720p, mit irgendwie höherer Bildfrequenz, weil sie sagen, nee, oder non-interlaced, versus irgendwie private mit 1080p und interlaced.
Also meines ist ja dann nicht mehr P, das wäre dann I.
Genau, aber also darum, 720p versus 1080i, weil die Debatte öffentlich-rechtlich versus, also meines Wissens ist da 4K nicht ansatzweise, die müssten ja wieder ihre ganzen Kameras, also das geht auch nur alle 20 Jahre.
Wissens wird Fußball schon in 4K aufgenommen.
Ist 4K dann 30Hz oder 60Hz?
Na ich hoffe, ich rede natürlich von 60Hz.
Weil ich habe nämlich für das neue MacBook einen USB-C auf HDMI-Adapter gesucht, der 4K mit 60Hz kann und sowas scheint es gar nicht zu geben. Also ich weiß nicht, ob HDMI überhaupt 4K mit 60Hz hergibt. Also zumindest habe ich keinen Adapter gefunden, der von sich behauptet, er könnte das.
Na gut, vielleicht kann er es dann einfach trotzdem. Es ist ja eher eine Frage, wie die beiden Geräte sich über dieses HDMI miteinander verständigen. Also der Bildschirm muss es halt können und der Rechner muss es halt können. Und das normale MacBook kann es seit der zweiten Generation, kann der 4K mit 60Hz.
Okay, also der mit eingebautem HDMI-Port?
Nie mit eingebautem HDMI-Port, das MacBook.
Ja, aber das MacBook Pro. Das neue MacBook Pro hat ja kein HDMI, hat ja nur USB-C. Und der Apple-USB-C zu HDMI-USB kann keine 60Hz bei 4K und scheint auch überhaupt Kompatibilitätsprobleme mit HDMI zu haben. Und wie gesagt, ich habe beim Durchklicken bei Amazon auch keins gefunden, was HDMI 4K mit 60Hz kann. Wir haben alle nur 30Hz behauptet von sich. Insofern, ja gut.
Ja, das ist problematisch. Also eine Infrastruktur, die irgendwie nicht 4K und nicht 60Hz fähig ist, ist ungeil.
Also für sachdienliche Hinweise bin ich da zu haben. Nicht, dass es jetzt brennend wichtig wäre.
Man braucht natürlich auch 4K-Beamer und so, die gibt es natürlich auch noch nicht.
Die gibt es schon, die willst du nur nicht kaufen bei dem Preis.
Also ich würde ja sagen, Tim, das ist eine Sackkasse. Dieses Ganze auf eine Leinwand projizieren, aber das ist dann schon das nächste Thema.
Wieso ist das eine Sackgasse?
Weil wir das alles über Virtual Reality Brillen haben. Wo du wirklich im Stadion stehst und es dir anguckst.
Aber dann willst du wirklich 4K, oder?
Ja, das ist...
Dann willst du vor allem erstmal eine Tüte Kotz-Tüten da irgendwie immer daneben stehen haben.
Also, ich weiß nicht, wollen wir das Thema aufrufen?
Ja, bitte, bitte, bitte, es erschöpft sich mit dem Fernseher.
Also, ich bin seit einem Vierteljahr Besitzer einer PSVR, das heißt also PlayStation Virtual Reality Brille.
Das A steht für Brille, oder was?
Und ich würde euch gerne mal etwas über die Zukunft erzählen.
Zumindest das, was du dafür hältst.
Das, was ich dafür halte und jeder, der sie mal aufgehalten hat, dafür hält. Vielleicht kurze Vorgeschichte. Das Thema 3D-Brillen und Virtual Reality, das verfolge ich seit ungefähr 20 Jahren. Da bin ich schon in London in so einer Spielhalle, die so ein 3D-Setup hatten, wo man dann so eine krude Brille aufbekommen hat. Das war immer alles schrecklich. Alle drei Jahre habe ich es mal wieder ausprobiert, und es war immer alles total zum Kotzen. Bis aufs, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es der 31C3 oder 32C3 war, wo einer unten im C-Base-Bereich war, das mal eine Oculus Rift, eine aktuelle, hatte. Die habe ich mir aufgesetzt, und da habe ich direkt das Licht gesehen. Weil das, was derzeit in der ganzen Debatte völlig untergeht, ist, es gibt einfach mal einen Unterschied zwischen 360-Grad-Videos, die man sich irgendwie auf YouTube angucken kann, und wo man dann auch mit so einem Google-Cardboard sich das irgendwie dann so durch die Gegend gucken kann, versus 3D-Videos, die auch mit 360-Grad daherkommen, versus wirklich eine Virtual-Reality-Umgebung. Der entscheidende Unterschied, den ich bis zu diesem, es selber mal ausprobiert zu haben, nicht kapiert habe, ist der. Das Entscheidende ist nicht das 3D. Das Entscheidende ist nicht, dass sich mit den Augen oder dem Kopf umgucken können. Das Entscheidende, jetzt müsst ihr mal auf meinen Kopf achten, sonst versteht ihr es nicht, ist die Positionsänderung im Raum. Ich wippe gerade mit meinem Oberkörper nach vorne und nach hinten. Ihr glaubt nicht, was es für einen Unterschied in der Immersion macht. Immersion bedeutet, wie realistisch ist irgendwie ein Szenario für mich. So ein IMAX-Kino ist immersiver als ein normales Kino. Ein normales Kino ist immersiver als ein Fernseher. Und das ist alles aber im Bezug auf, wie sehr bin ich drin im Film oder in der jeweiligen Szene. Und das alles ist kompletter Kindergarten gegen das, was eine Oculus Rift oder eine PSVR oder eine HTC Vive Brille produziert. Weil durch diese zusätzliche Dimension von ich bewege meinen Kopf und die ganze Perspektive verschiebt sich absolut latenzfrei und korrekt mit mir, bist du plötzlich da, du bist da drin. So, es ist kein ich gucke einen Film oder ich spiele irgendwie ein Spiel, sondern du bist wirklich vor Ort. Und das ist ein Medienbruch. Ich bin nun wirklich Gamer seit irgendwie C64 Tagen. Ja, das ist größer als Doom damals war mit irgendwie dem ersten 3D-Shooter. Es ist größer als irgendwie, was weiß ich, Online-Gaming oder was auch immer. Also es wird diese Welt und die Art und Weise, wie wir Medien konsumieren und wie wir überhaupt mit unserem Hier und Jetzt umgehen, stärker modifizieren als alles das, was vorher da war. Der Punkt ist, das kann man nicht erklären, wenn man es nicht einmal irgendwie selber ausprobiert hat. Und es gibt so zwei Szenarien, die ich da einfach für Anfänger mal empfehlen würde, das mal irgendwo auszuprobieren. Das erste, da dürfte Tim hellhörig werden als alter Raumzeitgenosse. Es gibt eine Apollo 11 Experience. Das heißt also, du hast diese Brille auf und dann erlebst du die Apollo 11 Mission in ihren kritischen Momenten. Das heißt also, du läufst am Anfang die Gangway entlang. Die Anfangssequenz ist die, dass du die ganze Apollo 11-Rakete schön in 3D runterfährst und dann läufst du in den Fahrstuhl rein und dann fährst du mit dem Fahrstuhl hoch und läufst dann in die Kapsel rein. Und dann sitzt du wirklich, bzw. liegs angeschnallt, neben Neil Armstrong in der fucking original Apollo 11-Kapsel, die wirklich photorealistisch exakt so aussieht. Und es ist nicht so, dass du denkst, ich bin jetzt in einem Computerspiel, was mir gerade vorgaukelt, ich wäre in der Apollo 11-Kapsel, sondern du kannst dich so rumdrehen, ich gucke jetzt gerade unter den Tisch der Meta-Ebene, und du siehst, was da von unten gebaut ist. Also egal, wie du dich in dieser Kapsel...
Das darfst du aber nicht verraten, was da unten gebaut ist, das ist egal!
Wie du dich in dieser Kapsel wehgesetzt hast, du kannst dich... Du wirst dann sehen, die konnten verdammt wenig sehen in dieser Kapsel. Du kannst dich dann also so ans Fenster ran schmiegen und gucken so, was passiert da eigentlich? Und dann geht der Start los, und natürlich fehlt dir die ganze Traktion, du hast keine G-Kräfte und so weiter, aber du bekommst dann also wirklich in Echtzeit mit, wie lange dauert es eigentlich, bis die Schwerelosigkeit damals eingesetzt hat. Das waren ja irgendwie so drei, vier Minuten oder so was, und der Start ist halt wirklich in Echtzeit durchgerendert. Genau, Tim spielt jetzt gerade mal ein YouTube-Video ab, und das ist jetzt genau der Effekt. Jetzt guckt man sich das an und denkt sich, naja, ist halt ein Computerspiel. Wenn du aber diese Brille aufhast, ist es kein Computerspiel mehr, sondern du sitzt in dieser Kapsel drin. Die nächste Sequenz ist dann die, wo man das Ab-Dock-Manöver machen muss, wo sich irgendwie die ersten zwei Stufen von einer trennen und die eine Kapsel sich dann umdreht, und dann muss man so andocken und am Ende kannst du auch auf den Mond spazieren gehen und so weiter. Das ist wirklich nicht mit Worten beschreibbar, wenn man es nicht ausprobiert. Du sitzt, du bist wirklich beim Start dabei. Das heißt also, was dieses Medium an pädagogischem Potential hat, um Leute in irgendeine Situation reinzuversetzen, ist völlig irre. Du hast ein paar dramaturgische Probleme, weil du kannst halt als Regisseur nicht mehr vorhersehen, was die Leute sehen, weil sie sitzen halt in dieser Kapsel und wenn die sich dafür entscheiden, die ganze Zeit Neil Armstrong anzugucken und nicht aus dem Fenster zu sehen, dann sehen sie halt nicht, wie hoch sie sind. Das kannst du nicht mehr beeinflussen. Du hast halt wirklich diesen Freiheitsgrad, genau das dir anzugucken, was dich gerade interessiert. Wenn du die ganze Zeit nur auf die Terminals guckst, dann ist das so. Dann ist es eine freie Entscheidung. Aber trotzdem, es ist ein unglaubliches Gefühl. Du bist selber bei der Mondlandung dabei. Das zweite, was ich empfehlen würde, auszuprobieren, ist Resident Evil 7. Genau, bzw. wo alle versuchen, dich umzubringen, um genauer zu sein. Du hast es aus, das ist schwierig, jemanden umzubringen. Verstehe. Ich bin nun wirklich ein ausgesprochener Horror-Experte.
Das sind die ganzen Butler, die hinter dir herrennen.
Das sind die Zombie-Butter, von denen schon die Rede war. Ganz exakt. Ich bin nun wirklich ein ausgesprochener Horror-Experte. Das hat eine lange Historie bei mir. Ich war als ein Kind ein totaler Schisser. Und wie das manchmal so ist, irgendwann hat es total umgeswitcht. Und ich habe also ziemlich alles gesehen an Filmen da draußen, was irgendwo unter den Büchern gelesen, was irgendwo Rang und Namen hat und einigermaßen relevant ist. Ich habe in meinem Leben noch nie so eine Angst gehabt, wie bei diesem Resident Evil Virtual Reality Modus. Das ganze Spiel ist also ein VA. Und du hast jegliche Abstraktion, das ist nur ein Spiel ist weg. Du bist in diesem Haus, du weißt, da sind Leute, die wollen dir ans Leben und es geht um dein Leben. Das ist ein Grad von Immersion, den ich mir vorher nicht habe vorstellen können. Auch hier wieder das Problem.
Was macht man denn da, wenn man sowieso schon ein bisschen schissig drauf ist?
Das kann ich dir sagen, abschalten. Ich lese viel in Reddit, auch zu dem Spiel. Es gibt da ein ganz gutes PSVA-Forum, wo das viel diskutiert wird. Es gibt nicht wenige, die sich dieses Spiel gekauft haben für 60 Euro, die es nach 10 Minuten nicht mehr spielen können. Die es also einfach abschalten müssen, weil sie es nicht aushalten. Weil sie sagen, ich dachte, das sei ein Spiel, aber es ist einfach kein Spiel, sondern das geht mir hier zu weit. Ich persönlich kann nicht länger als ungefähr 30 Minuten das spielen. Als jemand, der ein Horror schockern und splattern alles gesehen hat, was die Welt zu bieten hat. Es gibt nichts, was ich nicht gesehen habe. Ich kann es nicht länger als 30 Minuten am Stück spielen, weil es mich zu sehr stresst. Es geht um mein Leben. Ich laufe durch ein Haus und es geht um mein Leben. Also ich als hochgebildeter Akademiker, ich schaffe es nicht, diesen Switch im Kopf umzulegen. Das ist jetzt nicht echt. Das ist Simulation.
Hochgebildeter Akademiker, total überschätzt.
Gelingt mir nicht. Und auch hier ist wieder der Punkt, es hilft nichts, das zu erzählen. Und es hilft nichts, sich das auf YouTube anzugucken. Sondern man muss es selber ausprobieren. Und da, ich hab es irgendwie hier in den, gibt's von Heise dieses Experiment, auf das würde ich da gerne noch zu sprechen kommen. Und zwar der Heise-Verlag hat, weil das in den ersten Wochen dann ziemlich, wie lange hältst du es in Resident Evil 7 aus, hat ein kleines Experiment gemacht, wo sie nämlich ein, ihre Redakteure live, ich hab mir das auch live angeguckt, mal Resident Evil spielen lassen. Und er sollte dir die ganze Zeit dann also quasi im Sinne von einer Introspektion erzählen, wie es ihm denn gerade so geht, und wie er sich da gerade so fühlt und so weiter. Genau, jetzt zeigt er gerade wieder, wie der Mond modelliert ist, ganz schön. Und das Problem bei dem Setup war dann wirklich, der war halt nicht alleine. Das heißt also ja, er hatte die Datenbrille auf, und ja, er hat Resident Evil 7 gespielt, aber er hatte halt um sich rum ein Team, was ihn die ganze Zeit gefragt hat, wie fühlst du dich, wie fühlst du dich, hast du schon Angst, hast du schon Angst? Und dann kamen diese ganzen psychologischen Mechanismen von, er hat halt schändlich Witze gemacht über das, was er da sieht. Und ha, so schlimm ist es ja noch gar nicht, und diese ganzen Geschichten. Das heißt also, wenn ihr das mal ausprobiert und wenn ihr das wirklich erleben wollt, macht es nachts, macht es allein. Aber ich bin da nicht schuld, wenn ihr am Herzinfarkt sterbt. Also, aber das sind wieder genau die Sachen, die die Medien jetzt gerade wieder, die Medien, wow, boo, irgendwie halt falsch darstellen. Ja, so schlimm war es ja gar nicht, weil der Typ bei Heise hat es ja irgendwie zwei Stunden ausgehalten. Das war halt überhaupt nicht das Setup. So, und genauso jetzt diese Geschichten, wie gesagt wird, ja, die Pixelauflösung ist viel zu gering, oder der Blickwinkel ist viel zu gering. Frag doch mal einen Taucher, ob er Tauchenscheiße findet, weil er irgendwie eine Taucherbrille auf hat und zu wenig Sichtraum nach links und rechts hat.
Ich fand das scheiße deswegen.
Also klar, der würde sich wünschen, dass er da ein breiteres Sichtraum hat, aber trotzdem scheint es hinreichend, viele Menschen zu geben, die es trotzdem geil finden. Wir fragen Astronauten, ob er ein Problem damit hat, dass er da irgendwie ein... Also gerade darum funktioniert die Apollo-11-Sache ganz gut, weil du eigentlich sowieso den Eindruck hast, du hast ja einen Raumhelm auf, von daher siehst du da halt auch einfach mal weniger. Also, was gerade in der Debatte irgendwie völlig untergeht, ist wirklich dieser totale Paradigmenwechsel, der hier stattfindet. Dass wir diese Schwelle von, ich bin wirklich dabei und mein ganzes vegetatives Nervensystem sagt mir, du bist jetzt dort, das wird gerade ausgeschaltet. Und das hatten wir bei keinem Medium in der Menschheit auch nur ansatzweise vorher. Ja, wir können uns in ein Buch reinsteigern, wir können uns in einen Film reinsteigern, aber dass ich dort durch ein Haus laufe und es wirklich um mein reales Leben geht, das ist wirklich neu. Und von daher, Tim, erzählen wir nichts von Fernseher auf Beeman. Das ist nicht die Zukunft. Das ist wirklich nicht die Zukunft. Das ist nicht das, was uns in zehn Jahren irgendwo definieren wird.
Also ich, ehrlich gesagt, weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob ich mit so einer VR-Brille in einem Fußballspiel herumlaufen will, das will ich mir schon dann so ein bisschen aus der Distanz anschauen.
Aber auf einer perfekten Zuschauertribünenposition, die du sogar noch wechseln kannst zur Halbzeit.
Wo man dann so nach links und rechts schauen kann und den Schwenk sozusagen selber wie im Stadion nachvollziehen kann, ist ein Aspekt, ja. Die Frage ist, welche Auflösung ich dann da habe, sozusagen. Wie viele Pixel hat man denn da bei diesem Teil?
Siehst du, das ist eben der Punkt, der egal ist. Weil die menschliche Wahrnehmung in der Lage ist, Dinge zu subsumieren. Wenn das eine gut ist und das andere schlecht, dann wird das Schlechte irgendwann mal ausgeglichen. Beispielsweise wird jetzt technisch sehr viel diskutiert, ob man jetzt bei diesen VR-Brillen die einzelnen Pixel sieht, oder ob das Gitter sichtbar ist unten drunter. Das ist dir alles egal, wenn der Zombie mit dem Hackebeil hinter dir her ist. Dann achtest du nicht mehr auf Pixel. Und wenn es darum geht, ob deine Union Berlin aufsteigt oder nicht, dann achtest du auch nicht mehr auf Pixel. Und die Pixel sind ein Problem von drei Jahren. In drei Jahren haben wir da irgendwie 4K in den Brillen, oder lass es irgendwie fünf Jahre sein. Das ist einfach mal egal. Das Thema ist durch. Die Frage ist, was wird das mit der Menschheit im Allgemeinen anstellen, diese Technologie. Und das müsste man jetzt mal diskutieren und nicht, ob da jetzt irgendwo Pixel zu sehen sind oder nicht. Aber darum sage ich, lasst uns unsere Energie lieber auf diese Debatte legen, anstatt auf, was jetzt irgendwie noch ein antiquiertes Medienkonzept im Bezug auf Fernseher oder Beamerwände ist.
Naja, ich habe 4K.
Wie viele Pixel?
Die PSVA hat 1080p aufgeteilt, also zwei Augen. Das ist doppelt oder die Hälfte? De facto dann ungefähr die Hälfte. Also in der Breite. Du hast also quasi 1800 x 1080 und auf dem linken Auge irgendwie 900 x 1080 und auf dem rechten auch 900 x 1080. Jedes Auge hat ein eigenes Display. Du hackst halt 1080p in der Mitte.
1920 sind das.
1920 durch zwei.
Also ich habe diese ganze 4K-Sache mir auch nur angeguckt, weil ich einen Monitor für einen Rechner haben wollte zum Programmieren. Und ich will gar keinen Medienkonsum auf 4K betreiben.
Da ist das, was die Apple-TV jetzt an meinem 21 Zoll Samsung-Uralt-Display mit ich glaube irgendwie so was hat, reicht mir weit.
Der Punkt, den ich einfach machen wollte, weil Tim relativ früh meinte, geh mir weg mit irgendwie Motion Sickness und sowas. Ja, das ist ein Problem, aber das sind lösbare Probleme. Du willst trotzdem bei der Mondlandlung dabei sein. Und das bist du halt nicht, wenn du auf eine Kinoleinwand guckst, sondern das bist du halt, wenn du wirklich dabei bist. Und darum ist diese Technologie, die wird awesome.
Das Problem ist aber, was ist, wenn du dir mit zwei, drei anderen Leuten irgendwie gemeinsam ein Spiel anschauen willst? Ich meine, dann kann ja nicht alle so eine scheiß Brille aufhaben.
Na ja gut, da würde ich jetzt wieder sagen, auch diese Brillen sind natürlich nur eine Übergangstechnologie. Also es wird ja jetzt schon mit Kontaktlinsen experimentiert, in denen Displays integriert sind. Das ist noch in einem relativ frühen Stadium. Aber das wird natürlich alles kleiner, leichter, wie auch immer. Also schon, wenn du eine HTC Vive aufsetzt, versus jetzt der Playstation VR, ist das schon ein riesen Unterschied. Also die Vive ist schon relativ schwer und bulky. Und die PS VR, die nimmst du eigentlich nicht mehr wirklich wahr, weil die sehr gut ausbalanciert ist. Also da würde ich immer dafür plädieren, so in alter Wikigeeks-Tradition, so projiziert dann doch mal so drei bis fünf Jahre in die Zukunft. Ja, es ist jetzt noch nicht perfekt. Ja, es ist First-Gen-Hardware. Aber die grundsätzlichen Probleme sind bereits gelöst.
Und das Problem habe ich aber auch, das habe ich vor 20 Jahren auch schon mal gehört, als die irgendwie schon alle mit diesen Brillen rumliefen. Das ist ja so ein altes Thema.
Aber die hatten nicht das Tracking im Raum. Ja, also du kannst eben...
So einiges nicht, aber auch jetzt ist ja das Tracking im Raum noch nicht perfekt.
Die hatten damals schon überhaupt kein richtiges Tracking.
Aber es ist wirklich hinreichend perfekt. Es ist hinreichend perfekt, dass Leute sagen, ich kann das nicht länger als 10 Minuten spielen. Das ist...
Hinreichend perfekt is not a thing. Hinreichend perfekt, was ist das für ein Quatsch?
Ja, das ist ein Widerspruch. Und außerdem, perfekt ist notwendig und nicht hinreichend. Und außerdem, perfekt ist notwendig und nicht hinreichend. Und außerdem, perfekt ist notwendig und nicht hinreichend.
Interessantes Plädoyer, I see your point. Ich weiß gar nicht so ganz genau der Gedanke, mich in eine Situation zu begeben, wo ich mir irgendwie in die Hose scheiße vor Angst. Ich weiß nicht so richtig, welchen Unterhaltungswert das in meinem Leben genießen könnte. Mir geht das nicht viel anders. Aber da muss man wahrscheinlich auch eine bestimmte Affinität haben und die fehlt mir ja generell für dieses Genre.
Aber das kann man ja abstrahieren auf 100.000 andere Lebenssituationen.
Wo man sich in die Hose scheißt oder was?
Nein, also nimm halt irgendwie Liebe. Nimm irgendwo Rockkonzerte. Du stehst dann halt irgendwie mit der Band auf der Bühne. Ja, und wer kippt mir dann das Bier drüber? Du kannst dich halt schon erstmal in alles reinprojektieren, was überhaupt nur denkbar ist. Du kannst halt den Himalaya, du kannst den Mount Everest besteigen. Du kannst irgendwie einen Fallschirmsprung machen. Also ist es einfach egal. Stellt euch einfach alles vor, was ihr eigentlich immer schon mal machen wolltet, wo ihr aber entweder nicht Zeit, Geld, Ressourcen, Mut, was auch immer für hattet. Das löst sich jetzt einfach auf. Also ich habe mir extra dafür dann das Upgrade auf die 4 Pro gegönnt, weil das noch mal ein bisschen mehr irgendwie dann so an Schärfe reinbringt, aber das ist letztendlich kein riesengroßer Unterschied. Also das soll jetzt hier auch keine Kaufempfehlung für die PSVR sein, sondern einfach nur Leute, das ist das Ding. Und das wird, glaube ich, die Menschheit mehr beeinflussen als das Internet.
Ist das jetzt die einzige Spielekonsole, die schon eine VR-Brille seelmäßig mitliefert?
Also die musst du dazukaufen, aber das ist jetzt so die einzige, dass Microsoft irgendwann dieses Jahr auch was rausbringen. Eventuell bringt sogar Apple auch was raus. Also Microsoft hat ja Hololens, das ist ja ein anderer Ansatz.
Ja, ja, das ist halt sehr teuer, ne?
Dieser Blend zwischen realer Welt und virtueller, dass du also über so Informationslayer drüberlegen kannst. Das ist auch cool, aber es ist halt was ganz anderes.
Du glaubst, Apple wird was rausbringen?
Es wird gemunkelt. Sie haben auf jeden Fall Leute eingekauft in dem Bereich.
Es wird nicht gemunkelt. Tim Cook hat mehrfach hintereinander bei öffentlichen Veranstaltungen gesagt, dass Augmented Reality für sie sehr interessant ist.
Also wenn da schon so weit raus schiebend mit dem neuen Thema, mit dem neuen IPhone, angeblich 3D-Scanner und sowas. Also das...
Ich glaube nur, dass Apple eine komplett andere Vision dafür hat, was die eigentliche Nützlichkeit dieser Technologie ist. Während die anderen sich immer Brillen aufsetzen wollen und immer diese sozial abkapselnden Dinge haben, was ein bisschen ein Problem ist. Auch deine ganze Schilderung, ja, klar, alles so. Aus der One-Man-One-Woman-Perspektive taucht irgendwo ein. Aus der One-Man-One-One-Woman-Perspektive taucht irgendwo ein. Und ist sowieso schon sozial isoliert, dann doch wenigstens in 3D. Dann passt das halt irgendwie rein. Nur für Everyday-Use und wirklichen Nutzen daraus haben. Immer so eine dicke Kamera aufspannen und über den Kopf rüberstülpen und Kopfhörer vollkommen isoliert sein. Und dann fehlt ja im Prinzip auch noch Temperatur. Und was nicht alles. Um es wirklich realistisch zu machen, muss es ja auch noch Wind und Geruch und das volle Programm irgendwie und Bewegung und Beschleunigung und so weiter. Also es fehlt ja auch noch. Du kannst mir ja nicht erzählen, dass es jetzt so ist. Ich setze mir eine Kamera auf und auf einmal fühlt es sich so an, als wenn ich zum Mond fliege. Da fehlen schon mal ein paar G. Zumindest am Start. Da fehlt auch Schwerelosigkeit und so weiter. Das ist schon so nicht so ganz unwichtig. Und da rede ich sogar aus Erfahrung.
Ja, das ist richtig. Das ist dann halt auch so ein bisschen die Arroganz des Parabel-Flügers.
Sorry, ich wollte nicht damit angehen. Ich wollte nur sagen, das ist jetzt nicht so ein ganz unerheblicher Aspekt, von dem ich fliege zum Mond-Ding.
Das ist schon korrekt. Aber dafür, dass es trotzdem jetzt Mainstream ist, und dass es die jetzt für 11 Euro shoppen kann, ist das schon mal ein Meilenstein, der da gegangen ist.
Die Frage ist, bei wie vielen Sachen es funktioniert. Also bei diesen ganzen Spielen, glaube ich, kann das ganz gut funktionieren. Gar keine Frage. Weil das ja ohnehin schon so 3D-Environments sind. Ich schiebe mit der Maus irgendwie auf den Tisch von links nach rechts, um meine Blickrichtung zu erinnern. Das ist natürlich Quatsch, wenn du das irgendwie auch mit deiner Blickrichtung selber ändern kannst. Das sehe ich vollkommen ein. Du meinst also, dieses Tracking von dieser Kamera ist so gut, dass man selber jetzt keinerlei... Du hast ja keinen Lack.
Also so gar keinen Lack. Nein, die sind eigentlich... Nein, die sind so Lack-frei, dass du es nicht mehr merkst und wahrnimmst. Weil sobald du einen Lack hast, wird dir schlecht und du musst kotzen.
Also ich habe fast schon mal in Oculus Rift reingekotzt.
Also man muss ja noch mal unterscheiden zwischen einem echten Lack, was im Sinne von wie schnell kann ich meinen Kopf bewegen und gibt es da einen ziehen und fremdbestimmter Bewegung. Das heißt, wo die Leute wirklich ins Kotzen kommen ist, wenn du beispielsweise ein Gamepad in der Hand hältst mit so einem Steuerkreuz und nach vorne läufst und du guckst aber nach links und bewegst deine Füße gar nicht und trotzdem bewegt sich deine ganze Optik so, als ob du gerade nach vorne läufst. Dein Körper sagt ja, du bewegst dich gar nicht nach vorne.
Gut, ich hätte vielleicht nicht Half-Life ausprobieren sollen.
Also das ist ein echtes, ernstes Problem. Wofür ist das denn allerdings halt jetzt beispielsweise bei Resident Evil, finde ich, die haben das schon relativ elegant gelöst. Der erste Punkt ist, die bewegen sich nicht so schnell. Du rennst halt nicht, sondern du läufst ganz gemächtig. Das macht die Sache schon mal entspannter. Da gibt es solche Trips wie, stell vor dir einen Ventilator auf, der dir Luft ins Gesicht reinweht. Das führt also auf irgendeinem sonderbaren, noch nicht gänzlich verstandenen, psychologischen Effekt dazu, dass du die ganze Zeit in einer Dauerbewegungsschleife sich dein Gehirn bewegt. Dann bist du schon mal wesentlich weniger anfällig für diese Motion Sickness-Geschichten. Da kann man schon was gegen tun, und da wird auch gerade massiv was gegen getan. Lack als solches ist nicht das Problem, sondern eher die Abstraktion von, wohin bewege ich mich jetzt in dieser Umgebung, versus wohin bewege ich mich in der realen Realität. Da sind solche Geschichten wie Apollo 11 dankbar, weil da bist du eh im Sitz fest geschnallt und kannst also gar nicht aufstehen in der Kapsel, weil da ist halt kein Platz. Du kannst dich nur durch die Gegend lehnen, und dann ist es nahezu perfekt. Nicht nahezu perfekt, sondern da ist es perfekt. Punkt, jetzt habe ich es gesagt. Wenn du da Lack hättest, würdest du kotzen. Wenn du jetzt noch kotzt, dann ist es, weil das Spiel noch nicht vernünftig getrennt hat, deine reale Bewegung im Raum oder nicht Bewegung im Raum von der Bewegung, die das Spiel oder diese Umgebung dir simuliert. Und das sind in der Tat zu lösende Probleme noch, da noch weiter auszuforschen. Da wird jetzt gerade auch viel experimentiert, mit statischen Kameras versus bewegliche Kameras, First-Person, Third-Person. Erstaunlicherweise, eines der beliebtesten Sachen auf der PSVR ist wirklich ein Third-Person-Spiel, wo du eigentlich einen Plattformer hast. So ein Mario-3D quasi. Wo du die ganze Zeit vor dir so einen Oeleken hast und mit der beobachtenden Kamera die ganze Zeit so dahinter herfliegst eigentlich. Relativ weich, so butterweich, um nicht zu sagen so. Und das funktioniert super, weil du bist in dieser 3D-Plattformer-Welt drin. Und hast trotzdem dein Oeleken vorne, was halt deine Bewegung macht. Ganz fantastisch.
Also du spielst so ein Diorama?
Ja, gewissermaßen.
Weil das ist mit vielen von diesen 3D-Sachen, also auch dieses 3D-Fernsehen, hatte ich immer das Gefühl, ich gucke da in ein Diorama rein, was sich bewegt.
Dann das Gegenteil davon. Du bist in dem Diorama, also du bist in dem Museum, was um dich umgebaut wurde und läufst da durch. Und von daher, also mein Credo, vergesst Fernsehen, vergesst Kino, vergesst den ganzen Kram. Das ist das Ding, das wird kommen. Da macht euch schlau, da probiert es aus, da steckt eure Fantasie rein, was demnächst passieren wird.
Ich kaufe erstmal nix.
Ich finde das irgendwie mit dem 4K auf der Wand, bin ich irgendwie immer noch überzeugender, was zumindest die Zielgruppe Fußball betrifft. Aber das mag jetzt auch nur ein Teilaspekt sein. Ich stecke ja leider in dieser ganzen Game-Welt nicht drin. Ich wundere mich ja auch immer noch, ob mich das irgendwie nochmal erwischt mit irgendwas. Glaubst du, das ist schon zu spät bei mir?
Naja, aber du warst doch hier ein großer Fan von Wie ist das hier? Wurde da plötzlich absurd weit. Also 2048 hast du gerne gespielt. Und du bist doch ein großer Meister hier in von Huckel da, die Firma, das Spiel. Wie ist das Viech?
Ach, das sind doch alles nur so Klimbim, irgendwie Nebenbei-Beschäftigungen. Das ist doch keine Immersion.
Klar, da geht es nicht um Immersion, aber es geht grundsätzlich um Spielmechanismen. Das heißt also, was ist das Spielziel, was ist der Spielmechanismus? Und bringe ich jetzt genug Konzentration auf, mich irgendwie für 20 Minuten mit genau dieser eine Aufgabe zu beschäftigen?
Tue ich ja gar nicht. Ich spiele dieses Spiel eigentlich nur, um besser Podcasts hören zu können. Was? Ich spiele dieses Spiel, um besser Podcasts hören zu können.
Ja, aber dann bist du auch kein Gamer.
Nein, bin ich ja auch nicht. Habe ich ja noch nie behauptet, dass ich ein Gamer bin.
Das ist eine besonders kautzige Form von Casual Gamer.
Ich habe ja meine Computer-Karriere auch mit Spielen angefangen. Wie bei allen war so Spiele am Anfang natürlich sehr interessant. Ich habe so mit meinen Freunden irgendwie da gesessen und haben irgendwie mit Summer Games unsere Joysticks zerrobt. Denk an, das tausendachtelang Meter. Und Loadrunner und Hust nicht gesehen. Das war auch irgendwie alles ganz interessant, aber es hat mich halt einfach nicht so gerissen. Und was mich halt komplett von Spielen von heute auf morgen weggezogen hat, war Programmieren. Also in dem Moment, wo ich angefangen habe zu programmieren, habe ich keine Spiele mehr gespielt. Das mögen jetzt manche auch nicht verstehen, weil ja gerade auch spielen und programmieren und dann will man ja auch vielleicht Spiele programmieren. Für mich war auch dieser Gedanke, ich muss jetzt Spiele programmieren, weil ich ja vorher Spiele gemacht habe, hat mich einfach nicht so gerissen. Ich sage nicht, das muss so sein oder das muss bei allen so sein und ich weiß auch, dass es bei den allerwenigsten so ist. Also mich hat einfach diese Spiel, Computerspiel-Geschichte nie so eingenommen. Und ich habe selber keine gute Erklärung dafür, warum das eigentlich so ist. Ich finde das eigentlich auch überraschend. Ich finde es komisch.
Mir geht das genauso.
Irgendetwas fehlt mir da. Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendeine... Das ist auch gar nicht so dieses... Ich will noch nicht mal sagen, dass es jetzt irgendwie keine intellektuelle Herausforderung wäre, aber ich sehe schon, dass sehr viele Spiele sowas auch bieten. Mit Rätsel lösen und was nicht alles. Da bin ich wahrscheinlich auch schon wieder zu faul oder nicht ambitioniert genug. Vielleicht fehlt mir einfach auch nur dieses kompetitive Grundelement überhaupt. Ich bin jetzt auch nicht so ein Typ, der sich so gerne mit Leuten kloppt. Zum Beispiel. Kann ich dir sagen. Singen. Ich frage mich halt, ob noch mal irgendwas kommt, irgendeine Qualität kommt, die mich irgendwie auch weghaut. 3D hat mich irgendwie nicht gezogen. Überhaupt nicht. Ich gucke mir das so an und so, ah ja, sieht schon wieder ein bisschen besser aus als letztes Mal, aber das Spiel ist für mich kein, also das Spiel im Sinne von so alle Computer-Games, die theoretisch zur Auswahl stehen, sind für mich nicht interessanter geworden, dadurch, dass sie toller aussehen.
Für mich schon. Ich bin so ein Sightseeing-Spieler. Ich liebe Spiele, die eine große offene Welt haben, wo man rumrennen kann und Sachen machen. Ja gut, das habe ich jetzt nie gespielt. Und die auch sehr story-driven sind. Also wenn du wirklich das Gefühl hast, du spielst... Gut, Zelda würde mich jetzt dann auch nicht so reizen.
Ich dachte nur, das wäre was.
Das wäre gut sein.
Ja, aber alles, was ich von Zelda gesehen habe, da muss man ständig irgendwelches Zeug machen. Also es soll halt auch nicht in Arbeit ausarten, wo du dann ständig Monster killen musst. Das nervt halt auch.
Ja, aber auch diese Trading-Dinger, wo man dann so, wie heißt das, Civilization, war das das erste, was so angefangen hat, wo man so richtig lange, über längere Zeiträume sich dann so in so...
Irgendwas entwickelt.
Ja, und dann gab es auch noch mal so ein weltraumbasiertes Handelsspiel.
Elite?
Elite? Genau, das war das, wo man auch so Handelsbeziehungen aufbauen muss und keine Ahnung.
Da habe ich drei Raumschiffe abgeschossen und dann war nichts langweilig irgendwie.
Also wenn ich jetzt so auf meine Gaming-Karriere gucke, dann gab es eigentlich immer zwei Konstanten. Das eine ist Adrenalin und das andere ist Moral. Ja, ich sage, ich führe aus. Adrenalin, das ist halt beispielsweise Counter-Strike. Das erwischt mich schon. Das heißt also wirklich Dinge machen, die man im normalen Leben nie ansatzweise tun würde, die aber trotzdem irgendwie so in der menschlichen Grundzüge...
Quake 3 Arena.
Ja, Quake war mir immer viel zu hektisch. Darum war ich...
Ja, deswegen Adrenalin.
Ja, aber ich bin dann aber schon auch sonst... Das ist dann so ein Camper-Air. Finde ich so wie ein Ruscher. Ist auch eine andere Formulierung. Nein, also das Spektakel ist sicherlich ein Punkt. Aber was mich wirklich wirklich interessiert bei Games, sind halt moralische, ethische Entscheidungen. Das geht in Richtung Story-Triphen. Und da finde ich GTA besonders verwerflich, weil man dort nie eine Entscheidung hat, sondern immer die schlechtestmögliche Variante durchspielen muss und die Entwickler das weil, haha, wir sind so anti-political correct. Ist das besonders lustig, finde ich. Ich habe da mal einen Aufsatz so geschrieben. Von der kann ich mich da ereifern. Solche Sachen wie Skyrim interessieren mich da schon viel mehr. Oder vor allen Dingen Fallout 3 beispielsweise, wo man also wirklich vor moralische Entscheidungen gestellt wird. Willst du es jetzt so machen? Willst du es so machen? Oder fällt dir noch irgendwie eine ganz andere Variante der Lösung ein? Das finde ich schon sehr, sehr spannend, solche Spiele. Davon gibt es nicht so rasend viele, aber doch irgendwie hinlänglich häufig welche. Und gut, man könnte das noch ausdifferenzieren. Also sicherlich so was wie jetzt Sachen, die wirklich sehr stark narrativ aufgebaut sind, wo man also eine Geschichte eigentlich nach erlebt, die man sich auch als Buch vorstellen könnte oder die man sich auch als Film vorstellen könnte. Aber ich bin halt irgendwie interaktiver dabei. Ist sicherlich auch interessant. Aber ich würde sagen, die beiden Sachen, die mich wirklich triggern, sind entweder Adrenalin oder Moral. Das ist das, womit man mich erreicht. Und das schaffen wir aber auch so auf der Ebene, finde ich, nur Computerspiele. Auch wenn ich einen guten Action-Film oder einen guten Horror-Film angucke, das ist mal echt was komplett anderes als Resident Evil 7. Das ist einfach überhaupt gar nicht ansatzweise vergleichbar. Und genauso ist es halt mit der Moral. Du kannst jetzt ein Theaterstück von Brecht dir angucken und hast dort auch die... Kann ich nicht.... auch Kammern und hast dort auch moralische Entscheidungen. Aber die triffst du halt nie selber. Die werden halt immer für dich getroffen. Und dann kannst du dich dazu verhalten und das hat auch irgendwie seinen Wert. Aber selber verantwortlich zu sein, das ist schon eine Ebene, die ein Computerspiel leisten kann, die auch so kein anderes Medium schafft.
Auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall, ja. Und ich spiele gerne Point-and-Click-Adventures. Also muss jetzt nicht Point-and-Click sein, aber insgesamt so dieses...
Ach, damals, Monkey Island....
dieses Zeug einfach rausfinden. Und Book of Unwritten Tales 2 ist immer noch für mich in den letzten fünf Jahren das beste Spiel, das rauskam. So unglaublich gut.
Fragen wir da alle nach links, und dann hab ich keinen, dann bin ich wieder schuld.
Du bist wieder schuld.
Ja, ich bin ja eigentlich immer schuld.
Ja, Minecraft, weil es gerade im Chat genannt wird, ist auch schon sehr, sehr spannend. Huckel hat da ja schon viel Richtiges, so gesagt, ja auch in der Freak Show. Das ist halt auch noch diese kompetente Kreativität. Was bei Spielen auch immer lustig ist, zum Beispiel widerständiges Handeln. Das heißt also, ein Spiel anders spielen, als es die Entwickler eigentlich vorgesehen haben. Das ist auch eine lustige Geschichte. Das ist ja einer der Grund-DNA-Bausteine von Minecraft wiederum. Ja, du hast da irgendwie so Sachen, aber dass du darin plötzlich irgendwie einen Logikgatter bauen kannst, ob das den Entwicklern so komplett klar war, in dem Moment, wo sie es mal implementiert haben, ist who knows, ne? Da bin ich dann eher bei dir, dann kann ich besser gleich programmieren, ja? Also ich verstehe bei Minecraft nicht die Leute, die das in diesem free, all resources are free Modus spielen, wo nichts was kostet und man einfach was bauen kann. Ich fand zum Beispiel hingegen sehr, sehr klasse, das haben Claudia und ich auch irgendwie ein paar Wochen wirklich gespielt, nachts auf dem Sofa, so diesen Survival Modus von Minecraft, wo du also wirklich gucken musst, so es wird uns überleben, aber dann ist halt wieder die Adrenalinkomponente die wichtige und nicht so die Kreativität Kreativität Komponente. Also kreativ bin ich dann eher gerne im Real Life und weniger in Computerspielen.
Ja, bei solchen Spielen habe ich so das Gefühl, dass ich es relativ schnell durch habe, weil ich das Gefühl habe, ich weiß jetzt, was da passiert. Ich habe das jetzt alles gemacht, gut, habe jetzt vielleicht nicht alle Ressourcen-Typen erreicht, aber irgendwie, und dann ist es nur noch Arbeit. Ich bin da, also ich empfinde halt Spiele, die zu repetitiv sind, schneller als Arbeit. Und dann ist bei mir der Ofen aus.
Ja, also da kommt dann sicherlich auch irgendwie der Aspekt mit anderen gleichzeitig Spielen zusammen. Also Huckel betreibt ja auch so einen Server, wo man irgendwie mit, zu mehreren etwas bastelt, ja. Es ist dann schon irgendwie nochmal eine andere Qualität, wenn man irgendwie plötzlich so mit seiner Freundin sich so das gemeinsame Heim zusammenbaut, ja, so in Minecraft und irgendwo da in den, in den Berg reinbaut und da guck mal, Schatz, was ich hier schönes gebaut habe, ja. Und auch irgendwie sehr schön so einer geht dann auf Expedition, ja, ganz lange in eine Richtung und guckt, was passiert denn dann noch so alles, so eine generierte Welt, die nie zu Ende ist und dann immer irgendwie nachprozessiert wird. So und der andere bastelt irgendwie zu Hause weiter und wartet darauf, dass der Schatz nach Hause kommt. Das ist eine Ebene so, die schon, die fand, die fand ich schon cool, ja. Also, aber das hast du dann halt auch nicht alleine. Also ich glaube, Minecraft alleine fände ich auch nur ausgesprochen deprimierender Erfahrung. So, also das lebt zum Beispiel davon, dass man es mit anderen zusammen macht. Ja, also, ne, your mileage may vary und so. Also klar, ne, jeder findet irgendwie natürlich an anderen Dingen Spaß, aber das ist jetzt so, so wie ich das wahrgenommen habe. Ja, also ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ich hab dir mal Perry Roden gelesen, so die ganz frühen allerersten Teile so. Es fängt ja irgendwie damit an, dass die Menschen auf dem Mond fliegen und dort irgendwie so eine Alien-Rasse eigentlich haushoch überlegen finden, die irgendwie in so einem gewrackten Raumschiff da auf dem Mond rumhängen. Und ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie die heißen, und kann der Chat vielleicht mal zuliefern. Und die wundern sich dann so, warum die so degeneriert sind, weil die schauen den ganzen Tag nur auf Bildschirme und dann läuft so ein Bildschirm schon. Also wie damals irgendwie auf dem Amiga so ein Intro-Generator-Fisch halt so. In der Zeit wurde es halt auch geschrieben. Und ich halte es nicht für die unwahrscheinlichste Entwicklung, die die Menschheit nehmen wird. Dass wir also irgendwie in 50 Jahren uns eigentlich große Teile unserer Zeit lieber in irgendwelchen virtuellen Umgebungen umtreiben, anstatt noch irgendwie in dieser Trump-Welt hier.
Ja, aber ist Fox News nicht das schon ohne, dass es...
Das Problem ist, die werden das dann irgendwie bereitstellen als Einzige. Das ist die Gefahr. Selbst diese ethische Frage muss gestellt werden, wer wird uns diese virtuellen Welten bauen, auf was wir Spielregeln und wird dort auch das kapitalistische Schweinesystem die Sachen vorgeben? Aber gut, das müssen wir jetzt vielleicht nicht viertel vor zwölf nicht auch noch diskutieren. Aber das sind die Fragen, die ich gerne diskutieren würde, anstatt wie viel Pixel hat der Beamer?
Tja, leider sind wir ja hier nur so ein Nerd-Entertainment-Podcast.
Ich habe zu lange keine Wiki-Geeks-Folge mehr gehabt. Man hört das vielleicht.
Das geht sozial komplett mit dir durch. Ja, aber warum machst du eigentlich keine Podcast mehr, Ralf?
Ja, die Umstände.
Die Umstände, das ist doch alles nur Ausreden.
Ja, das ist schon richtig. Aber Claudia und ich haben ja eigentlich auch noch ein lustiges Projekt im Köchern. Ja, es ist ein anderes Projekt.
Das lustige Projekt ist jetzt drei Monate alt oder was?
Ja, das steht jetzt alles unter einem gewissen Realisierungsvorbehalt. Was geht jetzt nun noch, was geht jetzt noch? Also ich war wirklich heilfroh, dass wir jetzt halt den Release irgendwie durchbekommen haben. Und dass ich mich da wirklich nachts mehr als hinreichend motivieren konnte. Aber wie das so weitergeht, man wird sehen. Ob ich dann doch irgendwie mehr oder weniger regelmäßig in Mikrophone spreche demnächst oder ob man dann doch mal andere Prioritäten setzt.
Wollen wir über rote iPhones reden?
So viel über rote iPhones zu reden?
Eigentlich nicht. Jetzt haben wir es erwähnt.
Um nochmal einen anderen immersiven Moment kurz vielleicht auch noch zu dokumentieren. Ich bin ja immer noch in diesem Wahn mit, ich kauf keinen Verbrennungsmotor mehr und das Auto, was ich da gerade fahre, das bestätige ich auch täglich aufs Neue durch seine merkwürdigen Spirenzen und vor allem auch dadurch, dass irgendwie auch die ganze Zeit so Dinge kaputt gehen mit Einschränkungen, die sich auch wirklich nur um diese Verbrennung drehen. Man merkt immer so, wieder etwas kaputt gegangen, was in einem Elektroauto nicht kaputt gehen kann, weil es da nicht ist.
Oder nicht benutzten Auto?
Das ist ein VW Turan.
Mit Diesel?
Nee, ohne Diesel.
Na immerhin.
Ist auch nicht besser, also es macht genauso krank und kaputt, also ich hab da relativ wenig Unterscheidungspotenzial. Jetzt ist gerade Diesel mal wieder ein bisschen mehr evil, weil da ist halt schon alles nachgewiesen. Aber wenn ich mir so diese ganzen Tests anschaue, die sie jetzt auch mit Benzinern gemacht haben, kann ich einfach mal davon ausgehen, nichts hält sich an irgendwelche Grenzwerte und alles ist schlecht. Also es ist einfach, es geht gar nicht. Dazu kommt halt auch einfach noch dieses ganze Prinzip, wenn man weiß, dass es schon jetzt besser geht. Also von Technik zu reden, die so in der Zukunft ist, sehe ich ja ein, dass man eine gewisse Distanz hat. Aber das ist halt nicht so. Also Elektromobilität ist real.
Sie ist da. Vor allen Dingen, wenn du dir anguckst, dass der Chevy Bolt jetzt eine 60 Kilowattstunden Batterie bekommen hat und jetzt eigentlich alle Hersteller, die irgendwo Elektroautos bauen, nicht mehr wirklich drunter können, dann weißt du, dass es in zwei Jahren auch keine Range-Axiety mehr gibt, weil dann gibt es keine Elektroautos mehr mit 20 Kilowattstunden. Akkus, das ist dann 60.
Heißt was konkret bei dem Auto?
300 Kilometer oder so.
Ja gut, das behalten sie jetzt beim Soja auch schon und der hat irgendwie 40 oder 43.
Ich glaube der i3 liegt da auch, ne?
Nee, der i3 hat eine 21 Kilowatt.
Und der kommt 350 mit Range-Extender weiter.
Ja, aber Range-Extender ist ja kein Elektroauto mehr. Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie ging es um 200 Meilen, müssten so 300 Kilometer sein.
Ja, man merkt auch, wir sind halt in diesem ganzen, also wenn man sich nicht täglich mit beschäftigt, dann zerfliest man ja schnell zwischen Ampere- und Kilowattstunden und so weiter und weiß dann irgendwie überhaupt nicht mehr ganz genau, welche Zahl jetzt wie was war. Später werden die Leute irgendwann auch nicht mehr mit PS klarkommen, was man sich derzeit auch nicht vorstellen könnte. Aber schon Kilowatt hat ja nicht funktioniert bei den Verbrennungsmotoren als Leistungsangabe.
Weil die Zahl immer kleiner ist als PS, deswegen wollen die Hersteller natürlich PS draufschreiben, weil die Zahl größer ist.
Ja, vielleicht auch. Aber ich glaube, die Leute haben sich halt an PS gewohnt. Also Kilowatt hat keine andere Qualität mit sich gebracht, außer dass du es die ganze Zeit mit der anderen Zahl verwechselt hast. Dann war das halt kulturell einfach durch. Davon unabhängig habe ich jetzt mal weiter überlegt, was denn so die Lösung sein könnte, abgesehen davon, weil Pkw gibt es ja noch viele Fragen. Kaufpreis, Wartung, Blablabla, Ladestellen, das haben wir ja alle schon ausführlich diskutiert. Was natürlich auch immer noch eine andere Variante ist, ist dieses vielleicht gar kein Auto mehr. Ich habe mal ausgerechnet, was ich pro Tag für diesen Wagen bezahle, wenn ich wirklich mal alles mit einrechne. Dadurch, dass ich jetzt schön meine ganzen Finanzen in Ordnung bringe, kriege ich ja so sagen wir mal ein bisschen Überblick und so weiter. Da kann man mal so kategorisieren und lalala. Was habe ich denn eigentlich für Geld gelassen? Reparaturen, Tankstellen, Säuer, Versicherung und so weiter. Dieser ganze Glimmbimm, Strafzettel, kommt ja dann auch alles noch mit rein. Und bin dann irgendwie schon so auf so was in der Größenordnung von 15 Euro pro Tag gekommen. Und dann schaust du dir ja an, wie viele Tage steht denn eigentlich die Karre dann auch mal so unbewegt so rum. Du bist halt mal drei Tage irgendwo weg, oder keine Ahnung, oder bist du nur im Park, oder krank oder was auch immer. Steht das Ding halt einfach nur auf der Straße, nimmt Platz weg, nimmt Sicht und rostet so langsam vor sich hin und kostet halt dabei auch noch Geld. Sodass du dann das eine Wochenende, wenn du dann doch mal rausfährst und so quasi dieselben Strecke auch hättest mit dem Taxi fahren können, wärst du irgendwie immer noch besser weggekommen und hättest noch nicht mal selber fahren müssen.
Genau, genau wie den Einkauf, den hattest du ja auch vom Taxi bringen lassen.
Ja, gut, Taxi ist dann meistens auch ein Verbrenner.
Das macht ja ein bisschen Pride.
So, jetzt möchte ich natürlich die Kosten insgesamt einerseits ein bisschen reduzieren. Also auf die Zahl müsste man jetzt nicht unbedingt kommen. Und ich weiß auch gar nicht, warum. Die ökonomischste Variante, also wenn ich jetzt so einen Wagen hätte, der nicht so kaputt ist und...
Es gibt Leute, die sagen, so nur ein Jahreswagen und dann sofort wieder verkaufen und so weiter und wieder neu und so weiter, das sei das Ökonomischste. Ich bin da auch mal ausgestiegen, aber da kann man schon andere Rechnungen machen.
Ja klar, weil da hast du halt keine Reparatur an. Das ist irgendwie alles auf Garantie. Wenn wirklich mal was kaputt ist, dann kannst du auch das Leasing-Modell machen. Dann hast du dann irgendwie auch noch so andere... Gut, da will ich jetzt gleich drüber nachdenken. Auf jeden Fall, es ist ja, seit gestern ist ja Frühling. Habt ihr vielleicht gemerkt.
Aber so was von... Kennt ihr diesen, Claudi hat mir das geschickt, diesen lustigen Blogpost über irgendwie die Jahreszeiten in Berlin? Die schmeiße ich mal in den Chat rein. Red weiter, Entschuldigung.
Naja, und dann habe ich mal so meine Mobilitätsoptionen gecheckt und dann festgestellt, dass ich ja noch ein paar Sachen hier überhaupt nicht nutze, die es in Berlin gibt. So, was ich nutze sind halt alle Carsharing-Angebote. Also ich bin bei allen Gruppen, die hier irgendwie cash... Also alle, die Peer-to-Peer machen, plus Links da bin ich.
Was ist denn Peer-to-Peer?
Point-to-Point machen, also wo du sozusagen... Karre steht irgendwo rum, fährst du irgendwo hin, lässt du da stehen. Versus stationsgebundenes Carsharing, gibt's ja, Flinkster vor allem, die halt hier feste Stationen haben. Da gibt's auch noch ein paar mehr von, da bin ich immer nur bei Flinkster. Das heißt, ich kann halt immer wählen, Drive Now, Multicity, das sind diese Elektro-Karren, die auch zum Flinkster-Verbund gehören und natürlich Kato Goro. Und da kommt man eigentlich schon immer ganz gut so zum Ziel. Es könnte alles noch mehr sein und der Bedarf ist, definitiv noch größer, also mehr Abdeckungen zu haben. Das ist immer wahrscheinlicher, dass auch etwas in deiner Nähe steht, vor allem in so kritischen Zeiten wie nachts in der City, wenn irgendwie schon alle Kar-Shering-Karren aus der Mitte eigentlich in die Randbezirke abgezogen sind und solche Sachen. So, aber jetzt gibt es ja noch etwas Neues. Es gibt jetzt elektrische, elektronisch auch, elektrische, wie sagt man?
Scooter?
Scooter. Vespas sozusagen.
Motorroller.
Motorroller, genau.
Da habe ich Angst.
Wovor?
Die zu fahren. Das hängt jetzt aber mit einem traumatischen Erlebnis auf Thailand zusammen, wo ich zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben Moped gefahren bin.
Und dann auch das letzte Mal.
Das war in Thailand eher aufregend, muss man vorsichtig zu sagen. Man kann es sich vielleicht vorstellen. Ich bin generell gar kein Motorfreund. Alles, wo ein Motor drin ist, finde ich unheimlich. Ich bin kein Motormensch. Also alles, was mehr als 0,01 PS hat, finde ich unheimlich, mich da rein drauf, was auch immer zu setzen. Also ich fahre Auto und ich flippe da auch nicht aus, aber ich habe echt keinen Spaß an Motoren und motorisierter Bewegung.
Schließt das Fahrstuhl mit ein?
Das ist weg abstrahiert.
Naja, also ich habe da überhaupt keine Angst. Und ich bin ja auch früher schon viel Vespa gefahren, von daher ist das für mich ein vertrautes Teil. Und es ist ja auch nochmal eine andere interessante Facette, weil du hast natürlich gegenüber einem Auto noch mal einen Vorteil mit den Motorrollern. Erstens Parkplätze. Also wenn du wirklich in so Bereiche fährst, wo du weißt, dass es schwierig ist, überhaupt etwas zu finden, bist ja meistens so ein bisschen privilegiert, Parkraumzonen und so weiter kannst du da mit Carsharing einfach so anfahren. Aber wenn halt partout genau da, wo du hin willst kein Platz ist, dann musst du ja unter Umständen weiter wegparken. Das ist der ganze Vorteil, schnell auch mal wieder dahin. Das ist auf jeden Fall so ein Punkt. Das ist natürlich ein Nachteil, was so Wetter betrifft. Wenn es jetzt in Strömen gießt, dann willst du nicht unbedingt mit den Jeans auf so einen Teil sitzen.
Was ist denn mit dem Helm?
Ja, den musst du halt auch aufsetzen.
Ist der da drin dabei in den Teilen?
Also konkret zu sagen, es gibt im Prinzip...
Ziebst du einen Helm auf, den 25 Leute vor dir schon auf hatten? Mit teilweise ungerössenen Haaren.
Oder ist wahrscheinlich so unter dem Sitz irgendwo mit drin?
Ja.
Und der passt dann oder passt auch nicht? Also...
Also es ist meistens so, du... Also erstmal funktioniert das halt ähnlich wie beim Carsharing auch. Du hast da so eine App und da steht halt irgendwie drauf, auf einer Karte, da steht ein Teil rum. So, dann kannst du das reservieren. Hinlatschen und dann machst du Unlocking über die App. Und dann machst du irgendwie Knack. Es gibt zwei Anbieter, muss man sagen, in Berlin. Und zwar auch mit unterschiedlichen Ansätzen. Das eine heißt jetzt EMI, das hieß bis vor kurzem noch E-Mio. Haben sie jetzt gerade umbenannt. Und das sind eher so, auch so Vespa-artig aussehende Teile, wo hinten so eine extra Box noch auf dem Träger drauf installiert ist. Diese Box ist quasi das, wo die eigentliche Elektronik-Ortung und so weiter mit eingebaut ist. Und auch so ein aus der Ferne zu öffnendes Schloss. Das heißt, wenn du das Ding unlockst, dann geht hinten der Verschluss auf. Du kannst auf den Knopf drücken, machst die Box auf. Da liegen dann zwei Helme drin, ein großer und ein kleiner. Dann nimmst du halt den, der dir besser passt. Und außerdem so ähnlich wie bei den Flinkstar-Dingern, nimmst du dann einen Schlüssel, der einen RFID-Chip hat, in einem eigenen Steckfach, dass er merkt, dass der Schlüssel da wieder steckt. Den ziehst du ab und zündest dann ganz normal das Teil, was dann elektrisch funktioniert.
Zünden ist gut in dem Zusammenhang.
Ja, das sind halt so die übertragenden Begriffe. Und dann kannst du mit bis zu 45 Sachen durch die Gegend kacheln. Ich hatte es mal ausprobiert, da kam es mir langsam vor. Ich muss sagen, ich habe es jetzt mal richtig gemietet, bin immer richtig gefahren und habe mich schnell festgestellt, so reicht schon. Also die letzten fünf Stunden Kilometer hätten sie für meinen Geschmack auch noch drauflegen können, weil so im Straßenverkehr willst du ja dann zumindest das fahren, was so erlaubt ist, so 50, wäre schon mal ganz gut. Aber ich glaube auch, umso wärmer das jetzt irgendwie wird, umso geiler wird es einfach, mit diesem Teil einfach nur rum zu cruisen. Weil du hast halt einfach keinen Lärm, machst nicht so was mit. Dem Lärm. Also wenn es jetzt wirklich nur ums Rumkrammen geht, muss man halt mal ausrechnen. Natürlich immer noch viel billiger als Taxi. Also normales Carsharing, würde ich sagen, liegt schon ungefähr so bei der Hälfte. Bis zum Drittel Taxi, hier bist du vielleicht so bei 25% bis zum Drittel Taxi. Und kannst halt im Prinzip auch eine zweite Person mitnehmen. Wie schnell der dann ist, weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob der bei 45 gedrosselt ist oder irgendwie so dimensioniert, dass er nicht schneller fährt. Und man ist dann noch langsamer. Habe ich nicht ausprobiert. Ja, aber zumindest in Berlin sind die Dinger halt zumindest im kompletten inneren S-Bahn-Ring. Also wer Berlin kennt, ist das schon so ein relativ großer Stadtraum und damit kann man also dann auch, sagen wir mal, die wichtigen Tages anfahren. Also es ist ein interessanter Ergänzungstransport, sag ich mal so. Zweiter Anbieter, der jetzt irgendwie neu ist, heißt Kuh. Das ist im Prinzip dieselbe Geschichte. Die haben definitiv die spacigeren Helme. Ich habe es ehrlich gesagt bisher habe ich mich...
Wir sehen gerade einen Hipster-Werbefilm von Innoform, voll inneren Mint ist es glaube ich, oder?
Das ist so ein Helm, wo du quasi den Sonnen- und Windschutz ausklappen kannst, aber trotzdem halt einen offenen Helm, also ohne Kinnlade.
In Zeitlupe und sehr glückliche Menschen.
Sehr glückliche Menschen, also definitiv.
Mit Tattoos auch jetzt.
Ja, ich meine, ich bitte dich, mit dem Himmel.
Der guckt jetzt ein bisschen tumm, der mit den Tattoos.
Genau, einen Pimpfelschneiser haben sie auch hier irgendwie.
Würde eigentlich lieber eine Harley fahren, aber...
Na schön, dass ihr euch an euren Vorurteilen gut anarbeiten könnt. Wenn ich euch jetzt sage, dass Q, zwar in Berlin antritt, aber nur in den Stadtteilen Kreuzberg, Mitte und Trinzlauberg, dann ergibt das alles Sinn.
Wo ist das Problem, Tim?
Ja, das ist die Zielgruppe. Das ist ja auch vollkommen okay. Ich finde das ja vollkommen in Ordnung. Wenn du halt wirklich nur diesen Cruising-Lifestyle hast, dann geht das. Ich habe mich da jetzt mal angemeldet, bin die Dinger noch nicht gefahren. Daher kann ich leider zu Performance und so weiter nichts sagen. Der Unterschied hier ist nur, dass das Fach hier tatsächlich unter dem Sitz ist. Also das ist nicht so eine olle Vespa, sondern das ist halt wirklich ein relativ moderner Elektroroller, wo schon so vieles integriert ist und wo auch die ganze Bedienung über das Display im Lenkrad funktioniert. Und von daher kann es halt auch sein, dass die irgendwie ein bisschen anders abgehen.
Die E-Mio-Roller sehen doch so umgerüstet aus, eigentlich eher, als ob die nicht extra dafür gemacht wären.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe eher so den Eindruck, die sind mehr explizit in diesen Style gehalten worden, um einfach auch diesen Retro-Aspekt noch mit dazu zu haben. Dann in so einem knackigen Rot und so. Also das funktioniert auch. Inwiefern die da jetzt tatsächlich von so einem Ur-Vespa-Modell ausgegangen sind, kann ich nicht sagen. Dann habe ich vor kurzem auch noch mitbekommen, dass Vespa übrigens selber auch ein Elektro-Vespa angekündigt hat, für im Laufe dieses Jahres.
Auch eine Ape?
Ich fasse es nicht. Was für ein Claim die haben auf ihrer Webseite, mit dem sie werben. Join Coop für einen gelungenen Auftritt beim Tinder-Gay-A-Date.
Weitere Fragen, die ich übrigens nicht darf.
Nuff said. Genau. Das musst du dir jetzt mal vorstellen. Spätsommer, 25 Grad, noch um 19 Uhr. Du mit deiner Elektro-Vespa. Du steigst irgendwie von deinem Bike. Du ziehst dir die Kopfhörer ab. Dein Gegenüber hört noch Freak Show. Natürlich. Einfach sau cooler Typ. Geile Braut, hört Freak Show. Da läuft es dann auch einfach mit dem Date.
Wunschdenken pur, oder?
Um mal was Neues beim Mittag zu probieren.
Eine Art, weil du gefragt hast, ist von Vespa dieses Dreiradding hinten mit Ladefläche, wo du vorne so eine Kabine hast. Ja, naja, anderthalb Sitzer. Es kommt drauf an, wer die zweite Person ist, sag ich mal, oder wer die erste Person ist. Aber ja, gerne als Kaffeemobil verwendet. Ja, Vespa ist die Vespe und Ape ist die Biene. Weil das Ding halt was transportieren kann. Das ist halt die Transport-Biene-Fleißige.
Verstehe, verstehe, verstehe. Naja, auf jeden Fall zu dieser Elektro-Vespa gibt es leider, die heißt irgendwie Elektro, wie heißt der das nochmal? Elektrik-Vespa. Gab es auch irgendwie Elektrizion oder so was? Ich bin einfach... Nee, das sind alles so Umbauten. Es gibt ja eine offizielle, ich habe jetzt bloß gerade, die heißt irgendwie Vespa, Electro-Electricio oder irgendwie so was. Da gibt es bisher nicht sehr viel mehr als ein Bild. Und ein Video. Oder ist das überhaupt die hier? Genau, El, Eltrika oder Elektrika? Eletrika.
Ich hab hier einen Sternartikel. Aus dem November.
Ja, genau. Also sieht noch ein bisschen merkwürdig aus, aber weiß ja geier. Es gibt auch noch keine Daten. Aber ich finde es schon mal ganz gut, dass es jetzt sozusagen auch etablierte Marken gibt, die da rangehen. Und meine Vermutung ist, der Roller ist eigentlich der geilste Kompromiss zwischen Fahrrad und Auto.
Wenn du kein Elektrofahrrad hast.
Nee, auch besser als Elektro.
Auch Dinge fliegen nämlich noch viel mehr unter dem Radar. Das ist aber inzwischen eine ganz schön große Industrie geworden, weil sich sehr, sehr viele Leute diese Elektrofahrräder kaufen.
Ja, aber dann musst du dann halt, also wenn du es regelkonform machst, musst du das Ding halt irgendwie mit treten und so weiter, also ein sehr beschleunigtes Fahrrad fahren. Ist ja auch in Ordnung, kann man ja machen, hat auch einen sportlichen Aspekt etc. Eine Vespa ist halt, also Vespa jetzt als Kategorie für Motorroller, ist halt so ein richtiges Ich transportier dich, du musst nichts tun-Teil. Aber das kompakteste und irgendwie in gewisser Hinsicht auch coolste, was auch in seinen bisherigen Dimensionen, um diesen Motor unterzubringen, eigentlich schon so ohnehin schon immer so viel Platz verbraucht hat, wo du jetzt eben auch ein problemloser Elektromotor, der sehr viel weniger Platz reinnimmst, plus eben Batterien rein kreist und mit den Dichten, die wir jetzt eben erreicht haben, glaube ich, kriegt man jetzt einen ganz interessanten Mittelwert rein. Zumal auch, und das ist auch noch so ein Punkt, wir haben ja viel geredet bei Auto, brauchst ja viel Akku und dann lädt das lange und dann musst du stundenlang irgendwo rumstehen, bevor du wieder weiterfahren kommst, um 100 km zu haben. Ich bin jetzt mal sehr gespannt, was jetzt hierfür zahlbar rauskommt. Aber du brauchst halt nicht so viel Saft, um dieses Teil halbwegs brauchbar zu beschleunigen, also brauchst du auch nicht so große Batterien, also brauchst du auch nicht so lange, um die Dinger zu laden. Und wenn ich halt so ein Teil irgendwie einmal die Woche, eine Stunde irgendwo ranklemmen muss, selbst wenn das nicht der super hyper Turbocharger ist, und vor allem steht halt auch irgendwo, ich kann sogar eine Elektrotankstelle dann benutzen, wenn irgend so ein Panel die zugeparkt hat, der eigentlich gar nicht lädt. Komme ich halt trotzdem noch ans Kabel ran. Also du bist halt einfach mit der Vespa sehr viel flexibler, also mit so einem elektrischen Motorroller, als du jetzt mit dem Auto bist und da ist dieses, ah ja, da hinten ist jetzt frei, ich fahre mal 50 Meter, das sackt auch deutlich weniger als irgendwie jetzt mit dem Auto, nochmal ausparken und kriege ich danach wieder einen Parkplatz und so. Das sind alles so Aspekte, die da noch mit reinkommen. Klar, ist jetzt nicht unbedingt für das ganze Jahr, aber ich habe einen Freund, der fährt jetzt auch einen elektrischen Roller schon seit einiger Zeit. Das ist so ein Teil, was hier irgendwie auch aus Berlin kommt, auch irgendwie so eine Crowdfunding- Kampagne gestartet ist. Vielleicht fällt irgendjemand gerade ein, wie die heißen. Ich habe den Namen gerade vergessen. Er meint, das geht eigentlich auch das ganze Jahr.
Also ich fahre jeden Tag im Jahr Fahrrad zur Arbeit, so 40 Minuten. Also das ist alles eine Frage des Equipments. Da finde ich jetzt, das ist überhaupt keine Kategorie, so Wetter, ob jetzt Best Buy oder nein. Also ja, ich sehe den Punkt, dass da irgendwo so ein Sweet Spot ist. Also ich bin auch irgendwie in zwei Carsharing-Modellen ja drin, habe jetzt selber ein Auto aus irgendwie Gründen, die jetzt ja gar keine Rolle spielen, da langweilt sich wirklich Woche für Woche irgendwie auf dem Parkplatz und passiert nichts mit. Was mich beim Carsharing derzeit einfach immer noch sehr nervt, ist gerade hier Prenzlauer Berg, Winzviertel, wenn du es brauchst, ist kein Auto da. So, das ist jetzt glaube ich schon ein Problem hier von dieser Hipster-Gegend, dass jetzt hier sowieso die ganzen ökologisch bewegten da drauf abfahren.
Aber wir haben jetzt auch die Leihfahrräder, das heißt, du kannst mit dem Leihfahrrad zu deinem Leihauto fahren.
Ja, ich habe ein super eigenes Fahrrad.
Aber das willst du ja nicht unter Umständen da stehen lassen.
Da bin ich schmerzfrei.
Du willst ja mit dem Auto wieder zu dir möglichst nah ran und kannst ja nicht davon ausgehen, dass du genau da an den Parkplatz für das andere Ding findest, wo du dein Fahrrad abgelassen hast.
Das sind alles irgendwie so krude Lösungen für Probleme, die man irgendwie anders angehen müsste. Also ich denke schon, dass Individualverkehr eine Zukunft hat, aber das muss einfach ganz anders skalieren, als es derzeit der Falle ist. Also wir müssten 70% unserer normalen Autos einfach verschrotten und durch Carsharing ersetzen. Dann macht das Ganze total viel Sinn, sehr schnell. Und da finde ich, diese Roller haben da schon einen guten Sweetspot, da würde ich dir recht geben. Also ich persönlich habe da mit jetzt ein Problem, das ist eine Sache der Übung, ich habe einfach keinen Kurs gemacht, muss halt einfach einen Kurs machen, und jetzt auch mit der Sicherheitsgefühl und so weiter, ich mache es hin, und Roller, wenn du sagst, dass du jeden Tag 40 Minuten mit dem Fahrrad fährst, dann wüsste ich keinen Anlass dafür. Also, also momentan, also unterschätz das nicht, wie absurd das ist, dass ich dieses Gas geben am Lenkrad habe. Also ich hatte in Thailand wirklich die Situation, ich schiebe das Teil, mache eine falsche Bewegung, das Teil macht WUMM und plötzlich bin ich 4 Meter weiter vorne auf dem Asphalt. Ist einfach so passiert, weil mir niemand beigebracht hat, wie du mit diesem Gas geben durch eine Handdrehung agierst.
Du bist auch das erste Mal damit gefahren?
In Thailand. Genau, das wird aber passieren, wenn du...
Ja, gerade in Thailand ist das natürlich auch.
Genau, das passiert aber, wenn du die Sachen ausrollst. Oh, das ist aber lustig, eine Vespa Odyssey, so ein Vespa, tot. Also da muss man schon ein bisschen gucken, aber ist ein lösbares Problem.
Naja, aber ich meine, du hast ja die Erlaubnis, diese Teile zu fahren, mit deinem Führerschein erworben.
Ja, aber es hat dir nicht jemand beigebracht. Also egal, ob du die erlaubt hast oder nicht.
Wahrscheinlich ein normaler 50er.
Und auch, wie motorisiert das Ding ist. Also ich hab halt noch einen alten Klasse 3, aber das heißt das jetzt irgendwie C und da ist halt dieses A1, glaube ich.
Bauer bedingt bis 50 Stundenkilometer.
Weil der Grundunterschied halt zwischen sagen wir mal, einem Verbrennungsmotor in einem Auto und jetzt so einer Vespa ist, wenn du dich als irgendwie Anfänger beim Autofahren zu schnell Gas gebe, stirbt mir halt der Motor ab und ich stehe und nichts ist passiert. Wenn ich dann den selben Stunt auf einer Vespa mache und zu weit reindrehe, fliege ich von dem Teil weg und bin irgendwie tot in Zweifelsfall.
Nö, der reißt das Teil aus der Hand. Der reißt das Teil aus der Hand, da fliegt das Ding, aber du nicht.
Na gut, aber wenn ich drauf sitze, wo fliege ich dann hin, wenn das Teil unter mir wegfegt?
Auf den Hosenboden.
Ja, wer es nicht in der Jugend gelernt hat auf dem Dorf, der braucht einen vernünftigen Kurs dafür. Ich finde es fahrlässig, Leute Moped fahren zu lassen, nur weil sie einen Autoführerschein gemacht haben. So, meine Meinung.
Ich hieß das mal, ja. Und jetzt heißt es A1. Das ist noch ein Rosa, ich hatte mal einen grauen.
Das ist ja noch älter.
Ich hatte auch einen Rosanen, aber der ist mir mitsamt meines Namens abhanden gekommen.
Musste neu ausgestellt werden. Ich wollte da noch einen kleinen Nebenaspekt. Dieser ganzen Elektro-Vespa-Sharing-Registrierungsgeschichte machen, den ich irgendwie ganz interessant fand, mal so als Erlebnis. Und zwar muss man ja dann quasi mal nachweisen, dass es einen auch wirklich gibt und dass man da wohnt, wo man wohnt und dass man halt irgendwie einen Führerschein hat.
Wie bei den anderen Verleihern auch?
Wie bei den anderen Verleihern auch, nur dass die anderen Verleiher halt in der Regel irgendwelche großen Büros haben, wo du dann irgendwie aufläufst, mal kurz deinen Führerschein zeigst, guten Tag, Dankeschön hier unterschreiben, fertig. Und dann hast du deine Karte, dann bist du freigeschaltet. Diese Buden hier allerdings sind natürlich auf maximale Kostenreduzierungen gedacht und haben natürlich nicht ein solches Büro, sondern versuchen das natürlich alles online zu machen. Und das fand ich schon sehr interessant. Vielleicht mal zuerst EMI. Da wurde man dann aufgefordert, erst mal über die Webseite, ich glaube zuerst musste man sich bei beiden einen Account machen. Also wie man es so gewohnt ist, machst du ja erst mal so irgendwie einen Account. Und dann hast du quasi schon mal so deine Basisdaten, von denen du überhaupt behauptest, dass es die richtigen sind, hast du dann eingegeben. Und dann musst du aber noch in so einen Verifizierungsmodus gehen. Dieser Verifizierungsmodus wird über Skype gemacht. Das heißt, du addest dann halt irgendwie die in Skype. Rufst da an und wirst dann halt so real mit so einem Menschen auf der anderen Seite mit Hallo.
Oha, wie unangenehm.
Das ist nicht so schlimm. Das geht gar nicht lange.
Ja, das sagte ich am Anfang auch, wobei das dachte ich... Also habe ich bei einer anderen Registration mal deswegen nicht gemacht. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr so ganz genau, warum nicht. Aber irgendwie passt mir das da in dem Moment gerade nicht. Diesmal war ich aber finster entschlossen, mich dazu registrieren, das auch mal so durchzutesten. Und war auch alles gleich so schlimm. Ich meine, das ist halt wie so Videotelefonie mit... Also das ist jetzt nicht so sehr viel anders, als ob ich da in den Laden reingegangen wäre. Ja, mit Hallo und Tralala. Und dann musst du halt irgendwie deinen Führerschein in die Kamera halten.
Naja, ich stelle mir gerade vor, dass es eventuell einige Webcams gibt, die die Auflösung gar nicht hergeben, dass derjenige auf der anderen Seite erkennen kann, ob das, was du da eingegeben hast, auch so auf dem Führerschein steht.
Naja, die machen dann halt so Spin-Shots und kriegen dann...
Auch so ein gefälschter Führerschein ist da, glaube ich, relativ einfach in die Kamera zu halten. Aber sei es drum.
Na ja, da komme ich gleich drauf. Und zwar war das bei EMI, war die ganze Überprüfung so okay-ish. Also, wenn man das jetzt so unter Sicherheits- und Fälschungs-Gesichtspunkten vielleicht beleuchtet, wäre da sicherlich auch noch so ein bisschen was gegangen. Wobei ich jetzt auch nicht so sehr sagen kann, worauf sie vielleicht geachtet haben, wo ich jetzt nicht so drauf geachtet habe, durch irgendwelche Sachen, die sie mich gefragt haben. Auf jeden Fall ging das dann irgendwie dadurch relativ schnell und dann war man halt auch schon freigeschaltet. Bei EMI muss man dann auch eine Aufnahmegebühr zahlen, die einem nur so zum Teil noch in Kilometern erstattet wird. Da gibt es so irgendwie zwei Tarife. Bei Q wiederum, und da merkt man, dass hinter Q offensichtlich ein größeres Unternehmen steht, ich habe leider gerade vergessen welches, aber das hat schon sehr viel mehr Mobilitätsstrategie. Also dieses EMI ist so First Mover und dieses Q ist schon, das mit den Rollern nehmen wir ernst, wir bauen da jetzt auch mal was auf. Das heißt, die kommen nicht nur mit einer App, sondern da ist es dann auch die App selber, die halt dann diese Videokommunikation herstellt. Das heißt, du verlässt gar nicht die App, du machst da irgendwie deinen Account, über die App kommt dann der ganze Kontakt zu und das ist im Prinzip ähnlich. Und da ist ja dann auch vordere Kamera, hintere Kamera, also alles, was sozusagen das Telefon, also da wird sozusagen sehr viel mehr schon auf die Videokommunikationsmöglichkeiten der Telefone gesetzt und da sind die Qualitäten halt ausreichend. Trotz alledem, da waren sie auch noch ein bisschen mehr hinterher, dass ich den Führerschein auch so kippen musste. Links, rechts, um Wasserzeichen, Elemente zu sehen, das war bei EMI auch, aber bei Q wollten sie noch ein paar Bewegungen haben, die da jetzt noch nicht nachgefragt wurden. Also muss schon richtig so Wasserzeichen und dann gibt es auch auf der Rückseite des Führerscheins, das ist das Sicherheitsmerkmal, das mir selber noch gar nicht aufgefallen, bis dahin. Also du hast ja diese generelle Glitzerwelligkeit dieser Oberfläche und dann auf der Rückseite der Führerschein hat ja hier irgendwie so eine eingepresste Nummer, die aber auch so als Wackelbild ausgelegt ist. Also das wechselt immer zwischen so Verkehrszeichen, Symbolen und der eigentliche Nummer.
Du meinst dieser Silberstreifen?
Nein, hier links neben dem Ding. Ja, und sowas lässt du dir dann halt zeigen und dann bist du halt auch freigeschaltet. Wie gesagt.
Ja, aber mit so einem rosa Führerschein?
Ist die Frage, ob sie den online überhaupt akzeptieren würden?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, ne?
Das weiß ich nicht, davon stand da jetzt nichts geschrieben. Ich meine, das ist ja ein gültiger Führerschein, kann man ja jetzt nicht sagen.
Was ist das denn für ein geiles Blies?
Nein, das haben wir nicht gewettet. Ja, nee, das wird nicht gehen. Der hat ja auch gar keine...
Naja, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Wenn Eurostadt auch irgendwann mal solche Dienste in Anspruch in Anspruch nehmen anbietet, dann macht das doch mal. Und hier kommt gerade ein Passender, Link Bosch, genau das war das, was dahinter steckt.
Zum Thema Autos sind immer weg, bei mir um die Ecke. Quasi 20 Meter von der Haustür entfernt haben sie ja jetzt eine Ladesäule hingebaut, da steht immer nie jemand. Nur irgendwie so alle zwei, drei Tage lädt da ein Drive Now i3. Also im Prinzip habe ich fast immer irgendwie ein Auto vor der Tür stehen. Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Ja, in meiner Straße auch. Aber ich, also umso, ehrlich gesagt, jetzt wo ich es die ganze Zeit nochmal durch den Kopf gehen lasse, während ich hier rede, ich glaube diese Elektro-Roller-Nummer, also ich bin ein bisschen gespannt auf die Reichweiten und so und auf die Ladezeiten, aber ich glaube, das ist...
Nimmst du dann auch deine Kinder damit? Oder wie machst du denn das dann?
Das ist nicht der Use-Case. Genau, der Use-Case ist nicht alles Mögliche. Der Use-Case ist... Einkaufen fahren...
Tinder Date in Kreuzberg.
Also für mich zum Beispiel ist Mobilität in Berlin auch immer nachts ein Thema. Du hast so Nachtbahnen und so. Aber das ist mir dann zu anstrengend, weil ich dann unter Umständen spät erst loskomme, 20 Minuten später fängt die Veranstaltung in der C-Base an, dann willst du dann noch mal schnell hin, da ist das irgendwie cool, entweder auf Carsharing zurückgreifen zu können oder eben auf sowas, oder eben auch über ein eigenes Gerät, was aber vielleicht im Idealfall nicht im Idle-Modus die ganze Zeit 15 Euro pro Tag verbrennt und deswegen ist es halt eine coole Option, so mit der Vespa, weil meistens hast du nur eine, nur dich zu transportieren, du kannst aber halt auch mal eine zweite Person damit transportieren, passt halt, zweiter Helm, zack, passt einfach rein da und ab geht er da, Peter.
Ja, also generell, also ohne, dass es noch endlos jetzt verlängern zu wollen, also man muss aber auch schon die Frage stellen, so ein bisschen poppt das gerade auch im Chat auf, so also ob das Fahrrad als solches denn nicht, aber auch irgendwie einfach, also selbst in der nicht I-Variante, vernünftige Variante ist.
Also für mich die letzten 25 Jahre ja, aber so.
Also ich fahre halt auch 90.
Du fährst mit dem Fahrrad nicht die Geschwindigkeiten hin.
Logisch. Das kommt ein bisschen aufs Fahrrad und deine Fitness an, würde ich sagen. Also 30. Ne, mit 50 sicherlich nicht, aber wo fährst du in Berlin denn schon mit 50 durch die Stadt? Also außer halt irgendwie nachts. Ja, aber dann kannst du auch mal zehn Minuten länger fahren und hast noch was für dein Body und deine Fitness getan. Musst du dich weniger beim Joggen verausgaben. Also ich meine sie die Rechnung mal so.
Also ins Fitnessstudio damit.
Ja, genau. Also ich meine ernsthaft so. Also für mich ist mein Fahrrad meine letzte Versicherung, dass ich nicht komplett irgendwie mit Bierbauch verende.
Ja, da kann man auch laufen.
Nee, das kannst du in Berlin nicht.
Klar.
In Berlin kannst du nicht laufen. Nee, dann bist du wieder mit irgendwie U-
Du fährst mit der Vespa in den Wald und dann läufst du da. Ja, das ist aber echt ein Punkt, weil dann kannst du mich total erschöpft auf deiner Vespa sitzen und nach Hause fahren. Das geht dann mit dem Fahrrad, ne?
Ja, gut, also ich meine, da kann ja jetzt jeder...
Mit dem Fahrrad kommst du halt direkt dann erschöpft zu Hause an.
Also ich glaube, wir können festhalten, dass es einfach mal gut, dass es diese zusätzlichen Optionen gibt. Ich sehe da generell ein Sicherheitsproblem. Ich würde Unfall-Statistiken auch mal interessieren. Roller?
Wahrscheinlich ganz weit unten.
Dürfte. So im Sinne von am meisten Tote, ja? Am unsichersten?
Die meisten Tote sicherlich bei den schnellen Motorrädern mit den Heinichsen mit 150 über der Landstraße in der Kurve mit Donnern.
In der Berliner Innenstadt.
Das Gute ist, mit der Geschwindigkeit eines Rollers kannst du halt einfach auf der Hauptstraße fahren, da kotzt dich halt kein Auto an. Also das kenne ich nicht. Du wirst auf Motorroller, wirst so halbwegs ernst genommen. Da hast du deine Spur, da drängt dich keiner ab. Das ist nicht so wie ein Fahrrad. Also nicht, dass ich finde, dass man so mit Fahrräder, Fahrrad umgehen sollte, das auf gar keinen Fall, aber einfach die Realität ist anders. Du bist als Motorroller mit der Beschleunigung und mit der Top-Geschwindigkeit hast du kein Problem im Autoverkehr flüssig mitzufließen. Klar, du musst natürlich auch noch aufpassen, aber das musst du generell. Also ich finde, Roller ist ausreichend gleichberechtigt, um überall mitzufahren. Du kannst halt alle Straßen damit fahren, die nicht Autobahnen sind, das ist schon ganz okay. Thumbs up für Roller! Und ansonsten kann man machen, würde ich sagen, streben wir mal das Ende der Sendung an, oder? Ja, weil jetzt haben wir uns schon richtig durchgequatscht.
Vier Stunden sind voll.
Vier Stunden sind voll. Divers, divers. Insofern, will noch irgendjemand ein letztes Wort richten an irgendjemanden?
Auf gar keinen Fall.
Auf keinen Fall?
Muss nicht.
Diese Euphorie, wie sie sich baden bricht. Heiko?
Ich habe noch eine Literaturliste für Windows-Programmübungen aus den 90ern, aber die kannst du ja nicht in die Show Notes packen.
Ach, dann würde ich sagen, gucken wir mal. Da ist ja auch der Autosound hier. Vielen Dank. Das war's. Die Freak Show. Deutschland hat auch gewonnen, habe ich gerade gesehen. Insofern, alles super. Es war uns ein Fest. Viel Spaß auf eurem Tinder Date.